foreign
I have started sharing my screen once
again I hope it is possible to everyone
[Music]
thank you
all right we'll be starting uh with the
presentation in just five minutes
and meanwhile we are waiting it would be
great if the participants who have not
introduced them till yet uh to introduce
in the chat so that we know about
background research interests
and thank you so much Daniel for uh
interacting with the participants and
you're welcome
[Music]
hello
yes uh Daniel we'll be starting in four
more minutes with my presentation we are
waiting for rest of the participants to
join
okay
[Music]
all right so uh we have the test
Muhammad Abdul Rob and he is the student
of biochemistry and molecular biology uh
thank you so much for introducing
yourself uh can you also let us know
about your research interest
and what about the rest of you I'm
curious to know about you as well I can
see that several participants have just
joined with us it would be great if you
can introduce yourself as well in the
chat
sorry are you referring to me
uh sorry who is this
my name is
um
could you please also let us know about
your research interests
my my research interest is in the area
of environmental health
um
issues
what are the latest prints or what are
the latest issues in the environmental
health
area
how did you get interested in the field
of bioinformatics and data science
I'm curious to know
uh well thank you for that that question
there is a friend of mine who is into
bioinformatics and we've discussed
extensively so much and I see a Nexus
between this area and my area of
research and um being a researcher uh
which is a multi-disciplinary researcher
uh I tend to explore new areas like by
informatics so that I can see where
I can contribute to knowledge especially
in the area of the media
popularization and awareness creation so
that's that's my major area that's my
major interest in this
all right thank you so much that was
pretty uh good to know about and uh can
you also let me know
um how would you rate your bank medical
data science skills are you a beginner
or are you already familiar with the
field
uh well I can I can just say I am a
beginner because uh starting or probably
I have a few or
um very few background in it so let me
just say so that by the time I now
upgrade it starts getting exposed to
um this area then I can now pick or
develop myself in that in that direction
foreign
for introducing so um I'm curious to
know about the rest of you as well uh
please feel free to interview with
yourself in the chat with your
educational background and research
interests just like uh updated so with
that let us start with today's Symposium
let me first turn on my camera
okay so hello everyone a very warm
greeting to one known it is my great
pleasure to welcome you all to omix
logic so to begin with we must ask why
biological data analogy data analysis is
an essential component in any bioparma
or healthcare industry data analysis in
biology has already moved out of the
domain of conventional statistics and it
is expected that a student of biology is
acquainted with basic concepts of modern
data analysis tools
biological data analysis also has
practical applications in healthcare
Agriculture and mitigating climate
change and as this field progresses
biological data analysis possess several
challenges for both students trying to
learn it and faculty trying to teach it
so how do we at home exologic tackle the
institutions we'll get to that initial
well so before we begin with today
Symposium let me overtake a brief moment
to introduce you to the team behind the
program
we are a us-based by informatics company
who is working with multiple academic
and Commercial collaborators to develop
easy to use analytical tools and our
mission is to meet by informatics more
accessible
the omic Strategic Training has been
completed by over 24 000 participants
from 187 countries in over 300 workshops
and due to this fast Road our team is
working with local and Regional
coordinators that are helping refine
local program Logistics and leveraging
our online training resources adapting
them to the needs of students and
researchers around the world this
training has been completed by
participants in six different
specialization tracks that includes
oncology infectious diseases Precision
medicine Neuroscience data science for
biomedical data and comprehensive
training on omix data
and in this presentation I will explain
the current challenges and limitations
in biological data analysis
describe how we aim to address these
challenges for the women's logical
portal describe Bloom's taxonomy for
learning progression and how it can be
used in biological data analysis
coursework explore the online storage
portal and how it utilizes Bloom's
taxonomy in structuring its coursework
Pipelines
projects and finally describe several
outcomes of the omics logic code
so what are some of the challenges that
the field of biological data analysis is
currently facing
so to begin with this field is
constantly growing and developing new
technology and software to improve
processing time and Power
the data types that are analyzed are
usually very large and take immense
amounts of computing power and memory
that many personal computers do not have
also despite being publicly available
data are also usually complex to access
and coding knowledge is usually required
to do so similarly analysis pipelines
and programs require coding knowledge
that many biologists do not have and in
a university setting students have the
opportunity to learn the background
information of Designing and
implementing a biological data analysis
project but they do not receive
practical hands-on experience with the
full workflow due to the limitations
mentioned previously similarly faculties
faces the challenges with being able to
cover a diverse range of topics if they
are specialized in a certain area of
biological data analysis or if they are
unfamiliar with data analysis in general
for example a professor whose research
focuses on oncogene expression might not
know about the meta genomics
so to overcome these challenges the
women's logic Hotel was developed this
aims to standardize organize and
systematize by informatics training in
order to make these analysis usable for
any biologist or clinician
there are some traditional problems with
the standardization of bioinformatics
coursework that is materials for courses
are usually developed in-house not
sporadically and are rarely updated the
omics larger portal introduces new
material that keeps up with new
technology and these courses also need
to be organized because the challenge is
to combine several different topics
together the flow and transition between
the subject also need to be developed
this is addressed at omits logic through
introductory material being woven
throughout the coursework the last
challenge we face is systematization
so how can you know that someone is
stuck and needs help or allows someone
to run forward
so to address this Comics logic uses
standardized modules and interactive
sessions beginning with mastering Tech
terminology and Concepts to implementing
these concepts with real data sets in a
project-based
so here is an overview of the learning
progress that takes place at omex logic
in order to create a clear path of skill
development who makes logic employees
for blooms taxonomy levels of learning
so to those of you who are not familiar
with this this approach starts with the
basics that the students report facts
and terminology and they are able to
repeat and memorize the material with
this paste the learning based conceptual
knowledge being able to understand
Concepts and apply information to new
situations
the students will then be able to
analyze data by drawing connections and
evaluate when to use certain method this
leads them to the highest level of
learning that is the ability to decide
and create or generally
so how do omixological resources help
Advance these above mentioned points
omic's logic is supported for practical
and theoretical learning or biological
data analysis it is composed of courses
designed to take you through the
theoretical knowledge
Comics logic takes a combination of
training modules data analysis tools
curated project data sets and
interactive sessions with mentors to
give the student a clear path of the
gloom's taxonomy pyramid
and no matter what the user's initial
experience with biological data analysis
is omix logic is going to be a very
useful tool for gaining a baseline
knowledge of the theory behind
biological data analysis analysis of
large data sets and introduction to base
reporting languages like R and Python
Programming or even beginning a data
analysis project
so here are some of the courses that we
have on the portal these seven courses
were taken from the core omics logic
curriculum available online
so beginning with an introduction to the
application of biological data analysis
and an overview of data types the
student is able to learn terminology and
factual knowledge to build upon
from there genomics Comics metagenomics
epigenomics data science and chem and
chromatic concepts are introduced
each course starts with important terms
and Concepts and then introduces case
study and pipelines related to each one
this allows the students to gain the
conceptual knowledge in order to begin
their their own projects
omix project expands upon these basic
curriculum with specialization track
projects biological data analysis method
are best done in the context of real
case studies prepared by our network of
mentors and collaborators that
illustrate how various biological data
analysis matter and omox data types are
used in current research in medicine
biotechnology Agriculture and even
astrobiology
the projects are prepared by taking
publicly available data sets and using
them to explore and understand both the
research Challenge and the analysis path
to extract meaningful Insight from
complex books data
the omics larger portal also gives
students an option for analyzing a given
data so there are code dependent path or
that are called independent
these data sets and Associated
Publications can be used in several ways
for instance you can learn biological
data analysis without any coding at all
and for that in each project we explain
the analysis pipelines on the
user-friendly T by info platform for Big
Data analysis which I'll be introducing
in my next slide you can also learn the
scripts behind many of the steps
learning to Wrangle clean visualize and
analyze data in popular languages like R
and Python Programming in order to
create your own analysis
finally you can hear about the projects
and the research applications in our
mental guided programs where experts
share their expertise and support
research project that is developed by
you
so here is an example of the code
independent type the pipeline Builder
interface on the T by info platform it's
a color coded pipeline that establishes
a logical connection between the
technical names of data analysis methods
and The Logical texts needed to build
pipeline
so first of all the data is put in as an
input file and then analysis can be
chosen based off the type of research
that you want to carry out and each
analysis is separated into three
colorways you have blue for
pre-processing red for mapping and green
for quantification and each time you
click a particular algorithm a pop-up
will show up that contains additional
information that is useful for building
the pipe
the ease of the color-coded buttons
allows the program to be run without any
coding information an interactive output
allow easy visualization of the data and
several demo pipelines with real data
sets are available for students to
practice the workflow including demos on
genomic variant calling of cancels
headline 15 amplicon analysis diet and
its effect on the microbiome and even a
pipeline examining phylogenic
phylogenetic analysis of Ebola
so after using the TV info platform to
visualize the pipelines and practice
analyzing students are then able to take
their knowledge remember the understand
levels of two and then apply that in a
project
here can be applied analyzed and
evaluate levels of the Bloom's taxonomy
that I was talking about in my previous
slide then check the comprehension with
levels and badges certificates of
completion and test similarly faculties
should be able to assign the omics
portal to their students with
understanding that it will give them a
holistic and comprehensive knowledge of
biomatics beginning with bytes molecules
and on to designing their own question
based product
the omics logic also employs a hybrid
approach
I'd like to request the participants to
read yourself so that thank you
omixologic employees a hybrid approach
combining learning and research to
ensure that students are building off of
the first levels of rooms taxonomy opens
logic fact progresses with activities
that pipeline coding and literature
reviews quizzes on topics key terms and
important questions and covers a broad
range of topics like biomedical research
biotechnology and agriculture then
students are able to continue their
knowledge base with the research
assessment making sure that they are
able to understand the methods
challenges and results as well as being
able to comprehend primary research
literature and recreate the methodology
they should also be able to ask
questions based on the data exploration
that they carry on this leads to the
ability to encounter errors in their
analysis apply theoretical knowledge of
why those errors are occurring and
finally find a solution to it
biological data analysis combined life
science terms with data science skill
which allows researchers to answer life
questions with reproducible data
analysis method
so now you might be wondering what comes
after all the training and completion of
the coursework the answer is
possibilities are endless so to begin
with a majority of the students who
enroll for the programs are focused on
publishing their research work so for
instance a biomedical science graduate
student who worked on existing the
underlying visa for development of gray
matter lesions in multiple sclerosis
species the transcriptomic level went on
to publish work
in immunogenetics which is an Open
Access Journal that focuses on the
genetic research areas of autoimmune
disorders such as multiple sclerosis
pneumatoid arthritis
and another interesting student
publication that I want to share with
you all is
a genetic engineering student he studied
the effect of malaria vaccine on the
transcriptional profile of patients to
determine its efficacy and understand
the molecular mechanisms underline the
protection this vaccine provides he also
went on to publish his work in genomics
and informatics Journal which is the
official Journal of Korea genome
organizations
presently just like to bangka and would
be we have several other students who
are working on their publication like a
biotechnology student she is working on
transcriptomic study of cancer treatment
on patients and its ever and it ever
effects leading to relax
like her we are looking forward to
several other Publications from our
current students
further you also have the opportunity to
participate in post presentation
competition such as as part of the omics
research Symposium that we are having
now to win exciting cashbacks
experts from all around the world
the student projects are not just
limited to graduates doctorates or post
doctors for instance
a high school student at Mexico
president his Neuroscience project at
the region around international science
and engineering there for which he won
the potamkin prize and the fourth award
in the biomedical and Health Sciences
category
and this program can also be integrated
as a part of existing University
curriculum for instance find biotech
offered the machine learning for
biomedical data python course which was
integrated into the system medicines
graduate program at Georgetown
University the lecturers were prepared
considering the interest of the
programming director to address the
challenges that is relevant to clinical
application biomedical research and of
interest to the industry including big
Pharma and biotech costs the training
ended with students submitting their
research projects on the omic large plan
portal so I would like to request all of
the participants to take a look at it
I'll be sharing the link in just a while
and you will come across several student
projects on infections with these
Neuroscience psychiatric disorder
oncology machine learning and so on and
these are very inspiring to look at uh
that students have carried out these
and these projects can also be showcased
for higher studies and International
University applications like some of her
research fellows for example there are a
typing she got accepted to the
erasminded imbrc program in Marine
Biology Drew Barack or Advocate to a
Precision medicine graduate program at
University of Manchester and Anusha ta
just recently got accepted to PhD
program in metagenomics at a university
in Sweden
so faculties and researchers have also
collaborated through our training
programs to publish their research work
and our latest collaboration have been
with a team of researchers at noguchi
Memorial Institute of Medical Research
at University of karna and They carried
out a computation-based study to
understand variants associated with
Alpha Doctrine in plasmodium plasma
and it is also possible to pursue an
entrepreneurship on business Innovation
track just like a team of Industry
researchers from biology Support
Services a biotechnology company in
Nigeria their aim is to improve the
fertility of women in Nigeria and
improve their chances of carrying their
babies to term by developing a test kit
the entrepreneurship track is not only
pursued by researchers but by students
as well for instance a group of
undergraduate and postgraduate students
worked on developing a early detection
kit for early detection of neurological
disorders with a specific focus on
Alzheimer's disease
so now if you are interested to learn
more about where these courses are and
how you can view videos with various
student projects that have been carried
out I would like to direct you to owning
software important it is free and easy
and free for anyone to register with
many courses available at no point so to
view the various courses example
projects and student projects you need
to first sign up on the own strategy P1
portal before that let me walk you
through a brief demo on what a completed
program on the portal looks like
so once you sign up on the portal these
are the features that you need to update
on your account that is a completed
profile will have a profile image full
name with appropriate capitalization
link to your social media handles and a
brief BioWare airport that will consist
of your education background and
research
and as you can see under the activity
tag the mentors can view your programs
the courses you are currently completing
will appear under the courses tab
finally after the completion of your
coursework the certificates will appear
under the certificates
that was all about that I wanted to
discuss in this presentation with that
let me walk you through on how you can
sign up on the omic search clone Hotel
I'm sharing the link in the chat box for
the participants sorry
the participants who have not signed up
yet to sign up and explore the various
project and courses that I was just
discussing in my business
and if you have all these kind of on the
portal please put a yes in the chat box
so that I know that
you have already an existing account on
the portal
all right so for those participants who
are joining with us for the very first
time and want to get started by signing
up on the portal you can click on the uh
create an account option that you see
here first visit the
learn.omexlogic.com sign up link and
then click on the create an account
option and once you click here you will
be asked to enter your name email ID and
password
you can either sign up using any of this
method or you can also sign up using any
of your social media
so this could be your Google account
Facebook account GitHub account Apple
account or even Twitter
so I'll pause for a couple of seconds if
the interesting part is still wish to
sign up so that they can snap and uh
all right I do have couple of years in
the chat
if you are facing any kind of technical
issues while signing up please let me
know our team is here and we'll be happy
to look into it as well or if you want
me to explain any of these texts that I
was just searching about signing up
please let me know that as well and I'll
be happy
so with that I'll just pause for a
couple of seconds to sign up and then we
will resume the card
navigation
thank you
all right I can see a few
yes in the chat box I'm so I'm hoping
that I can proceed ahead so that
I can show you how you can
so since I already have an account on
the portal I'm just going to click on it
okay now I have uh entered my existing
email ID and password and I'm just going
to click on sign in
so once you sign in uh you are paying
the courses page so here when you scroll
down below you will see a search bar
that says looking for its specific words
so here if you are to enter your key
area or research interest so for example
we had apartment who was just mentioning
that he's interested to learn about
bioinformatics but he seems to be a
beginner so for such uh beginners I
would like to direct you to uh
interactive courses on buying addicts
such as when I enter the term
introduction
it will show me the very first course
course one introduction to
bioinformatics so this is a very free
course and I would like to encourage all
the participants who do not have a
previous uh knowledge of why informatics
to take it so this course on biological
data analysis is an introductory course
that covers the topics of big data by
informatics and its uses in basic
research Healthcare and biotechnology
and pharmaceutical industry and the
topics are arranged into three segments
as you can see here the where it was let
me focus is on Big Data biomatic then
biomatically Healthcare and translation
binding so let me just open one of the
lessons and then show you each of these
ports were comprised of a different type
of content and video tutorials quizzes
assignments and even interactive visuals
so you can take a look at it at your own
pace and navigate and
take a look at all of the courses that
are there
so another pre-inteructory course that I
want to direct you to is the course to
bytes and molecules so this happens to
be one of my very favorite cores on the
portal since it introduces you from the
very beginning by uh introducing you to
the concepts such as citizen science
molecules data analyte code of life and
then the course focus on particular
topics structural biology genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics and my
favorite one happens to be the fave
omits one which
um comprised of several interactive
video tutorials from astronauts
explaining their work and even linked to
some of the publicly available data sets
that the participants can take a look at
so that is one of the courses and I'm
also noticing that there are several
participants Among Us who might be
interested to learn about Python and our
program so for such participants who
want to get started in this field I'd
like to direct them to python course one
getting started with bi-informatics
so this course is uh covers the
introductory basic fundamentals of
Python Programming from teaching you how
to import practices such as numpy and
pandas to reading DNA sequences using
python code to calculate genome-based
frequency and even creating uh reverse
conflict so whether you are from a
biology or from a computer science
background this course will help you
equip with the required bioinformatics
skills to help you get started in Python
coding and at the end of the coursework
students will be able to create write
and execute python functions and even
create very beautiful data visualization
using python
so that was all about my coursework and
I'm also um assuming assuming that there
might be participants who might be
interested to learn about our program so
for such participants we have the very
first coursework that is our course one
getting started with
so this course is for those participants
who want to learn to how to load data
and visualize it alkaliers analyzed
normal sequence and find patterns that
can help us interpret the language of
DNA RNA and protein and the course also
introduce basic concepts in our data
structure and on working with a unique
type of data sequences so that is all
about that I wanted to uh show you about
the courses apart from that there are
several intermediate coursework that I
encouraged participants who already have
a prior background knowledge of find
management Expo so for instance if you
are someone who is interested to learn
about genomics then I would like to
write you four three genomics and if you
are someone who is interested to learn
about transcriptomics then I would like
to break through the course by transport
comics
like this way if you type any of the key
areas of research interests that will
increase learn more about that will show
up so apart from the coursework you can
also see several example projects that
have been taken from high impact
research applications that break down
simple that breakdown research work that
has been carried out by other scientists
in simpler terms so that it is beginner
friendly and for those participants who
want to get started in research will be
able to understand how they are carried
out so that is all about navigating to
the courses you can browse through it at
your own pace and
now I'd like to take you to the uh how
to set up your account settings so to be
able to do that once you sign up you
will see a blue bar that is welcome back
with your email ID when you click on
this it will directly take you to your
account setting so here if you want to
click on the button that is profile
you will be able to edit all of the
features that I was just talking about
in my presentation so that includes your
name make sure that your name has to be
in proper capitalization then the third
page will be printed out and uh you can
add a bio about yourself that will
consist of your educational background
and research interest and you can add a
social media link as well and upload a
group connect so once that all of that
is complete it will be showing to file
completion as Unwritten
so now you will also see the activity
tab like I mentioned where the program
mentor and the community manager they
will be tracking your live programs on
the portal the courses tab will keep a
track of all the courses you are
currently enrolled in as well as show
the coursework progress that you're
making
and under the programs tab you will see
several uh ongoing programs that must
have included and finally once you
complete the required coursework with
Associated assignments answers you'll be
able to receive all of the certificate
something certificates
and finally one interesting uh tab that
I want to show you is to click on the
projects tab as you see here so this is
the place where we have all the
collection of student projects that I
was explaining about in my presentation
and these topics range from oncology
infectious diseases Precision medicine
Neuroscience data science
and some of these projects have also
been published so you can take a look at
all of that and explore at your own pace
so that was all about that I wanted to
introduce the participants too about the
image logic flow and platform and
training so with that uh let me
introduce you to the uh today's omic
research symposium
the omics research Symposium is a
two-day online event aimed at bringing
together network of experts Educators
and students from around the world to
learn from each other interact and
discuss advances in the field
discussions will highlight challenges
involved in research using computational
tools for Big Data opportunities in this
outputting field and applications of
advances in various fields so today we
have the opportunity to hear from 18th
experts from all around the world above
their groundbreaking research and I'm
certain that their talk will leave all
of us with a great appreciation of the
importance of biological data analysis
and the need for further research in
this area so without further delay
please join me in welcoming our very
first teacher doctor
has over 12 years of research and
Industry experience he completed a
masters in bioinformatics
and PhD in computational biology
and he is an expert in machine learning
in application through biomedical and
chemical data he is currently heading
the global business development for
buying biotech USA and contributing to
biological data science research and
education by collaborating with
universities in India and Africa and
mentoring participants from various
programs by providing research
and today he'll be introducing us to The
Omen Sergeant Asia and how it is working
to advance biological data Science
Education in the region and with that
brief introduction now I would like to
pass on the stage to Dr Mohamed
overdues
[Music]
so it looks like you're on mute
oh I'm sorry uh thank you srigori for
the introduction and telling me that I
was on mute and uh it's great to see you
all here today with us
I'm really excited every year we prepare
and wait for this time for our omics
research symposium
to be able to meet with you and learn
from the experts in the field of
biological data analysis for research
and uh industry or business so for many
students it's an opportunity to compete
uh showcase their research work and get
recognitions and prizes
so I hope
um you all are as excited as we are to
hear about these cutting-edge approaches
and Life Sciences as well as challenges
not just from our team
but from experts who have spent their
entire lives struggling with these type
of challenges and more importantly
coming up with great Solutions
um also it is uh great to see a much
broader appreciation of data in life
science domain as well as a great
excitement about the potential impact of
biological uh data analysis
bioinformatics on areas touching the
likes of everyone so medicine vaccine
design genomic surveillance and even
space travel and space omics so at omics
logic our mission is to simplify
bioinformatics and advanced research
through these different modules that
srivari was just showing you and the
intuitive multi-ohmics research platform
we are working with students researchers
and we are providing research support
and also working on several research
projects
for biomedical drug Discovery and uh
well-being of uh and Healthcare and
well-being of human beings So eventually
or the ultimately we are working for a
future where we can contribute to him to
enhance human health and well-being by
enabling biological research and
Discovery with relevant Data Solutions
support
um that's our
journey and in that Journey uh I'm
really happy to have an amazing team
with us and I wanted to use this
opportunity to briefly introduce our
team who will be who will be there in
the chat and who will be helping you
with any of the technical challenges
that you might be facing in the next two
days so since 2019
uh we have launched omics logic in India
with initial collaborations at several
universities where we piloted our
training and worked with faculty to
develop programs that addresses these
major gaps in uh biomedical data Science
Education uh and since then we have been
working with students from partner
universities going through the training
and project work and faculty who are in
who are who have showed interest in
utilizing the collaborative research
platforms and collaborative Workforce to
incorporate project-based biological
data science and curriculums and coding
curriculums into there into their
coursework into the students training of
undergraduate postgraduate pre-phd
pre-trainings and all so
so in India it has been a thrilling
journey and this experience has enabled
us to work on variety of challenges that
comes with any educational training
pertaining to translational research or
pertaining to something that has been
not so much well established so when we
started we were we were facing a lot of
challenges in terms of awareness of
umix research awareness of data and data
science so with that agenda to bring
awareness about data-driven Healthcare
research
our team reached out to universities and
our agenda was to able to our um our
offerings was to able to uh provide a
computational infrastructure and um
cleared curriculums that the faculty can
use and the resources to be able to uh
get high quality data-driven research
accessible to everyone like
undergraduates postgraduates PhD
students which is one of the biggest
challenges in bioinformatics uh doing
high quality bioinformatics so this
engagement has helped us collect data
and tremendously improve our own
learning models so today I will be
showing you uh some of those outcomes
from what we have experienced in Asia in
our programs in Asia so after many
programs coordinated with universities
and thousands of students from India
we saw that there is a gap in skills
that helps students to effectively
integrate into a research experience and
thinking more critically about data uh
and applying appropriate analysis
methods to the right data so to address
address those gaps we came up with our
educational collaborative model where
every student we think needs to be
enabled with data skills and Analysis
logic to succeed in their research excel
in their career and be ready for the
world of data that we live in so schools
universities colleges how they are
needed to be equipped to help faculty
and students learn and use this data and
um as I'm saying this uh I we we
understood that it's a it's a massive
responsibility on our hands that can
only be accomplished by an ever-growing
Community it's just something that we
cannot do alone and that's why we need
all of you to be able to do uh work
towards the similar goals that would be
helpful for any nation and even the
entire world so our appreciation to all
our academic Partners who have come
forward and join hands to bring the
awareness the tools and the technology
and an international standard to the
training and research in biomedical data
science so in this presentation
I'll explain our initiatives and
highlight the Partnerships and
collaborations from omix logic
bioinformatics and data science training
in Asia and this upcoming expert
sessions and discussions on day one of
This omix research Symposium and uh we
will be discussing about the university
training programs that we recently did
we will start with from there and with
this entire one hour is mostly dedicated
to an introduction and to Showcase uh
how these different types of educational
and research awareness is going to be
very helpful in the future to develop
capacity
so after learning from our experience
and working with universities in India
we were able to start a new chapter in
Bangladesh and uh this this was a new
challenge that our team has taken up uh
after the university reached out to us
with their interest and it was
interesting to know that the genomic
Center in in Joshua University which is
a very renowned University in the short
Bangladesh is uh is kind of now going
into more detailed sequencing groups are
right now they have used a lot of rtpcr
and generated a lot of data from there
during the covet pandemic and have the
centers and now they are going for uh
sequencing capabilities and they were
interested to learn and bring that
capacity to be able to utilize
sequencing capacities capabilities with
the right kind of analysis and outcomes
so um what we did is that we kind of uh
wanted to incorporate also uh the
learnings or the curriculum terms that
they have developed at Joshua University
integrating with our own curriculums
that we are going to offer which
includes statistical analysis methods
and visualization use of machine popular
use of popular machine learning
techniques which srivari was showing you
in the previous presentation uh so
students were able to learn about public
data repositories and various file
formats bioinformatics for storing and
efficiently processing omics data and
also the topics from the University that
focuses on you know the rtpcr analysis
phylodynamics and protein modeling so
this was an integrated program that we
recently completed
and in this program
um the great thing about such programs
is that the collaborative effort of both
the team members are both the teams and
both organizations help students to
really get the most out of this so we
had a collaborative team of faculties
from buying biotech and um Joshua
University helping students go through
this entire experience and make the most
out of this so over 100 students joined
this program and uh over 50 students
completed it with very high points and
many of them under the rest of them were
able to start and still are progressing
through the mixed logic Community
similarly I mean in India as I already
showed that we have been working with
several University partners and we had
this opportunity to work with a group of
faculties so uh honorable Vice
Chancellor Professor Deepa Sharma at
iimt University meerut and assistant
professor Dr vatsala Tomar help students
with this industry Academy partnership
to work collaboratively and integrate
modern and Industry approaches in
healthcare and biomedical research and
using this interdisciplinary skill set
of different departments at the
University and developing a research
ecosystem but all of this talks with uh
with the faculty so we did recently A
Faculty development workshop and in that
faculty development Workshop which is uh
which is to help faculty to come up with
different types of
research areas integrated into their own
research so our University training
programs are recognized by some of the
top research and educational
institutions in the U.S and we are glad
to bring this high quality and effective
experience to those who are interested
to work collaboratively in Nigeria in
India in other countries where we can
have a collaborative framework to be
able to do this and sustain all of this
so This Workshop series are focused on
powerful scientific data generation
techniques and also some of these
techniques which we were really going to
deep uh we deep dived in is next
Generation sequencing data analysis uh
and also uh the publicly available data
that is helping a lot of like at least
thousands of researchers in Discovery uh
to translational research so uh we
covered the basic technician sequencing
process where uh like where we discussed
about the fragmenting from fragmenting
DNA RNA sequences into multiple pieces
to Bringing to adding adapter and
sequencing and libraries to be and also
uh which is more focused on different
types of data that you would generate
for cancer for infectious diseases for
Neuroscience giving an idea of these
risks how big data is integrated into uh
into uh day-to-day research that one
could be able to do with the capacity
that we were able to provide
this year we extended our community by
starting to work with departments
interested in applying Big Data analysis
for pharmaceutical research and
Innovation and that's where we
collaborated with sniper Hyderabad to
assess the students of pharmacology and
Pharmacy to be able to integrate Big
Data analysis like genomics and
transcriptomics into their uh Research
into their Project work so a group of
students from btec from bachelors and
Masters joined the program and completed
the training on genomic data analysis
and transcriptomic data analysis under
the guidance of mentors from Pine
biotech as well as Dr vasundhara
bhandari assistant professor and Dr
shashik Shashi balasing Director of
National Institute of pharmaceutical
Education and Research in Hyderabad
so uh we had a lot of programs that we
were able to do in some of these areas
in Hyderabad uh including a government
City College and uh going back to the
relationships that we have already
developed and continuing developing
these programs for our partners who are
open to integration of Industry relevant
training and development for their
undergraduate and postgraduate Life
Science Education to provide job
opportunities and internship
opportunities uh we were we went to
Amity Jaipur we met with their students
and their faculty and we were able to do
some workshops for the students from
biotechnology
bachelors and Masters and I'm taking
biotechnology food technology and
microbial technology and applied
sciences who are eager to learn about
genomics metagenomics and how different
types of omics data could be used in in
food technology and Agriculture and we
also had that opportunity again to uh to
work with the administration at the uh
at the uni at Amity University where the
emphasis on uh was to do a code
structure so how industry related
courses can help students to directly
integrate with the industry once they
finish their uh degree what would be the
delivery plan uh how the course will
have what kind of learning outcomes will
the course will have what would be the
program are learning outcomes how this
will be mapped with the Amity and
external contributors and would
facilitate in research and development
so we had Round Table meetings we had uh
panel discussions where in where uh
different like uh
industry experts came and help students
understand that what they need and also
on help the university understand that
where the need is and what kind of
technology and courses are required for
students to be able to go and get those
job opportunities which are really
available in the market
so um that's uh about Rajasthan so in
Rajasthan we had an amazing opportunity
that I wanted to show you all and talk
to you all about which was partnering
with some top research and academic
institutions in India to develop
training and development programs for
working professionals as well as for
students to upskill and integrate more
modern data literacy and expertise so we
recently collaborated with IIT jodhpur
Department of biotechnology biosciences
and bioengineering where we collaborated
with Dr pankaj yadav Professor mittali
Mukherjee and we met the students and we
interacted with them and we had a lot of
discussions about different types of
projects that IIT jodhpur and these
students are working on collaborating on
metagenomics research and other research
which are relevant to harsh environments
in the Thar Desert and also working on
new projects that would be or that would
be about the capacity development in
India in this area of Next Generation
sequencing and its application uh so uh
this led to something really uh new uh a
new program that we have envisioned and
we are going to start in the summer
which is a certificate and diploma PG
diploma program from IIT jodhpur uh in
collaboration with Thomas logic Pine
biotech and Primus Life Sciences where
there's this uh this Delta where there
will be an opportunity for students to
not only learn the data science part or
data generation or how to analyze data
and interpretation but to also do the
wet lab experiments to the data
generation and also learn from the
experts in IIT jodhpur and pine biotech
in an intensive six month certification
and one year diploma course and that
would prove and which would enable
students to get job opportunities and
get into created with some of the
partners who will be there in this
program so it's something that we're
really excited about and we are hoping
that we'll be telling you more about
such opportunities so that's about
Rajasthan and I wanted to take you
um it's from Rajasthan to little above
uh Punjab so we have a wonderful uh
experience collaborating with
universities in Punjab and we have a
team they are working in Punjab
including our team members who are
present here uh spurge Mr nalika wojiswi
and uh and we and akshita and we have
been able to reach out to some of these
universities do online and on-site uh
web uh on-site
um classrooms classroom studies and
workshops and the focus of such
collaborations vary from University to
University based on the need of the
University so these modules that we have
been showing you and these the modules
that we have been developing in
collaboration with researchers are being
utilized by University departments or
University students or a PhD student
based on their own research interest so
the focus with Chandigarh University uh
cgc Land Run is to be able to provide
basic bioinformatics training to finally
your students who are who are working on
research projects so our team at
Chandigarh facilitated the ceremony
there and helped with that means help
the admination administration to start
the hybrid bioinformatics training and
research
um similarly
and we were really happy to start
working with Punjab University and we
have been connected with Punjab
University for the last three four years
uh trying to uh trying to work with Dr
Ashok and their other collaborators and
recently we collaborated and and
recently we are working with the
Department of microbiology where uh our
Focus would be metagenomics analysis to
be able to help the uh the students who
are going through microbiology
um on us so that's one program and
another with the Department of
bioinformatics to be able to help them
with Next Generation sequencing data
analysis and interpretation using
machine learning and data science tools
for model generation so these are some
of the important uh areas that Punjab
University focuses on and uh and they
have asked us to collaborate and help
develop up these cutting-edge programs
for their students so another aspect for
us to be able to do this is to be able
to help students with opportunities
which are Beyond Education and Training
which is more relevant to job job
opportunities so we keep on doing as
industry Academia meets with the
university giving opportunities to the
students for a job as well as internship
and connecting them with the network
that we represent being an International
Community to be able to go for higher
education in some of the top
universities or go for for an industry
experience internship or a job
opportunity which which they are
eligible to so our team has been meeting
and going to these different uh events
helping students to develop such uh such
a career in their
in there after completing their degree
so um I'm continuing to continuing this
with other universities so we also
collaborated with Chandigarh University
and they their focus was to help the
biotechnology and computer science
students who who are doing uh
undergraduation and post graduation life
science degrees to give them an
opportunity to work on
um bioml and also learn about data
science application in art and also to
do uh biomedical data science in Python
because the computer science students
they are really fascinated with how the
application of computer science is now
such a big application of computer
science is there in uh in life sciences
so from application development to data
wrangling to data transformation all of
that is something that really interests
the computer science departments and
that's why this collaboration and and
understanding how to write and execute
your course and use Jupiter notebooks
and start doing uh exploratory analysis
and do different types of data sets
using Google collab and uh you know
check those codes and make sure that
these uh these all of these components
are related to some objective that uh
that is either translational or has some
research Noble nobility in it so that's
one of the reasons uh that uh the uh
that we have been working with these
different universities that actually
describes a pipeline so that's like
coming towards the end of my
presentation I would like to show you a
case study uh so this is with Amity
University uttar Pradesh and this is the
pipeline that we have developed and
designed uh so it's a multi-departmental
pipeline which includes uh it starts
with the technology training like the
Next Generation sequencing and as you
saw in Sri guys presentation and learned
about different types of Technologies
like chem informatics Health informatics
NGS and then data science so this is
technology training and then it involves
like different stages in technology
training so you learn about uh you know
gene expression then you learn about
differential gene expression then you'll
learn about machine learning how all of
these are different stages and steps so
there are Advanced Training steps and
then there is research specialization
where your interest is maybe Precision
medicine maybe oncology maybe
Neuroscience infectious diseases
agriculture metabolic diseases and AMR
whatever public repositories uh data
that is available there is some
bioinformatics application or value that
we will be able to extract with that
idea we wanted to show that with uh with
the incorporation of Faculty here we
will be able to work and use the student
capacity to work on Noble projects and
showcase them in Symposium such as this
and in this entire process we are able
to provide the career Pathways and this
entire pathway includes you know going
through the developing skill sets for
people who are just interested in
developing skill sets for people who are
interested in research and higher
education and job opportunities so there
are different career Pathways that we uh
that we that came out of out of this
like finding a lab for academic purpose
working with a team in an industry in
academic internship and job
opportunities which are relevant for
these fields and uh the companies that
are working on these fields and the
academic Labs that are that are
researching in these fields and as well
as entrepreneurship opportunity like the
hackathon that
um that srivari was showing you so all
of this effort is through constant
meetings and discussions with
Administration with effectivity with the
director with the VC with the assistant
assistant professors who have initiated
these conversations stations initially
and have helped us build this
relationship and develop different types
of projects so we saw some patterns
which I wanted to show you quickly that
uh students who are going through this
initially had some ideas but their ideas
got more and more defined they use a lot
more new uh projects and topics they
will they used a lot of there were a lot
of students from different types of
backgrounds and it it is kind of
becoming easier for students to now do
this and go through this in a structured
manner which is otherwise very
challenging considering how the world of
bioinformatics is and it's it's open
source many of the things are free but
to navigate through it you need
experience you need expertise so it's a
structured way to go through this
navigation and get a starting point and
then explore by yourself so this is not
something that is something that makes
you dependent but it makes you aware and
it makes you ready for the future and to
take up new new challenges in research
and in in in the English in the industry
and we are really happy and we're really
glad to have been partnered with many of
these international national
collaborators and uh we are happy to uh
happy to be a part happy that if you if
you are interested to be a part of this
community uh which is helping with data
awareness and uh helping reaching out to
more students will definitely uh will be
something that would be helping for
capacity development as well as the
importance of Health Care in our life so
uh including our industry Partners I'd
like to thank all of them for coming on
board and helping students with this
opportunities that they are bringing
with the connections and contributions
so with that uh I'd like to invite Steve
again uh before that I'll just tell you
that uh we did the hackathon and this is
a example of how industry is going to
attributing to all of this working on
these relevant topics that are important
for the market and then trying to come
up with a minimum viable product using
research so we have other industry
partners and this is my presentation for
tomorrow where we are focused on
industry partnership and how industry is
helping in and contributing in in
healthcare and in in bioinformatics so
uh with that I'll just conclude my
presentation and I'd like to ask srigori
to invite the next speaker and let let
us know if there are any questions I'll
be happy to answer them answer them in
the chat
let me just quickly share my screen
all right so for those participants who
missed the session right now uh let me
just quickly summarize the topics that
were discussed so uh this session was
designed to introduce the audience to
various online storage programs in Asia
and Dr Mohit nazundar shared his Insight
on recent collaboration with Joshua
University and iimt and even providing
customized curriculum for night
iit.org and Punjab University
and how these efforts are Bridging the
existing industry Academia Gap in
biological data science research and it
so thank you so much Dr Mohit and if the
participant any of you are interested to
uh participate in the partnership
program please feel free to reach out to
us um I would like to request uh uh
um Symposium moderator to share the link
the program page so with that let me uh
introduce all the participants to the
next session by Dr Andrew Lynn so as we
all know the ongoing covid-19 pandemic
has had a profound impact on public
health worldwide and the development of
effective vaccines I guess Sarah spoke
to have been a critical step in
controlling the spread of the virus so
with that building on the building on
the insights and knowledge that we gain
from the very first session about
ongoing biological data research and
education in Asia I'm excited to
introduce you to our next speaker Dr
Andrew Lynn Dr Andrew Lin is currently a
professor at the pool of computation and
integrative scientist at jawaharlal
nehru University where he has been a
dean and coordinator of the center of
excellence in computation biology and
bioinformatics as well as director of
communication and Information Services
he has served on the board of studies in
bioinformatics at Bernard at Hindu
University
Central University of South Bihar and
pondicherry University his areas of
research are predominantly in
computational biology biomedical Digital
Science where he works on the
development and deployment of
computational methods applied to
biological sequence structure and
systems analogy without further delay
let us in welcome our distinguished
guest Dr Andrew Lin as he takes the
stage to discuss his work on modeling
sequence evolution in the sarscope to 5
protein and its implication for immune
escape and vaccinated
uh thank you uh just give me a minute
let me see whether I can share my screen
okay I'm sorry it looks like some
portion of the window may be cut can you
hear me yes sir you're perfectly Audible
and we can see your presentation as well
okay fine so let's get started but uh so
the title has already been read out and
uh so let me go straight away into the
talk uh from the title the focus is on
using bioinformatics Methods at the
level of sequence and the structure of
the spike protein and the bottom line is
where we're looking at immune escape and
trying to see whether we can predict the
next sequence which can be used as a
potential vaccine
so as a brief introduction to the spike
protein this is the protein and this is
the structure on the top is a schematic
view of the sequence and where it has
domains so it's made up of two major
subunits one called the S1 subunit shown
in red and gold over here which has a
n-terminal domain
a receptor binding domain and it has the
S2 subunit which we're not too bothered
about at the moment it's involved with
membrane Fusion so on the top right of
the screen which may be hidden is the
idea of why we are working on the spike
protein when you have the virus the
spike protein is on the surface and
therefore the only protein that is
really visible to the host immune system
it binds to the host receptor as its
primary aim which is to the get into the
host cell the S2 receptor and therefore
the S2 receptors this receptor binding
domain so that would be the initial
focus of what we are looking at now the
structure has a sequence and the
sequence has these various domains
now the work on the SARS scope to be
over the last three years is basically
encompassed or enveloped all of Indian
and Global Science
and here are some three major papers
which talk about this term immune Escape
so they are in big journals the science
there is plus pathogens and the title
over here is essentially what I'm
talking about it's already about two
years old the SARS scope two variants
Spike mutations and immune Escape so if
we already have this work published why
am I talking about it nearly two years
later
so the reason I'm doing this is that
there's a credible amount of work that
is being done on the spike protein but
our aim is not just to Monitor and
analyze existing data but to try to use
that particular data to predict how the
sequence is evolving and predict the
next sequence of SARS the future
sequence of stars so that we can prepare
for it before it comes so that's the
real Challenge and that's the kind of
predictive data science that we're using
so this is the protein
to summarize what we are trying to do as
an objective of this talk what are the
residues responsible for
the protein stability and its fold
the proteins function which is
essentially what will the residue is
responsible for binding to the as2
receptor
and the protein and the residues that
are recognized by antibodies and which
need to be mutated to avoid the antibody
response and therefore what we call
mutations responsible to escape the
immune system or the residue is
responsible for immune Escape now when
we have this information can we use it
to predict the sequence of the next
variant for example if we had Alpha Beta
etcetera State could be a predicted
Delta before it came on if we have all
this information up to a micron can we
predict the next variant now if we can
do this the sequence can be used as a
vaccine for a future infection for
example especially in the United States
not so much in countries like India you
have an annual influence of vaccine
so the strain that was used or available
in the previous year is used as the
vaccine now what we are trying to do is
to actually preempt this can you use the
information that is available from
previous trades to predict what will be
the strain that's going to be the
Infectious agent of the next year and
therefore Prime the population with that
okay so the first thing is uh how do you
predict the residues responsible for
fold and for function
uh this is really from a little bit of
dated work two papers from my group
which is from
2010 and 2011 and plus one and then plus
computational biology so these are
methods which can be used to predict the
proteins
uh fold and functional residues now this
is a schematic which shows you what I'm
trying to talk about on the top left is
a protein structure and I'm going to
reduce the talk from a research level
talk to something that may Encompass
even people who come in from a
background who just want to know what
bioinformatics is but there is a lot of
research level content in it so you'll
have to please excuse me if I skip over
some things but very briefly this is a
structure of a protein and the shape of
the protein is responsible for being
able to detect what it can bind to which
is the substrate so the protein that is
in consideration over here something
called a protein kinase by wearing
residues around what we call the active
site you can change its recognition for
a different substrate but the overall
protein shape Remains the Same you also
have a different kind of protein this is
called the Tim Barrel structure where
you have the evolution of various active
sites in different locations now now why
am i showing you these structures the
structure shows you how the function of
the protein is performed at the level of
individual residues but actually what we
have is the information at the level of
the sequence of residues and this
information that the sequence needs to
be mapped to this structure
now what we can do is take a number of
protein kinases in this case I've taken
for instance four different families
shown over here in four different panels
and they give you examples of the kind
of residues now you won't be able to see
the residues exactly so just look at the
color coding when you have a color that
is common across all four families now
that is a protein residue in the protein
that is conserved across all four
families however if you have a substrate
specificity
uh determining residue they would be
conserved only in one sub-family and
differently conserved in a different
family okay so what you have is you have
a conservation in one sub-family and
differently conserved in another family
so if you have this kind of data that is
given to you as human beings we can look
at it and Visually find out by scanning
through these various columns that I
want to have this kind of a column that
is conserved across the entire protein
family and those that are conserved
across sub families separately and can I
determine this so these are methods that
I'll discuss in the later stage which
I'll show you about now what you have is
that we can score this using these
methods
and we have a score that can detect a
protein that is a residue that is
conserved across all of them another
score which we'll call the re function
which I'll describe in the course the
next few slides which can be used to
detect these so you see when the re
function is higher than the re
fold which is the pink color
then the residue is conserved
differentially in one sub-family and not
in the other
similarly if we have the dim battle kind
of format you have a conservation and
you don't have anything necessarily
conserved or maybe even a gap in that
particular area so it's only conserved
in one sub-family even in this case the
score that we have for the re function
will be higher than the fold and those
that are conserved otherwise the other
are sequences which are not really
responsible and something that are space
filling so I'm only looking for in the
course of this sequence I want to be
able to score the protein residues which
are responsible for the fold and then
for the function so how do I do this so
the first step is that we take all our
sequences and we build it into a
multiple sequence alignment and then we
use a model of the multiple sequence
alignment called a hidden Markov model
and for this we use a method from
information Theory called relative
entropy which can be used to detect the
fold specific residues so this method
simply scores the probability ability of
occurrence of a particular residue in a
particular column
and divides it by the expected
probability so this is a relative
entropy score which is an information
theoretic score and for those of us who
are not too hazy about mathematics we
can just simply remember that when this
divided by this when these two values
are equal this reduces to one
so if the expected probability is the
same as the observed probability we get
log of 1 and this tends towards zero
however if this expected probability is
much higher than the sorry the expected
probability is much lower than the
observed probability we get a very high
score over here so when we get high
scores for residues that are conserved
this score
or this method can be used to be able to
score columns which have residues which
are highly conserved
now how do I get the other kind which is
the functional specific residue there's
a simple tweak of this equation so
instead of taking the entire probability
of occurrence in one column I take the
probability of occurrence in what sub
family and then the probability of a
currents and the other subfamily so I
get two of them now if we have this Pi
XY such as this residue is the same as
this residue like I said earlier the
score reduces to zero so it's no longer
going to score residues that are
conserved in both but however if a
residue is conserved in one sub family
and differently conserved in another
subfamily this score is going to be very
high so you see the cumulative relative
entropy score
can be used to determine differentially
conserved residues so when we apply this
together and I put and I score each
column together it's called re context
essentially we just use a statistical
method to be able to
combine and see which one is higher or
lower for example if the cre is greater
than the re then this re context is the
cre otherwise the re context is the
negative of re fold the y direction is
negative because the negative scores now
come up at one level of the distribution
the positive scores come up at the other
level of the distribution and then we
can just use a cut off to be able to
identify which residues are responsible
for the fold and which residues are
responsible for the function of this
protein and the other residues are not
responsible for anything responsible for
either fault or for function so now when
I have my sequence of my protein and I
stack it together with other structures
and sequences of structures which are
very similar to this I will now be able
to score these two and score each
location on the sequence to be able to
identify whether the residue is
responsible for its fold or its function
so here is what we did with the spike
protein this is the raw data
this is a set of proteins from various
organisms now this is the clade of SARS
cove2 this is the SARS scope one which
is the earlier pandemic
and these are other proteins which cause
in various other animals
the same kind of sars-like infections
all of these bind to the ace2 receptor
there are also other Spike proteins from
other viruses which do not bind to the
spike to intercept so what we have now
is we have two multiple alignments one
corresponding to spike proteins which
bind to
the S2 receptor and the other Spike
proteins which do not bind to the ac2
receptor and by using those two methods
that I had just described we will be
able to score and identify which of
these residues which is conserved across
this subfamily is either conserved in
this or differently conserved in this
subfamily
and these are the results
uh I think the slide is slightly offset
so we'll come back to it in the course
of the
sequence so on the x-axis is the
location on the receptor binding domain
they're approximately about 200 residues
on it most residues don't have an
involvement in either maintaining the
overall fold or the function a few of
these residues shown in their location
over here in the sequence and mapped to
the location in the structure
is
highlighted in two different colors so
these are the residues which are
receptor binding residues now why are
they important for us because if we
design some sort of a monoclonal or a
nanobody that can attach preferentially
to this we can block its function or
binding to the S2 receptor that's the
first case because these residues can
are forced to be invariant if you have a
loss of these residues or a mutation of
these residues then you lose S2 binding
functions or binding to the receptor on
those functions so these are the most
critical residues that are responsible
on this receptor binding domain
excuse me
okay so that's the first goal done we
can identify which residues are
responsible for binding to as2 and which
residues are responsible for maintaining
this overall structure both of which are
critical for the overall functioning of
this protein
okay so let's move to the next step now
the next step is not just simple
sequence analysis of the protein the
next step is to use genomics what is my
aim now my aim is now to look at all the
sequences that we've had from Alpha Beta
gamma Omega Delta no Micron and there
are millions of sequences and to evolve
some sort of a workflow which I realized
by listening into the previous session
you will have some sort of an
understanding if you go through the
courses and the tools that are provided
by this platform so we develop these
ourselves and we run them on ourselves
so there's this data pre-processing
which is essentially what was called
Data wrangling in the earlier talk so
you take all this data there are
millions of sequences we use a tool
called nukema which takes the protein
sequence of that particular section maps
it to the original sequence and we have
nuclear alignment annotation of these
and you have the assessment of variance
and the mutations so these tools will
map the variant or the mutation in a
particular sequence compared to the wild
type and we have this information for
the millions of sequences Each of which
is tagged to a particular
sequence which is you can now tag them
as which variant they belong to
so this is the canonical data that is
available from The Who website how do
you define a various strain so the alpha
beta this is the technical terminology B
Point 1.1.7
Etc but let's use the Greek alphabets so
we have major strains which are the
alpha beta gamma the Delta which caused
a very big pandemic disturbance in India
and a micron which is now the prevalent
strain which is post vaccine
as well as newer variants so for micron
and these are the various mutations that
are used to define the variant and these
are canonical ones so do a
does our analysis first of all give us
this and what additional information do
we get because these are just canonical
ones that are described by who so by
using this method on these millions of
sequences we can map them out the graph
over here shows the spike protein
sequence which is in this is the
nucleotide sequence so the numbering is
a little different but it's a it's a
originally around a 1200 odd residues
and the location at which this mutation
is present and when it's right up to the
top which is at 100 percent the entire
strain has these mutations
at 100 but we're not just looking at the
hundred percent because that's used to
define the mutation we're also looking
at those which have come up and also be
able to map them out in terms of time
and the location that they are present
now one of the things that you could
look at this graph is that Alpha Beta
gamma and Delta show a natural
progression in the evolution of these
strains they don't necessarily move from
alpha to Beta Etc they could have moved
from the wild type through various
trades before they became dominant
strains but this did not have
any
immune response to them now after Delta
most of India for example was vaccinated
and therefore the O Micron strain that
came up as a post-vaccine strain so most
of these mutations would have
had to occur
to escape the antibody response to the
wild type protein okay
[Music]
all right
okay so uh essentially what we do is
monitoring and mapping out this data is
the first stage and being able to put it
down onto the structure also shows us
these various locations so if you
remember from the earlier schematic this
is the location of the various domains
on the sequence the important one is the
receptor binding domain also important
for now for immune Escape is the
n-terminal domain which is visible on
the surface over here so when we map
this you can see most of them are really
white and therefore not too important
but there are some residues which are
responsible and which are colored up
over here and which are found and as you
can see also from this there are very
few with Alpha few with data a few there
are much much more with a micron which
had to mutate extensively to be able to
become a dominant strain since most of
the population in the host that it was
infecting had been immunized so these
now this also gives us two types of
mutation when you look at the mutations
at the top which are exposed to the
immune system these are have a selective
pressure these don't have a selective
pressure because they are not exposed to
the immune system they are embedded
within the membrane so we can also use
this information which I'll describe
later in the talk to be able to identify
how to get positive selection for immune
Escape so these are all mutations that
are present on the protein which are
involved with having to detect a new
antibody now just look at the schematic
because if you want to get we read a
mathematical model but if we like
visualizing data here's it on a
structure which is what we've been doing
now for 50 or 50 odd years what happens
is that when you have the wild type
protein which looks like this ice cream
in White in vanilla you have mutations
in the alpha first which come up which
don't cause too much of a disturbance
and then you have more mutations
that are coming in now you see that a
number of mutations on the same terminal
from the beta are also present in O
Micron the Delta was a far more uh a
virulence strain and it had a few
mutations which could have been
responsible for virulence not the focus
of my talk but these are the mutations
that have come up on top of these
visualization now all of these would be
small mutations that are present in
locations on this sequence okay now what
I'd like to do is use this information
to be able to predict on the sequence
what would be the next residue in what
location on this protein so that I can
get the next strain from a micron all
right so this is the second part of what
we've done where you use genomics
information and you'll be able to
identify from this genomics information
what is the mutation rate what is the
type of mutation and what are the
residues that are present on the protein
so once we've finished with this the
data that we get which is the mutation
information we can do two types of work
with it the first is if you take a
mutation table along with the
frequencies separately for each of these
variants and you use the structure of
each of these variants we can map these
mutations and predict Spike epitopes
because of the tool called disco top
from the structure so from the structure
if you use this tool disco toe You can
predict what will be the epitopes on the
structure and overlay the variant
mutations on that to identify their
particular rate of immune Escape so
here's a bit of it I'll read it out
actually I'll leave it out maybe for
some in the interest of time because
it's simply some information about what
we have as we saws go to spike protein
it's exposed at the surface and it is
key to infection now what we are really
interested at this stage of the talk is
that an epitope which is known as the
antigenic determinant is the part of the
antigen that is recognized by the immune
specific immune system specifically by
antibodies and from B cells or even by T
cells now the T Cell epitope prediction
is slightly different but you can
integrate it into the metal because what
happens is that the protein is sometimes
digested and there are smaller parts of
the protein that are exposed onto the
surface of antigen presenting cells but
the B cell and antibody recognition is
on the primary protein so the epitope
can be determined directly from the
protein structure
so when we identify these B cell and T
Cell epitopes on the protein and then we
map these mutations we can see which
mutations are going to detect can be
detected and overlay on that that block
the antibody response Against the Wild
type protein then overcome the antibody
response Against the Wild type protein
the antibody that was generated from the
wild type protein can no longer
recognize the mutated protein if it is
mutated in those locations now this is
the result of the and antigen epitope to
describe the result on the x-axis is the
location of the sequence they're
approximately about 1200 residues for
the spike protein and you have a score
for the epitope propensity in a location
on the residue and what we have mapped
over here is an overlay of the mutations
that overlay with the immune Escape so
you have on the wild type this has
colored up
mutations across all of them why this
slide is important but the coloring is
to show you that a micron has lost an
area
that is present over here around 180
position number 1980 there's a loop that
disappeared in the overall structure and
that is why one of the principal reasons
why the antibody response that was
prepared from the wild type which was
used as the original vaccine no longer
has much of an effect on the o Micron so
you see there's a very very strong
correlation shown over here with these
red lines between where we have
mutations and where we have areas which
are
epitopes now why is this important from
a data science perspective I don't need
to look for mutations elsewhere they may
be responsible for other things such as
virulence susceptibility transmission
Etc but for binding and for the
recognition by the immune system these
are the residues that are critical so we
need to focus
only on this
and then we'll be able to detect
locations and residues which can be
responsible for immune Escape so uh this
is a result which is a different way of
showing showing what was earlier
presented this is the actual data that
is present in the O Micron which was
shown in an earlier slide and it shows
you
the overlay with the earlier slide with
these structures there could be
a mapping from this
the coloring is not very easy to make
out so let me just describe this what we
have is with the oh Micron protein
the sequence shown over here will map to
the various domains so for instance if
I'm looking for the N terminal domain
I'm looking at the location from about
13 to 305 and for the receptor binding
domain from this region now you will see
that there's a region over here which is
towards the end of the receptor binding
domain which is highly epitopic I mean
antigenic which is which has a large
number of epitopes and so is a region
that is just below it so this is the
region that we need to focus on and they
are colored up over here from the
mutation rate so a micron has mutations
in most of these regions that are mapped
as you can see 339 348
Etc most of these regions from 400 484
in these regions that are responsible
for immune Escape so what we've got so
far is that you take a classical
sequence analysis method by
strains from various organisms of the
spike protein and you overlay them and
you understand the protein structure
then you take the sequences of the SARS
scope to itself in the last pandemic
millions of them and again identify
mutations using standard genomics
methods and using standard analysis
methods now once you have that kind of a
data you can also use an evolutionary
analysis because what you have is
mutations that are happening the tool
that is commonly used over here is HiFi
and you can identify sites which undergo
positive and negative selection using
what they call fixed effects likelihood
and both of these will correspond to
what we will call significant sites now
here is the example of what we are
talking about essentially a
non-synonymous mutation which is a
mutation which changes the amino acid it
directly directly affects protein
function which influences the fitness of
an organism
mutations that leave the amino acid
sequence unchanged are synonymous
mutations
now under negative or purifying
selection less fit non-synonymous
mutations accumulate more than
synonymous mutations so essentially if
you have negative or purifying selection
what we call purifying selection you
will have
uh more of the
non-synonymous mutations and then the
synonymous mutations however when you
have positive selection or diversifying
selection which forces the protein to
mutate far more then the inverse is true
so what we need to do is have a method
which can monitor a rate of
non-synonymous substitutions and
synonymous substitutions and there is a
score that is made by the program HiFi
it's well known in the theory for now
nearly 40 years and you have a ratio
which is one of these the non-synonymous
mutation divided by this Anonymous
mutation and it's a standard measure for
selection so there are two types of
selection you can classify over here the
positive selection or the negative
selection and if there's both of them
are equal if the rate is the same then
it's neutral Evolution okay so if we
take all this data together and we
qualify the kind of mutations that we
are getting in do non-synonymous
mutations and synonymous mutation or
rather purifying and diversifying
mutations we can see that we have a
mapping of the kind now we've reduced
the kind of mutations that are present
in the spike protein to a much fewer
number that are responsible for the case
that we are looking at which is for
immune Escape
okay so this is where we were now let's
move to the last stage of what we want
to do because it's not just mapping and
identifying residues we want to use this
information to be able to predict what's
happening now the classical ways of
doing data science would be to build a
classifier because if I have this kind
of variant information I can build a
classifier so give me a sequence and
I'll be able to tell you what strain it
belongs to by building a classifier
based on the variations that are present
over there a second type of classifier
would be able to predict sites
responsible for immune Escape both from
this kind of information now what we'd
like to do is look at forecasting the
next level of sequence which is by
regression now this is not easy to do
the reason is that the longer a protein
the more the number of potential
sequences that be generated by this this
is just a theoretical exercise to tell
you this because each location can have
20 different amino acids and therefore
you have this many number of
combinations but this is not really true
why because in the past methods that
we've used we first of all reduce this
to a number of sites it's not just the
overall protein length that we are
interested in and we've also reduced
this to what type of amino acids are
available and allowed and the earlier
residues that were already used cannot
be reused so we have methods that we can
use now when we are dealing with this in
terms of time
you can't necessarily pick up the
residues because substitution and
reversion is Now hidden from your data
but now we have time based data so we
have both this residue and we can map
out both substitution as well as
reversion so what we'd like to do is
build a model which we can convert and
in this case we can convert it into a
continuous regression model so this tool
has been developed and available on
GitHub by Eric Eric it's uh the link is
present over here it was used for
influencer and we modified it slightly
for using with the cell scope too so
this is what essentially what happens uh
just as everyone in the world now knows
about chat GPT chat GPT is a large
language model which is called a
generative AI model so what we are
dealing with here over here is also a
generative AI model but instead of
dealing it with large languages we've
fed in uh the previous information
present on the sequence Evolution and
trying to ask whether it can predict the
next sequence and this is known as a
variational autoencoder so you have a
discrete to continuous conversion and
you have some sort of a scaling that is
done this is a schematic and this is the
code
so you essentially variational
autoencoders are unsupervised learning
techniques which leverage neural
networks for representational learning
now there are specific type of feed
forward neural networks where the input
is the same as the output so you have
two types which is the sorry three and
three three components the first is the
encoder the second is code
and the third is the decoder
so you have a hidden layer that
describes the code used to represent the
input and the network may be viewed as
consisting of just two parts which is
the encoder function and the decoder
function which produces a Reconstruction
from that particular code now uh in some
ways you will have to read up and we'll
have to come before we start using this
at the theory level to be able to pick
up on machine learning to get to
artificial neural networks Etc I will
skip over that and let's just use this
as a back box okay essentially what we
need to do is put in the information on
the variation and we get this code so
how do we implement this if we are given
something like code that is here
so you take your viral sequences and the
first stage is to be able to convert
this data which basically has a
collection date and you have a protein
sequence that that is generated from
that into some sort of a binary format
so we convert it into a binary format
and this is now
translated from the discrete form into a
continuous representation in lower
dimensions
so what you have now is you can
visualize this more or less like a
flowing graph the continuous
representation and the way to model this
is to use what is known as a gaussian
process regression which forecasts
future continuous coordinates so given
some sort of a regression line a
continuous regression line I can predict
what the next value would be
so what is this idea of the gaussian
process the basic assumption is that if
you say two vectors let's say x and x
dash are similar then they're functions
f x and f x dash should also be similar
so the covariance function between these
two will give you a measure of
similarity between these two vectors x
and x dash and the mean function MX
encodes the a priority expectation of
the unknown function so this unknown
function values are conditioned using
the known ones if there's no similar
values then the mean function influences
the result so translated into biological
English I have sequences of the virus so
far and those are the known values that
I want to use can I massage them into
this particular model such that we can
predict the next sequence that is coming
out okay so once we've got this data
that is fed in over here
the variable Auto encoder decoder now
constructs new sequences from these
forecasted coordinates so now I'm
getting new sequences which are
predicted based on the timelines and
based on the kind of progressions that
have come in from the earlier sequence
and we can then synthesize these
sequences and see whether and rank them
and see what that is an internal
likelihood measure but we can also use
other measures that we've described
earlier such as are the location of the
residues of importance in the locations
we are looking at for immune Escape
so this kind of model forecasts
they held out sequences so these are
some of the results that we have
essentially this is the sequence and
shown in red over here the forecast
points
which fit very well with what is
expected okay so when we put all this
data back in we can see which residues
are predicted to change there are a
number of residues which could be false
positive but they are filtered out from
our information earlier so the ones that
are in the locations that we are looking
at and which we have defined as
important those are the residues that we
can use to filter out from these odds
from these 70 odd sequences that were
generated in this exercise and predict
which sequences would be the sequences
which be of relevance okay so this is my
end I think we reached the timeline also
a little overtime I'm sorry so you
implement analytical methods which are
responsible for protein stability and
fold the protein function and immune
escape and we use this information with
generator AI to predict the sequence of
future sequence of the spike proteins
and this can be used to generate a
vaccine which will be predict future
infection okay my apologies for running
uh short on time I didn't have the clock
present over here so thank you I hand
back to DJ
so we do have some queries in the chat
that I would like to quickly take up I
apologize to Dr bookna we'll be starting
this with session in just few minutes
and so the one question that we have is
what does Gap indicate in protein
structure will it be the void space or
is it the sequence
okay uh can you is my sharing still on
I'm sorry I really don't know how to
stop this
okay I'm trying to switch it off
thank you
okay uh very briefly a gap in a multiple
alignment is what we call either an
insertion in some sequences or a
deletion in subsequences in
bioinformatics it's called it indel so
when you uh stack together these
sequences if there is a deletion in a
few sequences the other sequences have
the sequence which is an insertion
present and it will the other the
sequences will come out as a gap okay so
it's only present in a few sequences and
absent in the other sequences
much and then the next question is were
there any
other research
uh okay I I'm just listening to you
because I can't see the chat you want me
to read it from the chat
so just disrepute the question
yes uh were there any unexpected finding
in your research work
no because we were looking for a
particular question we used a standard
method to be able to arrive at that
answer so we weren't really getting
anything expect unexpected uh if that's
the thing we were we we focused our
particular research on a hypothesis and
we arrived at that particular result so
the answer is no
thank you so much so um we do have some
more queries we'll be other uh sharing
it with you during the parent discussion
or I really made it to you so we look
forward to apologize for taking so much
of time okay
it was a very wonderful message
so uh with that now I'd like to invite
uh Dr Mukesh Gupta so let me give you a
brief Dr Gupta is a fellow of the Royal
Society of biology he earned his PhD in
animal biotechnology from Kong Book
University he started his research
career as an associate professor of
animal biotechnology at Concord
University in 2007. he's currently
working as a professor of biotechnology
and medical engineering at the National
Institute of Technology he is also the
scientific steering committee member of
arbs to share insights on omics of
spermatozoa and its relevance to male
fertility I'm most honored to invite Dr
Gupta to start with the session over to
yourself
thank you
thank you for the inviting first of all
thank you for inviting for this
Symposium and I'm very happy to share my
research data with the with the
scientific Community let me first share
these slides
is my slides visible to all
yes and it is not in slideshow yes
nowadays thank you
yes so I'm thank you once again for
inviting and giving this opportunity to
share our data I am going to completely
move from the the in Silicon analysis
and prediction method to utilizing those
technology for understanding something
which was hitherto unknown to us so I'll
be presenting talking about both the wet
lab data as well as the prediction data
that we have done in our Laboratory what
we are going to talk is understanding
the experimentary function and it's the
11th to fertility from the omics point
of view
perhaps many of you will be aware that
the infertility has been becoming a very
common
a phenomena across the countries
particularly the the
developed countries and countries with
the rapid urbanization globally we
believe that 60 to 80 percent 60 to 80
millions of couples are infertile
worldwide in India alone estimated to
have 15 to 20 million couples infertile
in many countries it is generally
believed that the cause of infertility
or inability to Bear the baby lies with
the female which is in sharp contrast to
what science says is that 50 percent of
infertility cases arise from the male
factor in fidelity
and uh one in every 15 to 20 men are
diagnosed to be infertile worldwise this
data largely comes from the urban area
but perhaps similar things that exist in
the uh doodle areas as well
now the cause of fertility could be a
variety of them there could be disorders
of the semen there could be abnormal
spermotility there could be estimate
juice permia oligo juice permea being
very very common there could be uh the
failures of testes including cryptochism
or the bronchitis or varicose sale and
could be many but there are
roughly 20 percent of the infertility
cases
where we are unable to find the cause of
fertility simply the sperms are
infertile say for example this
spermatogenic failure where there is no
sperm production at all so fertility
cost could be a variety and so far we
have been trying to understand this from
semen analysis or hormone and Analysis
or the diagnostic tools such as
ultrasound and and so on in very recent
terms we are trying to understand
molecular point of view now from that we
have in our Laboratory
we started in investigating
that what other factors could be
responsible for the sperm fertility now
sperm traditionally is considered as
just a delivery boy it is considered
that the job of the sperm is only to
deliver the nucleus into the into the
cytoplasm of food site and which should
which cell participate to form the blue
nucleus and to form the embryo
but with time we get to know the job of
the sperm is not just to to deliver the
pattern of DNA or the nucleus but also
it takes part in formation of centriole
and other organelles which can go
particularly essential on the other hand
certain organs have delivered they could
be dangerous to the the or the the
embryo toxic say for example the
mitochondria which is in the in the
middle piece of sponsor
if they goes delivered into the
cytoplasm it may lead to mitochondria
heteroplasmic and embryonic death
we also came to know with time that
there could be soluble factors present
in the cytoplasm which might help in
oocyte activation triggering the the
resumption of meiosis in oocytes and the
the cell signaling particularly calcium
signaling so that this will start
dividing the Amazon external embryonic
cells to become the amnionic cells
and with that most of the factors they
meet and what are the research limited
to that sperm function and there we will
stop now in our Laboratories
and some other fuel about this
particularly from Pennsylvania
we have reported that the sperm also
contains a very very tiny amount of
skimeters over
the it's limited to be about
0.015 picogram of RNA which is very very
tiny if you consider the pulse cell
concentration but if you assume the the
volume of cytoplasm that is sperm as
sperm is largely nucleus very tiny
amount of cytoplasm then if you thought
think from that perspective this RNA
quantity is very pretty high
and it was discovered the time that the
you know earlier people trying to
evaluate one of you RNA in spumtazoa one
at a time a few at a time and
traditional methods of evaluating on the
population in uh did not give us much
information with the invent of omics
Technologies particularly after the
Illumina sequencing came into picture
then we and along with others have
identified that there could be more than
3 500
types of other names which are present
and some of them could be a total length
full length rnas that are present in
this middle so what include that include
coding sequences coding homogeneous and
non-coding sequences including
a circular awareness and long coding
long non-coding RNs
although this was very paradoxical
because it is in the traditional methods
we say that this is just residual the
treasure they do not they are not
supposed to be present they are present
the virtual being a reminiscent of
spermatogenesis
and why with this thought was there that
nuclear genome in isometer is
transcriptionally dormant except for
mitochondrial DNA where they say
probably some might function some might
be synthesized
and then this promoters over
therefore there is absolutely no
possibility of translation there is
complete translation shutdown there is
no de novo protein synthesis so the data
which was in Paradox that the omics
technology has given a data that there
could be a mother name it was initially
thought that perhaps this could be a
contaminant from the somatic cells all
the other cells that might get can that
mixed up with the sperm samples then
there are number of methods that was uh
you know employed to get a purified
population
and it was confirmed that these are not
just the the errors of the sequencing
not the errors of Illumina a sequencing
they are indeed percent and with all
value when people try to do the
traditional full learning synthesis then
they get to know yes this
also contains sums rnas which are in
full length sequence then the question
come what is this source and what is
their function
now there could be variety of the
function literature so that if you look
at this the presence of this tomato Zola
when they try to call localize
this permutation has a very peculiar
location of otherness
so the the
nucleosomes of the sperm is highly
compact with the solenoid structure uh
the DNA is bound with highly basic
protein which is protamine unlike the
somatic cells where we have the histone
bound DNA where we have glutamine
glutamine bound DNA and they take a
solenoid structures very difficult for
otherness to to transcribe
but then there were few in the
particularly in those near the the
nuclear Matrix area there were a few
amounts of the the histone proteins to
which dnas were bound and That Was Then
thought that perhaps those RNA which are
present here at the bound to histones
are probably potentiated to to translate
to a protein but so a lot of new
hypothesis is protein but nothing was
coming in in reality what would be the
reason
so we try to investigate that first with
some wet lab experiments we took the
sperm samples of three different picks
these three both one two three which
were known to have different ability to
develop into blastocyst or the embryonic
development this is low fertility this
is high fertility and this is medium
fertility
and we stain this tomato with the other
specific dye RNA the dye which combine
exclusively
what we could observe was
that the percentage of
RNA positive the RNA is a bit tiny so
very difficult to obtain the positive
signals but whatever we could obtained
we could see that the there was a
positive correlation between the number
of RNA positives from Reserva with the
blastocity stretch so as the percentage
of such cells increased the percentage
of
the placenta is a blastocyst she seems
to be increasing so it just suggested
that perhaps the spermatism
may have some some function to do that
so in before venturing into the trade
analysis what we did is we first took
this computer though isola's name we
purified them and injected them into
oocyte big blue sites firstly collected
inside and try to see if this is
injected
can develop into embryo which we found
that they couldn't develop
so we also could we started using the
oocytes injected them
and employed an elliptical signal to
activate the embryonic activation
embryonic development
so where we could find the embryonic
development so what we found is
very interestingly
the parthenogenetic activation which is
without spoon Reserva they can develop
to blastosis stage
but if we inject this promoters over
sponsor RNA and then activate
the rate of embryonic development
increases and not just that
the embryonic development can the
quality that we got was better in terms
of the cell number in terms of the
apoptosis and all which I'm not showing
the data they were much better compared
to the normal pathogenetic embryo so we
know that okay that means
perhaps some function
the next set of experiment what we did
we used a method and new method to
deplete those RNA so we use this
parameters over depleted them with this
moment of all RNA and then use them for
IVF in which your fertilization of
pagocytes what we found was when we
depleted this pandasova very few very
few embryos could develop you can see
roughly six percent majority of them
could not develop that means it
reinforces the idea that is
have some function because when we
deplete them it reduces development when
you increase them it improves the
development
so we try to do a rescue experiment
what we did we took this committers over
depleted the RNA from them
injected and then we use that RNA
depleted for IVF
and after in after fertilization we
injected Isola into those X and we found
that it could rescue the development so
if you see this is the normal IVF 31
embryo become developed after blastocyst
stage whereas when we depleted this
Commodus over it dropped down to five
percent and when we injected
it gained back to 21 percent
that means RNA does have some function
so next approach then we want we took
the uh to try to understand what could
be the reason
if the there are rnas there could be two
possibilities either the non-coding or
the nails has caused the must-cause
downloadation of some Gene related to
embryonic development or there could be
coding RNA which gets translated into
embryos and they may either down the
glitch or up regulate depending on
whether they are regulatory nature or
they are of proteins of the something
mean pathway
keeping in this View
what we did we took these parameters
over
one in which we injected this
permissible RNA and then parthenogenetic
activation
and one without supplies and we compared
them with the normal in vitro
fertilizations we take three group of
embryos and employed the LCM SMS
to do a global peptide sequencing we did
Global peptides influencing and we also
applied Aqua for absolute quantification
of some of the selected proteins
so what we found we could actually get
about 54 000 Spectra
and these proteins could map to about
this Spectra could map to about the
1353 proteins and if you look at that
the parthenogenetic embryo the green
ones are the one which is injected with
rnas and the blue ones are those which
are injected with the IDF
we could find that there were lot many
proteins which were common but then each
one has
their their individual unique proteins
present in them
and if you look at the concentration
wise
if you when we normalize the protein set
with the bathroom genetic activated mu
we could find that
the in the RNA group as well as the IVF
group a large number of protein got
appreculated by more than 10 fold
regulated
that means these probably some of the
other Nays are getting translated to
protein in the X
after the injection
and many proteins could get down
regulated also in fact number of
proteins which got Dominic related were
much higher than those which got
applicated so perhaps they are also
regulatory regulatory sequences like
mRNA sequences because in Hindi
so they were also
the unique proteins we got so if you
compare the the the RNA group all the
injected blue versus IVF group both Loop
contains 50 proteins which were common
and there were 40 to 13 unique to IVF
group and 152 152 unique new in other
negative similarly 160 about 39 were
absent in The Islander group alone
compared to partner genetic and 266 were
absent in IVF group compared to pass
genetic embryo so our hypothesis was and
these proteins when you look at
different uh cellular mechanism a great
majority of which were involved in early
metabolism or DNA metabolism a protein
metabolism or some of the base cell
metabolism but a good number was also
involved in the signal transduction
pathway
and different other physiological
processes so this suggests
what we understand is
if we find the proteins which are
applicated or downward regulated there
could be two reasons
if we have a change in both the groups
that means the proteins have some role
to play during embryonic development if
we have only in one group
and if that is due to other neck group
that means that that rnas are probably
those which have function during this
public Genesis and those which are IVF
groups are the one which probably have
functioned during the embryonic
development
so that so the this supports the basic
hypothesis that the rnas which were
identified by the Illumina sequences
they are not the the errors the the RMS
does seem to have some function
so then we we switched on to another
species growth and using as a model
system a very good model system for
respond to Genesis and then what we did
we started a detailed analysis of RNA
population info and then investigating
whether do they have any functions so we
we employed three different methods to
sequence all the RNA population that are
present in instrument
we employed avalum race and constructed
a full length cdna Library
we employed software Illumina sequencing
method and we also employed the long
read nanopo sequencing the other malays
and nanopore sequencing we have in our
laboratory we employed that Illumina
sequencing we Outsource it to another
company we got the data we analyzed them
we combine them and then we employed
normal classes which we all know we
trimmed the data sets mapped them to the
databases and then try to calculate the
fpkm value and do Gene ontology analysis
for the biological function or
cytoplasmic location or molecular
function then there's pathway analysis
we also built up uh the PPI Network
protein protein interaction Network and
try to analyze those Network where they
could participate
now what we put that in all the same
method
we could find that they are full length
sequences both in Illumina nanopore as
well as the race
there were some sequences we could
obtain the complete RNA sequence
starting from the the uh the first Exon
to the last exam
and these some of these were involved in
the mail reproduction says Androgen
receptor Casper which is important for
the capacitation event the catspot which
is the iron channel for capacitation
Dazzle very good marker for
spermudogenesis heat shock protein spsa
totamine very important for the
compaction of the the sperm nucleus and
three sequences all the sequences had
some of the genes which were common to
all of them that means the we could
infer from that that genes are this our
sequencing are working
so as expected you could find that the
majority of the in these sequences
belong to the mrns but it also included
the my qualities the unlock mini the
otherness of course
reduction so numbers were pretty less
otherwise they could have been more
we did get the uh some rrna despite
ribose reduction and then we also the
dictate some of the circular rnas and
long non-coding rnas if you look at this
graph here we predicted and show you
later the our we developed a novel
pipeline to identify the circular RNA
and we could find number of circular
rnas within this formula
the gene said interestingly also
included about 160 imprinted genes
probably all of you are aware the
imprinted genes are those genes which
are expressed from uniparentals in
either from the paternal chromosome or
from the metallic chromosome so out of
160 which are located in 20 different 29
different chromosomes
79 were maternal and 81 were paternal
input inverted genes we could predict
and there were also many long non-coding
RNs 591 were predicted and we also
predicted their targets and many of the
target genes were known to earlier known
to be participating in one or the other
steps of the meal of production and not
many of them were for this computer
Genesis process some of them were also
involved in the early embryonic
development
and these protein when I try to do this
genotology they were belonging to
several Pathways some important Pathways
which later we also discovered was there
are not many were involved in the wind
signaling pathway map kinase pathway and
ampk Pathways and tnfc Alpha this
significant human aquatic sector
Pathways of course their localizations
were there through many of the other
proteins and when you try to Cluster
them for those genes which are fertility
known to be male fertility elected we
could also see the involvement of not
many genes in the gpcr pathway G protein
coupled receptors and in Pathways some
of them were also involved in the the
the early embryonic development or
neonatal development including the
formation of the brain or limbic system
but they were a good number of Duty so
it probably suggests
these analysis suggest that sperm could
have sperm RNA could have function
during fertilization
that means could be either capacitation
I'll come to that later and the mrnas
May remain in the cytoplasm to affect
some signaling pathway post
fertilization that may play a role in
the early embryonic development or the
postnatal development so those synthetic
Pathways may be affected by them
so he took up the first one
whether this they affect the spawn
function itself so if you know probably
some of you know that when the sperm has
to function sperm has to undergo a
process of capacitation during which
they acquire the ability to fertilize
the egg so we started doing it we
collected this perimeters over purified
it the motile is permit is over and we
treated them with the capacitating agent
one group we kept kept in a
non-capacitating media and then other
one capacitating media with extra added
Heparin which improves the fertility
into this sperm motility hypomotility
and capacitation then we isolated the
MRNA from them constructed the cdna
library by and did an Illumina
sequencing and map them to genome and
try to understand the function of
whether this
capacitation
so as you can see from there when we
treat this from resource they improves
the mortality and capacitation
so the within four hours you can see
there is not many increase number nearly
80 percent sperm become capacitated and
shown ethosomal reaction which is a mark
of that the capacity has taken is it an
essential requirement for fertilization
to take place so we could see that
heparating can cause the the fertilizer
the capacitation and ozone reaction
which are requirements for sperm to
fertilize
then we did the RNA sequencing of them
both the groups we found that
while many Amana populations were common
there were many of the genes which are
upper regulated in the HEPA intuited or
the capacity that's among the zoa
uh the fold changes were not much which
were the anticipated because considering
the very tiny amount of spombezoa we
have but then we had about 96 proteins
which were shown the full change of
which in five to ten if you look at this
most proteins were upper regulated a
very few were down regulated genes
resulted them were updated if you if I
show you the volcano plot
you can see these differences the lot
many proteins were up with the glated
and very tiny fractions were reduced in
the expression level of the genes so
sperm RNA
have the once when we expose them to
capacitating
environment many of the spermarnate
numbers increases now the question of
course remains which I shall discuss
later where from their tummy but then
there is definitely an increase in the
RNA population once you activate them
and now if you look at this uh the
capacitation induced proteins in the
biological processes they involved in
many many uh molecular functions
including the DNA binding they have many
DNA binding rnas and metal ion binding
Serene Theory kinase activity then there
were some of them were ribosomal the ATP
binding there's a lot many binding
proteins uh the the one which they are
we had the upper regulated ones
and when we try to analyze them we find
there are many genes which are involved
in as we have seen earlier signaling
pathway is known to be related to
capacitation like ampk pathway calcium
signal pathway cyclic amp pathway cyclic
GMP pathway map kinase pathway
phospholipid pathway pik3
akt pathway so many genes were involved
in them and these genes which I've
listed here uh earlier known to have
impact on capacitation on one gene at a
time basis analysis
and we verified we selected some of the
data some of the samples we did the real
time rtpcr reverse transcriptase
polymerase reaction and verified that
the data which we generated from the the
Illumina sequencings are in line with
those which get with the the rtpcr or
the ultra and PCR
so among these pathway uh when we saw
was many of them were also involved in
the loss activity the oxidative stress
pathway so we then try to see if the
really there was an increase in the
oxidation or the reactive oxygen species
and we found that when the tree when
there is a capacitation event
the cons the activity of the reactive
oxygen species increases
you can see that more number of green
cells which means that greater number of
cells were having the high high Ros
activity
and it was it was parallely matching
with the percentage of cells that they
got capacitated so by four hours many of
them should be always positive cells
very much in green cells so it it then
reconfirms our idea from the insulin
from the omics data that the oxidative
stress pathway was indeed activated in
the in the smooth so we tried to call it
all the data and look at the the
capacitation pathway and if you look at
the the the our proposed model based on
these data analysis is that heparin
it increases the the Ros activity and
opens up the cat's power
to which the calcium goes in and this
happens can also find with the bsp
receptor
to activate the soluble
acetyl cyclase enzymes in the cytoplasm
and of course also cause the sodium
bicarbonate bicarbonate Channel open
which all together increases the
activity of cyclic amp these are the
genes which are involved in this pathway
the style ones we have seen them
so this the cyclic amp then increases
the pka which together with the AKP
increase the protein titles in kinases
to activate the the events of the the
thyrosine phosphorylation to somehow
cause the hyperactivation and
capacitation event
the oxidative phosphorylation events
also participate in the same so the one
which you are seeing the star marked we
have experimentally verified to confirm
our data with the omics data so this is
the the path will be fine with the
Heparin but then I'm not really not
discussing today but we also try to
change the the capacitating agent from
Heparin to another molecule called
Arginine L-Arginine also known to cause
in our data the increase the percentage
of capacity it is over so we also did
that we took this promoters over and
exposed them through the the
non-capacitating medium or Arginine and
we use another another molecule while
phe Peninsula mind
epinephrine cocktail and then analyze
the uh RNA sequences within them
to find out differential differentially
expressed Gene and then try to see the
pathway we could see that they're also
increasing the the the
capacitation although the pathway is
different uh nonetheless all of them
follows the uh the oxidative possible
license pathway say for example in case
of rg9 they produce nitric oxide which
can then activate the acetyl cyclase and
they can also participate in the last
and activate the guanoid cyclist
activity through cause the saline
salinetheone in phosphorylation
phosphorylation and increase in
mankinase activities all these proteins
or sorry mrnas which are participating
in these signaling Pathways were known
similar data we also got with the
penicillin epitaphane hypo tolerance so
if I sum up together
these data our data suggests that unlike
traditional
of investigating on one a few other
names the the question whether the
supplement were reminiscent of is from
the Genesis or did we really get them
it it it opened up the world of old new
suit of otherness including circular RNA
long non-boarding RNs and many of the
micrornos being present within them
our data also said that these response
when we inject they improve the
blastosis formation and the global
protein profiling we have actually also
done the uh the the absolute
quantification of this protein but due
to positive time I'm not not discussing
on them then we also saw that when
depleted it inhibited the embryonic
development and when we try to inject
this into these depleted there is a
residue of early embryonic development
so this data suggests this rnas are not
residual of sperminogenesis they do have
a function in early embryonic
development and they also have function
in the capacitation events at least the
one which you have analyzed for the
activities are going on now I also give
you a brief comparison of when you try
to apply a full length CDN Allied
reconstruction by race versus illuminai
in nanopore not much work has been done
with the Nano consequences and
considering the samples such as
is very very difficult to isolate the
the sperm what we found that with the
Nano post sequencing and other numbers
we can get the full length information
which is either though not possible to
get uh good with the Illumina but we got
in in nanopore sequencing the around one
and a half KB length
uh in some cases we got up to 3 KB also
but in case of Illumina uh we get of
course as we know it's a more number of
reads so if you want to looking for the
global profiling Illumina seems to be
good but if you want to know about more
about the analysis about the what kind
of transcripts are present with function
in see in cases like sperm it is
questionable whether these genes are
really a reminiscent of functionals but
if full-length information you have then
you know that these genes are bound to
have some function so in that angle
nano4 seems to be good
we have also developed uh sorry I didn't
discuss about this pipeline for circular
RNN lnc RNA but they are seems to be
involved in different stages of
spondylogenesis and learning development
and we have shown that this Commodities
over participate in Wind signaling CMP
pathway map kindness pathway significant
pathway including oxidative stress
pathway and when we did this staining
and confirmed that the capacitation in
stages involves iOS activity which
correlates with the our the the omics
data suggesting that the capacitation
losses involves some of the
um in Upper regulation of the other
names and thereby causing the
capacitation
so it gives us a lot of information
which was earlier unknown I have not
cited the the references all this data
has been published recently in CI
journals
and that's all for my presentation uh I
must acknowledge the funding agencies
before I close the gbt the icmr the
circsir has given the maximum fund for
this purpose and validation studies and
all comes from the icmr the in silica
studies comes from the DBT and also the
serve which has been funding us and of
course I it will be I will not undermine
our students both undergraduate
postgraduate PhD students who have been
the backbone to provide this data thank
you for listening
well thank you so much Dr Gupta for that
wonderful presentation uh but due to
time constraints I'm going to have to
limit the number of uh participants
queries that I have to share with you so
the one query that we have is uh can you
suggest any open source or publicly
available data sets or tools that you
would recommend for me to start working
on this area
uh sir you are on mute at the moment
[Music]
so if you are looking for the data sets
uh for analyzing species like human
Mouse then open source uh data sets are
also available and there are tools which
are available but if you are working in
other mammalian species farm animals
like pigs or goats where the database
remains incomplete so in those use case
you have to write your own code our
quotes are available in the in the
GitHub you can you can get the source
code from there and we have also
developed some of the pipeline by
secular RNA which you can get from the
GitHub if you look at Loop search for my
name you'll get there and data sets
which we are having we are still
performing some analysis so we have not
yet uploaded in the uh the
genome geosites we'll upload it shortly
because we are still doing this is the
novel study so far other than us there's
no study on protomix study nobody has
done because it's not easy to do that
you need uh thousands of eggs fertilized
egg to do that which is very difficult
so Atomic study nobody has done that and
we are the first one to do such studies
in good some more studies are pipelines
once it is done we'll put in the Geo
site so you have to wait for another two
three months
last question that I want to ask what
kind of opportunities do you see for
data scientists and why aren't married
what kind of opportunities what kind of
opportunities what kind of opportunities
do you see for data scientists and
bioinformations in this area of male
fertility
okay I think we have next final
discussion on that but yes it is a very
good question
this uh the uh the data scientist and
the involvement on the uh infertility
management or the oocytes embryos is
completely it's a blank field not many
people are working on that very few
people are working and it's an area
which is worth exploring and you will
look at the structure all the data
scientists who are working on this are
just working on some other field the
computational biologists are not working
on this bioinformaticians are using the
data and doing it not many people are
working and it's a full of opportunity
there is a need for computational
biologists to write code for the
specifically for this area fully open
and one area which is a research area
nobody is explode is working on the the
mechanism of how the oocyte activate
well it's completely who side part is
completely left
thank you so much uh I'm curious to know
more about this so for that we would
like to move on to the next uh part of
today's Symposium which is a panel with
Kashi so to start with the session I
would like to invite again Dr Andrew Lin
Professor rule of computational and
integrative Sciences
Professor Department of biotechnology
and medical engineering nit doctor
pankaj assistant professor Department of
bioscience and bioengineering IIT
jodhpur and the moderator of this final
discussion is going to be Dr Mohit
nizamberg Global Business Development
biotech
foreign
and professor
um uh yeah Professor ayado Gupta and
thank you for all of you that who have
joined this panel discussion
um so let me quickly just uh give a
perspective about what we were hoping to
discuss in this session and then maybe
we can start with having these different
type of questions so um I think
what we have been observing
is that the biological data is turning
out to be much more complex than we ever
thought of and learning about it and
correctly integrating these high lead
interdisciplinary subjects is quite a
challenge so with substantial and growth
in growing influence in health
environmental sciences and society and
being utilized by scientists from many
diverse academic background and that's
what we have learned from Dr Mukesh
Gupta Professor Mukesh Gupta that that
there are so many areas that people are
yet to explore because of the lack of
understanding so education and this is
these areas is therefore like necessary
see it's
for Effective development of skills in
having interdisciplinary collaborations
Communications ethics critical analysis
of research so all of these aspects
along with you know practical and
technical skills so I think that's where
we wanted to have a discussion around
that
um the need
for uh such in such a training in
education and how are the ways we think
is it possible to integrate some of
these things and at the same time what
is the current scenario because I think
uh Professor Lynn is associated with
jawaharlal nehru University and Dr
yadavir is associated with IIT jodhpur
iits and uh and uh Dr Mukesh here is
Professor Mukesh here is from a research
institute uh um nit very famous Research
Institute so I think all of you have a
various like different kind of
experience having to work with different
types of administration and so that's
how I think if you can give us your
perspective about first the use of data
science and
bioinformatics or biological data
analysis for this newer generation who
are started their journey in in
healthcare life science students
so with that let me yes yes I was just
going to ask you sir that uh
yeah okay so very briefly I think that
we should slot into three levels the
first is bioinformatics technical skills
the other is bioinformatics engineering
skills and the third is to be a
bioinformatics scientist now all three
of them have very different inputs now
off their biology itself is very data
driven but the problem is that the
bioinformatician very rarely controls
the research project you have to come in
as a scientist with control over the
project and very often you come in as a
biologist
and then you have together by
informatician or develop the
bioinformatics skills as part of it now
the engineering field is now dominated
by computer scientists there's no way
that a biologist or a life scientist can
now compete with the algorithm
development skills that come from
computer science
so what most of us have trained in
students are people with enough
technical skills you've got a very good
panel of skills that you have over there
and those would very easily be absorbed
in biology Laboratories because they
have to handle the data that is
generated by the laboratory or by
samples that are sent out for a
mixed-based right so that's again to
summarize three levels slot yourself
into one of them based on your
background and the skills that you can
develop in the short term and long term
technical skills which you should be
able to get with short-term diploma the
engineering skills you need to have a
background with computer science and
that does not mean just handling data
that means that you need to have
algorithm development skills which
require far deeper understanding of the
mathematics behind computer science and
the bioinformatics scientist which is
really if you have a life sciences
background you understand what the data
is going to mean and you can develop and
get hypothesis and also generate samples
which can be used for generating the
data okay thank you
yeah I think that's accidentally put I
mean categorizing them uh also we get an
understanding I think from this that uh
some of the undergraduate students I
think reached out us reached out to us
about uh what kind of job opportunities
that they will get after finishing such
a degree and henceforth so I think
understanding that a research based
career would take a little bit longer
time to develop uh it's just not about
the technology but also to learn to
apply that and do it do maybe a masters
in research or PhD would be something
that would be required for such student
who's going to the research journey and
for technical skills I think um you
would be needing an engineering degree
or
mtech degree I think is that correct
no I was actually dividing technical
skills and separating them from
engineering technically you can get with
a diploma and I think short-term courses
you should be able to scale yourself
with them a few months you can even do
them online and Engineering would be
that you have to have a basic skill set
with developing algorithm very rarely
can you do that in the isolation of your
home you need to have proper training
with them and you need to have a lot of
online outside of University spaces such
as open source software development
communities python groups that for
instance Delhi has a very good software
developed through hackathons so but it's
a different platform from what we are
normally used to and the one that I said
as a scientist is a slightly longer
timeline there's a lag phase where you
have to do a PhD where you incubate in
institutions on big projects and you get
the understanding you would normally
would be in your late 20s or early 30s
before you reach that stage and there's
an incubation stage through a PhD
program
yes absolutely thank you thank you so
much yeah so just to repeat if you are
young and in the undergraduate do
technical skills you can get them
through online and you love to choose
what you're going to
that's a great suggestion and that's
something that also aligns with what we
have been doing and asking students and
researchers to be able to go through uh
so thank you uh Professor Len and maybe
uh I I now ask a professor pankaj
yeah thank you thank you for inviting uh
let me first thank you for inviting to
the panel discussion I think it's a
wonderful to see a professor Andrew for
after a few many years
okay and
um yeah I think I totally agree with the
professor Andrew so he has already given
very clear answer to like what kind of
skills do we is required
yeah sorry I just bought yeah so I I
have just one one thing to add like what
we now at I in IIT what we are seeing
and also we are implementing is like we
are
trying to make the things
multi-disciplinary so those are
classical uh you know the traditional uh
way the people were defining the
ingenious and also uh the the those
which are from biology background so
these boundaries are sort of now
disappearing and uh one need to have an
understanding of different domains not
just a very particular domain in which
you are trained because nowadays
Engineers can also not work in isolation
so they have to have understanding of uh
at least some fundamentals or some to
some extent the knowledge of biology and
indeed like nowadays what is happening
is that nobody is working in isolation
anymore so you have to reach out to
people who are expert in their their
domain but at the same time you have to
have some exposure and to have to extend
your uh skills and knowledge to other
domains also in order to excel right so
I think in the coming generation I think
that change we will definitely see and
in in as I said in iits now there is a
closed focus on multi-discipline plenary
trainings so I I think
in this uh next five to ten years we are
going to see a huge change in the skills
with which people will be moving out in
the job industry right so I think yeah
that that's my insight on this
yes thank you pankaj guys for sharing I
think uh that's that's completely it
makes sense and uh uh in today's uh even
in job opportunities that we see we see
uh looking at uh like diverse
diverse types of skill sets as well as
uh some work experience that is required
by some of these uh industry or academic
Labs uh that are hoping that students
are coming with some specific type of
skill sets
um where before they apply and what they
are applying for so the question is uh
about the integration
in the curriculum so what what are the
what are your thoughts about like
integration of like how do we integrate
them in their curriculum or is it like
for an undergraduate how would that
curriculum would look like uh and uh
foreign
look like
yeah yeah sorry Mike can can you just
repeat your query sorry I just missed
your voice no no no problem no problem
so uh we we understood that uh the way
things are going and what are the
different ways students can perceive
this and then we understand that okay
there are uh skill sets skill sets and
there is a choice based credit system
which is mostly have been adopted by
many universities and institutions
giving a lot of flexibility to students
to do interest interdisciplinary stuff
and learn about different skill sets I
mean overall it's like a it's like a
it's a it's a good thing so I'm asking
that about the integration of such
um skills still skill set based courses
so are we there yet or what is the
situation so I uh I know about IIT but
what are your thoughts about the IIT and
other institutions that you might be
knowing of and uh like for
undergraduates how it looks like and for
graduates how does that looks like now
yes so currently uh and at undergraduate
level we have two years which are uh
common for the uh for the all the
branches uh so all the students they
take common two years common courses and
uh after uh starting from three and
third year onwards they take some
mandatory courses
um
in their streams and apart from that
there is a huge flexibility to opt from
other domains as well so for example
computer science student a lot of
computer science students they take
courses from bioengineering domain right
so from third year onwards and another
uh thing that what we have at IIT system
is also we offer from since second year
onwards we offer design credit projects
and some kind of other projects that
that allow them to work in a
multi-disciplinary uh
uh kind of team and work under the
supervision of different expertise so
that they learn and grab that different
domains on by the time they pass out
right so uh this is uh the scenario
currently at the undergraduate and for
postgraduate we also have the kind of uh
since postgraduate is more specialized
so it is expected they have some basic
training already at undergraduate level
uh we usually have a few first year that
is kind of course work and then followed
by mainly the research projects so uh
there is uh currently the scenarios but
I think in coming years uh once this nap
is uh is kind of new education policy is
implemented there has to be some some
changements that will be implemented
because there will be there are drastic
changes that has been done and to
keeping that in line with that new
education policy uh we have at IIT we
have started with the uh a lot of
certificate oriented and diploma
oriented training so that the future
generation is kind of trained on those
high demand areas and then there will be
a huge
jobs Market also once they take up those
certificate and diploma courses
yeah so yeah that is the thing at this
moment
all right okay thank you so much for
sharing that that uh that does uh like
makes us understand a lot about the way
it is being perceived uh at a university
or institutional level and what are the
different things that have been done in
and what people can and the students can
expect from there so I think uh that's
about the students but uh I have a
follow-up question for uh professor
Gupta about the PhD students I mean uh I
mean for them uh how are they I mean
some of these them are being biologists
and they then there is a need for them
to understand the aspect of data science
and maybe exploratory analysis that they
have to do uh for a hypothesis driven
research questions so how do how how how
you can train them or what is the way we
should go look at it right now for those
students who does not come from that
mindset right as you can understand
because you're going through and
training those students a lot
when it starts when the PhD students
when they start they have to come
through the bachelor's and master's
degree and if you look at the current
scenario I'll talk about the India first
I've been looking after the admission of
undergraduate as well as postgraduate in
its nits and all the josa and the ccmt
have been part of that so as Dr Andrew
mentioned you know there's we can
distinguish two part one is biomatics
where the people are using the existing
existing tools they don't involve in
developing a tool rather using the
existing tools that's one set of
scientists where we get most biological
people comes in people with the biology
background say BAC or mscn biotechnology
or BSE MSC and life science or some
other relative branches when they come
in then there's not many tools available
open source tools available easy to use
it very user friendly they're very nice
user interface graphical user interface
people can use it and uh tutorials are
well very good so all they have to
understand is how to use those tools but
that's very not very difficult People
Like Us who are the initially you know
wet lab experiment scientists so in
order to migrate them as a biology as a
buy information they are not many tools
available but certain tools which are
not available in the say windows based
system that doesn't work well say for
example if you're doing MD simulations
at all so it doesn't work so well in the
in the windows environment when they
have to switch to Unix environment so
the students with the the pure
biological background find it difficult
yeah so that's the place where they're
stuck in so in those cases the only
opportunity as others have also
mentioned they can take certain diploma
courses available they are certificate
programs number programs available in
iits as well as the on the nptel they
can utilize nptel training programs
available many internships are available
so they have to do that that's one way
but if you are going to write a
command-based tools for the analysis
then there is no way uh not easy
software for the biologist that normally
starts with engineering so if you look
at now many of the iits and triple its
nits they have started VTech program in
data science and Analysis but da
programs are largely on this High
demanding program data science is a very
high demanding but the expectation of
the student is to go in Ai and ml for
various applications and then go to the
the other area of non-biological areas
some institutes like say MIT Bhopal or
triple it allahabad they do have forces
specifically on mathematics those cases
they took for undergraduate or the
postgraduate level where they need to
have basic understanding of the
programming languages to start with
so once you have that background in
programming languages and understanding
the basics of the AIML having background
in basic and then if you come to biology
the problem here is the other way down
these people are usually poor in biology
they were very good at writing commands
very good at uh driving the writing the
course for them but the what biological
things they have to analyze is very
becomes very difficult for them and then
there they have to go otherwise and they
have to look for the other biotechnology
Institute where they can be taught
biology say I get many students coming
and trying to understand neither Network
so they come to us to say understand
about the neon biology that that way it
works so uh there is a both give and
take both as distinct pathway so if
you're going with the bioinformatics
there is a one pathway going with the
competition biology different pathway
but there is a scope to work together
see I am uh basically a wet lab and I
have read books of the Andrew and I have
learned from them so I have a student Dr
Henry never probably never met him he
doesn't know but I am an indirect
student of him there are two books I
have learned so the learning is the
continuous phenomena and PhD as you know
is a tough thing so if you love your job
in a PhD you can get things done then
but you have to have a beginning whether
you are going to be a buyer fermentation
or computational biology both requires
help that's how it will work
yeah thank you thank you so much so yeah
I'm I totally agree with you that uh
Professor it's it's a pleasure to have
Professor Lynn here with us because uh
his name in ban formatic we know from
the very beginning uh like from 2000 we
have been hearing his name and uh like
for like renowned Persona and
bioinformatics so I think that's a that
it's a good question for you so to tell
us about opportunities in this area like
how you have seen this field uh evolving
in a good way uh for for people or
students or researchers to take more
participation in this and what are the
opportunities that are there in India uh
right now as you see this entire field
evolving
but not a very easy question to answer
just as the impact of the NEP is also
not very easy because it's too
disruptive a change uh the big shift in
India at the moment is the pressure and
push towards entrepreneurship and
startups even funding is in that
direction both from government as well
as others uh so I think that you should
look at basically the panel over here if
I'm a teacher to many of the respected
professors like Professor Gupta I'm also
to hold to make such a comment on the
future but both of them have very good
backgrounds which I'd like to actually
use as a base see Professor guptas uh
Veterinary scientist of some background
and has used data-driven science in his
work over the last 10 years and pankaj
is much younger bioinformatician who's
actually done by informatics as a PhD
before coming back to the country to
lead these kind of programs see the
thing is that this was something of the
burst what has happened with the large
amount of data is that really speaking
we can think in terms of some algorithms
but we really need to look at computer
scientists to develop them we can be as
Professor Gupta said you can use tools
relatively easy because we own the data
and we're generating the data okay so
the answer to the question is if I was
20 years old what would I do it's not
that the excitement is not there the
search problems are really really very
exciting for instance the one that I
started when I was 20 on protein folding
which got solved with Alpha fold and
that was deep learning right so now
these kind of research problems are
being solved with many of the tools that
we've come up with in computational
biology and because they are data driven
there are models that we can use now
what is the kind of job that the being
enmeshed in these research problems as
part of your training is a real
opportunity for someone in the 20s you
can do it either as a PhD but then that
would be a longer term
so where are the startups it's hard to
say I think they are largely in health
Diagnostics and in agriculture so Health
Diagnostics and not yet in therapy
because it's much much easier to look
for Diagnostics and AI is very very big
examples for instance can you use
volatile matter can you use sound waves
for detecting tuberculosis what has
already been done is image analysis
x-ray based identification for diseases
using image analysis etc etc so that's
the low hanging fruit and a lot of
startups are coming up in that area I
think icmr has a panel of these kind of
tools and app development is another
side field Because the actual put push
is what we call Edge devices which you
have to have on the mobile for instance
if you want a farmer in the field to
detect what disease is present in the
crop he should be able to take a
photograph from his mobile phone and you
have the back end and you have the tools
to be able to detect that and develop
that kind of tool so startup space is
the area that we really need to push
towards and if you're part of a larger
program the short answer to your NEP is
that the 40 of your program
theoretically can be done using online
courses or courses outside of your main
institution and you have an academic
Bank of credits the quality control is
not very uh sure about what's happening
over there so really speaking if you
look look at real quality we're looking
at what are you getting out of it have
you been able to write out Publications
for instance in a research field or are
you developing an app that is going into
use
so if I'm taking two examples let's say
diagnosis can I detect disease from a
cough sound from the mobile phone now
that is already available as laptop it
has to be rapidly developed as an app
and then it has to be scaled up now this
kind of startup space is in incubators
I'm not sure of the quality of
incubators within Indian institutions
but I would think that the iits and the
nits are much better than a normal
university not in being able to scale up
not necessarily in the ideas or getting
banned
okay so that is where you should look
the short answer is uh if I'm in my 20s
I would take a big risk and do startup
space I should get a salary in startup
and I should be able to learn on this
side uh from platforms such as yours and
for that purpose you should probably
link up with institutions of repute like
the iits and nits so that uh some sort
of the affiliation tag can be associated
with The Learning Experience
and as the professor Gupta said they
themselves share a lot of their learning
tools because nptel has been there from
the early 2000s the platform has changed
Because The Internet Is Now 4G has made
it far more permissible it used to be
based on desktop based internet learning
which was not very easy and but because
of covet online learning has become the
New Normal and we have to learn how to
break with it so back again startup
space
thank you that was very like okay yeah
I would like to add further to what Dr
Andrew said that when we think of
bioinformatics or when you think on
computational biology the journal
perception people take it just analyzing
the DNA data or other data I'll put in
data that's right but we have to move
beyond that bioinformatics it goes
beyond that including medical
informatics image analysis sound
analysis say for example in our country
it's not that popular it's slowly
picking up but in other countries say
for example the following the
progression of physical cancer Theory so
a set of kits are available where say in
one go 384 genes can be tested for snps
or the year so whether the drug is
working or not working with the
similarly for HIV those tests are
available where you need the analysis of
the data sets the two follow-up whether
this is working or not working so one of
my students was working on the data
Medical Center they use the mathematics
for deciding whether the bone marrow
transplantation has to be done and
patient or not to be done that was to my
surprise what they do is
they have the position called by
informatician for that purpose what they
do is when before transplantation they
go for the uh the whole genome
sequencing of that uh what the idea
there and there are some marker
mutations are there which are suggestive
whether the transplantation will be
successful or will be a failure those
are known and they try to analyze those
uh mutations within them and then take a
call they will panel will sit down along
with the byte medicines and the doctors
and then decide whether the
transplantation has to be done or not so
biometric doesn't remain with the
research level it has gone to the
medical field I also Recall now uh one
of the
protein powder selling company that
muscle Blaze no so we had discussions
with them see they are now coming up
with the technologists there with others
so when you know you have to just take a
saliva sample send it to them and they
do a profiling and there are set of
genes which they will analyze uh for
specific for muscle tissue specific for
diabetic people specific for the say uh
lactose sorry lactose in problems and so
on or the specific some British
positions or some diseases those kids
are there and then they do analysis of
set of genes which may have impact on
them and then they suggest which product
might be useful for you or what kind of
diets you'll be used to this is there in
the market that's that's the place where
the biomatic is a must buy information
is a must to analyze those genetic data
so it's there in the diagnostic it is
then the Healthcare Management it is
there decided for the transplantation
and as Dr Anthony said
Precision farming School based on the
data analysis so when we think of the
biomatics I think we have to go beyond
simply instead of thinking that the
analysis and predicting a data set or
predicting the molecular structure or
predicting how the genes will interact
it has application and they are there in
the field less known to be
yes absolutely agree to all of this and
this is like a really valuable
suggestions to and I think the audience
is here are really uh appreciate the
same and I've been learning with all of
these suggestions that you have shared
with us so uh I think uh What uh what
has been suggested is the understanding
of the translational application and now
uh we see bioinformatics being used uh
for product development so I think when
you talk about startup it's about
understanding that there is a need which
is directly related to the uh to the
people and you can think about these
different problems and then think about
a product that could help them uh with
the with their problems and that product
is coming from
data analysis by basically
bioinformatics even from the very
beginning what we were doing is like
doing a lot of comparison so uh that
helps us understand how it could be
useful for a variety of like
personalized problems that we are trying
to figure out from nutrition to what
kind of food we should eat whether I
would get you know
um uh whether I can lose weight weight
or not so there are so many areas where
there's a whole lot of business that has
been done through supplements through
all of these different things that are
there in the market where there's a need
of more specialized uh um products with
the help of data that gives us very
great like great insights and is much
more reliable and trustworthy to you
know go for so I think yeah and that's
absolutely
um something that I think everyone
should take a note of and start thinking
in that direction
so thank you so much for the suggestion
so and we yeah I just just want to add
two more things like uh one thing that I
think both panelists have already uh
greatly emphasized so this is what we
are talking about digital digitalization
of Health Care so digital Healthcare it
is going it is currently actually in
totally in very demand and in coming
years we will see that lot of
digitalization will be happening where
we can you know use apps and Etc to even
check uh several those lot of diagnosis
at ourselves as well so digitalization
is a huge uh going to be huge demand for
the upcoming generation also in in the
bioinformatics will also a lot of
bioinformatizations will also be kind of
being involved in this uh kind of in in
this domain
and in India I think what we are going
to also see is that there is a huge
huge kind of increase in the volume of
the the data that we are going to
generate and there also we will need a
lot of people who should be scaled or
enough to handle and analyze their data
so I I would just say that to the
audience that the huge there is a huge
scope and
a lot of opportunities will be opening
up in the coming time so yeah so I just
want to motivate them
no thank you thank you pankaj I think we
are in sync I was going to ask you the
same things but uh you rightly summarize
the entire uh entire panel discussion
and thank you so much for all the
panelists for for participating today
and joining us in this research
Symposium we are so much grateful and I
think the audience have really benefited
we have a lot of students here and we
are also live on our YouTube channel
where there are a lot of students there
as well so thank you so much for your
time and thank you so much for
participating and giving us your
insights from your experience so uh we
would have another session next session
which is uh student poster presentation
I think students are really excited for
this part of the uh part of the
Symposium and without further delay I'd
like to invite srivari to summarize the
panel discussion and move to the poster
presentation session and again I mean
personally the doctor Professor Lynn and
Professor Mukesh and uh pankaj for their
time and for these uh wonderful
discussions thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you so much everyone uh Dr Lin Dr
Gupta Dr yadav I was such an engaging
and insightful family I want to take
this opportunity to quickly summarize
the points that were discussed quickly
we discussed the need for data fine
education for all life sciences students
and equipping them with students and
skills they need to analyze and
interpret the what amounts of data
generated and we also discussed about
how it is impacting Healthcare
biological and Life Science Education
and we also discussed the integration of
hybrid learning and challenges faced by
universities uh in implementing taken
together I want to thank our esteem
panelists for taking the time out of
their hectic schedule and sharing their
knowledge and expertise on these topics
so so far we discussed about some of uh
areas of academic research in biological
data
and we also covered some of the ways one
can get involved in these research books
but students worldwide they often lack
the opportunity to showcase their
research work after completing a project
therefore our Symposium encourages
students to participate in a post
representation competition which is a
great way to share their research
project interact with fellow researchers
and get instant feedback on their work
it also serves as a variable networking
opportunity and allows them to forge new
relationships for future collaborations
and this year's theme for poster
presentation where omix and Brian
married AI machine learning and data
kind astrobiology and space omics
computational biology in biotechnology
and pharmaceutical industry the
submission was open to all registered
participants from high school
undergraduate graduate and postgraduate
at Blackpool citizen science project now
let me also take a brief moment to
introduce you to the panel of Judges who
will be reviewing the project Works Dr
Ramesh Kumar associate professor School
of Allied Health Sciences from Brevard
University Dr Priyanka Nara assistant
professor Institute of biotechnology
Amity University Dr Julia Penner
associate director Tower Vines
management Research Center University of
Haifa and Dr Mohit lazindar director and
data scientist at Pine biotech USA the
presentations will be judged in four
categories that is introduction methods
and results discussion conclusion and
finally the presentation quality the
best posters will be selected by the
judges for prizes in different
categories best technical research
project on a competitive topic promising
research direction for future potential
and finally most Innovative approach in
an established way the guidelines for
the competition are very simple
participants will be given five minutes
to press in their poster once the time
is up we'll have to stop your
presentation and move on to the next
candidate so kindly make sure that you
complete your reputation within five
minutes so that let us invite the very
first participant of the posted
recitation competition Ariana F Rahman
who will be presenting her project on a
novel deep learning predictor for post
therapeutic breast cancer recurrence
risk using a multi-ohmic data
integration paper
over to you again
hello my name is Ariana
and
I
share my screen
and
this is my poster
and my project is on a novel deep
learning predictor for the Post
therapeutic breast cancer reoccurrence
risk using multi-ohomish data throughput
so
over the last few decades many breast
cancer patients have become disease free
because of the many advances in early
detection in diagnoses as well as
treatment of breast cancer
however for
this breast cancer can come back for
almost 30 percent of patients who were
disease-free after initial treatment
and this is called reoccurrence
so reoccurrence can return after
post-treatment and current methods of
recurrence risk prediction use clinical
or phenotypic characteristics such as
age tumor stage or menopause and other
biological factors and while these
characteristics are certainly helpful
they may not give a complete
understanding of the underlying genetic
causes for the reoccurrence
so by using multiomics data risk
prediction of tumor reoccurrence can be
used to make effective treatment
decisions and Aid in the survival
outcome of patients
so ultimately the aim of the study is to
use this data in order to identify a
marker list of Gene variation and an
expression for the patient
stratification based on their tumor
regression status
so in order to find these genetic causes
or underlying
um
yeah
um first we have to take a look at the
data and
that's why I conducted PCA to understand
the features of the data and
here we can see that the data clusters
around the ER status whether it's
negative or positive and it does not
cluster around disease-free or
reoccurred
So based on the observations above the
estrogen receptor status seems to be
masking the data representation of the
samples due to their tumor regression
status
and so in order to correct for this
confounding Factor an autoencoder which
is a deep learning non-linear based
embedding approach was used to get the
single representation from both the
omics data like copy number alteration
and the MRNA data while also
simultaneously adjusting for the
confounding factors
and so
this integrated data from Amy is then
taken and applied to random Forest which
will classify it into disease-free and
tumor regressed categories
so once the data was corrected for the
ER status
the accuracy of the model was actually
um at first without adjusting for it
almost like a coin toss approximately 50
but after it was adjusted for then that
accuracy Rose to almost 96 and this was
after cross validation with multiple
data sets outside of just the tcga the C
bio portal data set I used
and so what the ultimate output of this
is is a 25 most highly important genes
toward the tumor reoccurrence which is
shown in this this heat map above
and
some preliminary conclusions can be made
such as some of these genes are more
immune related such as Stat one and so
this might tell us a little bit about
how
reoccurrence might be more about the
body's ability to fight off the last
remaining cells that are cancerous
rather than how initial treatment which
is using like radiotherapy or
chemotherapy to quite often show cancer
cells
and we can see that in the PCA after it
has been the ER status has been adjusted
for that it no longer separates it no
longer clusters by the ER status
and instead it now does cluster in the
disease free versus the reoccurred
and eventually the clinical application
of this would be that this was made into
a pipeline that takes the
tumor record or the disease-free
patients their data and through the auto
encoder and with only 25 genes it will
give the probability of a patient from
of how probable it is that their cancer
will reoccur and I use that in a web app
so this web app with the information
that the patient provides will
generate a probability score from
based on their either mRNA data or their
copy number alteration data
and this will definitely be helpful
toward
um improving diagnoses accuracy along
with
the
initial predictions of
the treatment plan as well as helpful in
clinical decision making and in low
resource settings it can be used for a
much more Speedy reoccurrence prediction
and this doesn't just have to be limited
toward breast cancer specifically it can
be applied to
many other cancers as well
and it can also include other omics data
so my project initially used mutation
data and and micro RNA data as well but
since the sample size was so limited it
and it was very sparse they weren't
covered in this project but eventually a
more diverse like integration strategy
could combine other data sets that have
mutation data and micro RNA data in
order to
make a more multi-omics project and
it can go beyond the genetic level as
well into more into the central dogma
like it can go into a protein to protein
interaction Network that can be used for
further therapeutic applications
and that's my project thank you for
listening and I'd be glad to listen to
your feedback
thank you so much Ariana I would like to
pass on the stage to Dr Julia to hear
her feedback about the project
thank you very much for sharing was a
very interesting
um
I don't think I have a full
understanding of the I forgot the name
Amy right
of the exact procedure that you do uh
that you do to differentiate but can I
ask you why exactly you uh wanted to
take away this factor of uh er
um I mean
you saw that it differentiates on the PC
uh right
right but maybe it does have you know a
biological meaning that the sound
so why did you anyways decide to take
that factor away
just a question yeah no uh totally valid
and ER
status is very important for breast
cancer specifically
um like women with their estrogen
receptor positive it's been shown like
their cancer affinity and and there's of
course linkages to this status it's very
important but in the in my data it was
clustering by the ER status
and this was like masking the data
representation because it wasn't
clustering by these disease-free verses
reoccurred uh sorry this is kind of
small but
um there are like circles and triangles
and
um
that's like disease
oh sorry no I mean um yeah yeah here uh
like see how all the red and blue are
like mixed together
um and this is by like the disease-free
status so all of it's like mixed and it
doesn't show like separation between
disease-free and reoccurred so the
what's causing the reoccurrence or these
genes like ultimately the PCA shows
features which are the genes and so if
it doesn't cluster by disease free or
reoccurred it's not showing which genes
are the most important toward the sphere
cards and instead it would cluster by
the ER status so definitely like you
said the ER status is important but
since it's causing the
um distribution to not cluster by the
disease free and reoccurred it's
um therefore it can't be seen what
the top genes are in order to find what
the reoccurred like find the best genes
for reoccurrence prediction
very impressive work I must say I'm
really impressed thank you very much
very nice
thank you so much
so with that now I would like to pass on
stage to the next participant of the
poster presentation uh which is Umesh
Kumar he will be explaining this project
on exploring the microbiome in cat and
understanding the role of microbial
Community influine Health and
so that the stage is on yours
you seem to be on mute could you please
unmute yourself yes
hello everyone
um so the topic that I am going to cover
today is like the exploring the
microbial Community uh in cats itself
so
as you all know like most of the
diseases nowadays is actually spreading
um
but even viruses are actually
transmitting from uh from a different
species to human beings so in order to
understand the future
or a future we predict the future
diseases that is going to occur as you
all know like we are more more close to
felines like including cats dogs and so
so most of the diseases that is going to
be like spreading in the generation in
the coming time will be or also from
cats itself cats or dogs itself like the
most probably
so in order to identify such kind of
potential candidate like the mutations
that is going to happen in the near
future like I am conducting a study
which actually disclosed the number of
bacterial community that is there in the
uh cat speciesism
so
I actually done uh this using tape IO
server only
um with uh
analyze tool like I actually found close
to
um
I actually studied a genomic data which
is containing like four different
samples and that sample
um is of fecal samples or a pharyngeal
samples
fluid samples and also from blood
and II the data is actually for six
different kind of cans and that also
include males as well as females so in
all this study like uh
um after going through the analysis like
the I found that more than
um 70 to 80 bacterias are actually there
in the fecal sample I know
so most of the times like most of the uh
like from my perspective like I thought
like the most of the samples will be
there in the vehicle but
um
actually the thing was not like that
like it was actually from oropharyngeal
samples that I I found the most number
of abandoned communities out there so
more than 80 plus uh bacterial
communities were there in the
um
was the second uh second highest
followed by broncovascular fluid samples
and
in most of the samples here the
bacterial series like a was you can
actually find Battery soda is in quite a
lot number uh like when we actually
discuss about the fecal samples like the
most of the sample most of the Abington
Community was from bacteria family in
oropharyngeal Sample it was actually
from a pastoral assemble a pastorala
so even even with that like uh
um even you can uh from the analysis
like we actually find quite of like
different kind of
um different kind of data itself like
um the data that is the bacterial
community that is actually there in the
male samples was not seen in the
female's number if I would like
um if I would uh point it out like uh
some species of bacteria this was more
abundant in female cats compared in
fecal uh but in the male sample it was
more of like bacteriocetism so if you
physio bacteria sample was more and when
it come to
um oropharyngeal sample pseudomondase
was more in male compared to a pastoral
sample in that in female
um even the same Trend you can actually
see in Bronco vascular sample also like
uh where pseudomondase was more in
female cares while uh Spencer bacterias
were more in like a blood uh
so with that in mind like um uh that
actually
um helped me do just to uh like come to
a conclusion like even with the genders
like the bacterial Community can
actually varies
um even with gender even with the
physical condition and even with the
different sites itself like um the fecal
as I already told the fecal was the
exception the expectation was the fecal
he would be having more uh more a
bacteria a material Community but
oropharyngeal was the most abundant so
this actually proves that like as uh the
oral region like oropharyngeal or the
oral region that the cat used to like
um link or even bite us like in the
future a future generation like more
possibilities are actually the from from
that uh like from the feline like more
than different kind of bacteria can even
the possibility of transferring is there
to humans are there and in the future
um in the future analysis I would like
to study more about the bacterial
Community the different kind of Gene
that is actually there in the particular
family which can actually transmit it to
the human human Community itself and if
from that analysis I I can say that like
by
um by stopping the future by studying
the future mutation like the mutation
syndrome we can actually find a
different kind of treatment plant in the
coming generation itself so
that is all about my posture if you have
some query like I would like to here um
answer your questions thank you
thank you so much Ramesh for that
presentation and to share judges
feedback I would like to pass on the
stage to Dr Priyanka naral ma'am could
you please share your feedback
oh yes oh am I Audible
yes
okay uh thank you omish for your
presentation and it is indeed an a nice
work I just have a few questions for you
the first thing is that uh in your uh
poster you've taken one sample right
so how many actually I took like four
different
um kind of samples including like four
different kind of samples from six
different kind of cat species species
coming from a single study because the
accession number is one so I believe
you've taken from one study right
yeah one study only okay actually it was
actually having like the six different
uh kind of cat species they actually
study like six different kind of cat
species in there
and what was the total sample size how
many samples did they process
so they actually
uh no or they actually proceeded like
more than 80 plus 80 plus samples
okay and since you are talking about
males and females did you also try to
look at how many emails and how many
females were in the sample size
yeah the total form of four females were
there and the two males were
four females and two males yes
okay
and 80 samples right
yes
okay and then you process them using
okay you process them using sorry
T bio info yeah yes okay okay great so
these were 16s are in it was their
metadata also available did you look at
that yeah
so in your analysis did you also include
the metadata or this is just based on
the uh bacterial Co abundance
oh this is actually based on bacterial
carbon density
okay so any of these bacterias which you
have identified any of this is something
which is not known prior in cats did you
get something which is so there are more
than uh in fickle sample I actually find
more than 50 plus that were not been
discovered in any of the studies before
like 30 plus in oropharyngeal symbol
then
um close to 10 in Blood and in 30 other
13 or a bronchovascular samples
okay great so these are also gender
specific
yeah these are also gender specific
so just a suggestion you can go ahead
and find out whether these bacterias are
going to be beneficial or causing some
yeah even I had the debtors like I
didn't add this in the poster because I
was able to publish this paper itself so
actually like even the different
um activities that they actually uh
um like that is actually creating in the
uh
um cash body itself I actually noticed
few of them few of the changes that
these bacterias are causing yes yeah so
positive or negative interaction can be
explored
so more than uh like uh if I would like
to say in total like more than 40
percentage uh the bacterias were like
beneficial and the 60 percentage of the
15 days were like yeah 60 days bad
bacteria and 40 40 more than 40
percentage like good bacteria
okay thank you great workers thank you
thank you
thank you so much
for that one of his presentation and
next I would like to invite shimasha
into me who will be presenting her
poster on exploring the role of circular
RNA and micro RNA Gene interactions in
Parkinson's disease using transcriptomic
profiling or peripheral blood
mononuclear cells
it looks like you are on mute could you
please unmute yourself
[Music]
unmute yourself I have requested ask to
unmute on the zoom
[Music]
we are still not able to hear you
foreign
can you hear us
all right perhaps uh while you're fixing
your audio connection uh we can move on
to the next participant so next
participant is tanmoy biswal uh who will
be presenting his poster on exploration
of the intestinal microbiota regulated
by high fiber and high fermented diet
so over to Utah
yeah thank you for providing me with
this opportunity I'm just getting ready
in my poster
yeah
can you see my video
we can see yours three yes
so actually now let's go to the
introduction part so this is about the
factors that influence the gut microbes
the uh
the health issues that they cause
the technology that can be used to
determine this gut microbes the positive
changes that they have on our life
the uh The Chronic and the diseases the
interactions with immune systems and
immune responses that they play there
are there are several thousands of gut
microbes that play a key role in immune
system developing our immune responses
training our body against foreign
Invaders so
the introduction part just gives us a
brief information about that so I have
used the TV info service time to
Pipeline and our programs to develop
this
uh this project so first of all you see
in the top picture that is the
uh
that is the function that the gut micros
performs and what role that they perform
in the body and second picture is about
the uh microbiomes effect and how it is
processed and the primer setups that is
typically used in
while determining this kind of analysis
now we come down to the metagenomic
component analysis
here I have used the chime2 pipelines
and the pipeline is totally being
explained here from every step by step
so I am not going into the details of
the pipeline so pipelines basically
gives us otus that is operational
taxonomic units and asvs that is used to
determine the taxonomic proportionate
abundance plot
then we go to the 16s Downstream
analysis of uh
rrna data
mRNA data so this gives us otus
where we take out that otu tables and
ASB tables and compare it with the
metadata and then we about to know then
we get to know about the diversity their
abundance from the metadata plot then we
can do statistical analysis
yeah using statistical analysis of that
uh
taxonomic abundance bar plot so this is
the downstream analysis first we do the
downstream analysis we have to load the
libraries and the metrics then we unify
the informations that are present in the
otus and the ASP tables
and then we go then we get the taxonomy
compositions of the samples uh using
Alpha diversity beta diversity and we
got the taxonomic abundance bar plot
now as we come down to the results Parts
the results are clearly interesting to
me I did not expect this kind of results
the alpha diversity is basically uh
measures the diversity within a single
sample so I did not see any change
during both the dots
over both the dads did not show any
significant change using Shannon and
child diversity but
in uh while measuring the time points
there were some changes in the time
points and uh the people consuming the
fermented that shows more much more
microbial abundance
compared to the fiber debt now when we
come to a beta diversity beta diversity
was showing change uh showing changes
between the first week samples and the
nine tweak samples
between the high fiber and high
fermented ads so these studies were not
clear
what were the exact rule then we dig
down to the
uh phylogenetic tree analysis the
phylogenetic
uh phylogenetic 3 analysis for that we
have done the phylogenetic tree and it
suggests that some phylums of uh some
pile of bacteria class bacteriality
shows more growth in fiber rigida and
one was showing in fermented that so
from there we can draw a conclusion that
lower lower groups such as the order
class or family levels such as must have
shown different kind of bacterial
diversity there so I have gone with the
proportionate
taxonomic proportionate abundance bar
plot in this
in this comparing the major uh major
failures and there was an important
thing to notice was that out of six
samples
in the ninth week
three samples of high fiber diet were
completely missing actino bacteria so
which was
not
overall good in the perspective of the
studies
so when we come down to the statistical
analysis and finding the unclassified
genus species and uh
uh uh families of these so there were
there were about many uh in the family
level we are we are getting some little
bit uh of media uh
the median fiber median fiber was that
2.4 and the median of fermented diet was
4.5 so commented that was having much
more Unknown about unknown
unclassified families and same with the
genus level and when we come down to a
species level it was just
uh out of
200 200 uh 1000
255 species were present in the otus
60 to 70 were Mark uh unclassified in
some samples it was down to 48 and some
cases it was high up to high up to 90
percent
so this is the data chart that we
present of uh that we get
from that firmicutes were less abundant
in high fiber compared to a fermented an
actino bacteria which is showing much
more in uh
fiber diet
but at the latter stage of the actino
vectoration disappears from three of the
samples
and when we come down to the discussion
and conclusion part is that uh there is
less uh less abundance of unclassified
families and genuses of bacteria and
fiber fiber that compared to fermented
diet and
we also know that a proteobacteria that
plays a key role in gut health
so proteobacterial level was okay but
the actinobacteria was missing in three
samples out of the six in the final week
so and further think that it is very
much hard to understand from this study
that what is the exact role of gut
microbes because we don't know
species level interaction of
almost every samples because 60 to 75
and 60 to 70 percent of the species are
still missing and we have to discover it
using the wet lab techniques and without
understanding their role we can't
get the role of we can't get to know the
role of the true potential of the gut
microbes that is present in our body and
what kind of exact functions that they
do and how they interact with our body
in training our immune systems and
developing other
other functions that is synthesizing of
uh vitamins and production of small
chain fatty acids
Etc so we have to
no get to know more about these things
and I would be this is just the tip of
the iceberg as I am saying because much
more thing has to be discovered
and just minutes
okay okay ma'am I'm done so it is very
much important to understand
the role of the gut microbes and further
studies using single cell RNA single
cells
RNA status that we can discover more
about this thank you and I'm ending this
and I'm listening for your feedback that
you can provide me
thank you so much so to attend uh to
your poster I would like to invite Dr
Ramesh to share his feedback
yeah okay okay
oh wow okay okay
you have a certain very nice Eternal
system but I have one carry over there
so we did it that uh fiber diet that and
then fermented dietary analysis is
correct so this fermented diet or
covered it which were actually inducing
it like a increasing that Alpha
diversity more or it is a better
diversity move so because uh you know
that is actually that good bacteria
okay so it's important for which we have
to prepare like a fiber diet also and
even fermented Diet also so what is your
opinion to increase that Alpha diversity
you have to take that more fiber suppose
you want to increase that bitter
diversity suppose like a good bacteria
it is belonging to Beta diversity what
is your opinion
so in my opinion is that we should take
a balanced diet because the groups of
bacterias in each have their own
functions and they provide their own
ways of if there is an imbalance so the
body functioning may be hampered because
both groups of bacteria whether it's
fiber or fermented they have their own
rules and they should not be
uh changed means you can do it to our ex
experiment point of view but they play a
crucial role
in human health so I think people should
have a balanced diet instead of going
for high fiber or high fermented so
balanced diet is required
okay okay okay so it's very good
analysis to have done but yeah so that
is uh fine carry otherwise all are fine
we have done that okay
okay thank you thank you so much
thank you so much
for joining the first presentation
competition so with that let me quickly
share my screen and start this next
session
all right so I hope so far all the
attendees enjoy the first part of omen 3
sets both in 2023 which focused on
branchmatic education at home
exploitation we have learned about the
various class forms and initiatives that
are shaping the future of biological
data analysis now it is my great
pleasure to invite you to the next part
of the Symposium which will focus on
omix Project Africa the sessions will
showcase the very initiative challenges
and opportunities in the field of
biological data analysis in Africa so
without further delay please join me in
welcoming our neck Pika Mr adekunle Mr
Adler boy is a molecular scientist and
academic who is equally attract
enthusiasts with a professional
background as a medical laboratory
I would like to request the partition to
please the mutual thanks
currently he's the faculty at the lead
City University in Nigeria he is also
the founder of the research Mentor
program undergraduate research education
and knowledge acquisition traineeship
his ongoing research interest includes
molecular biology and genomic so the
focus on molecular characterization of
hepatitis B viral infection
he is also presently the director of
only project Africa program of fine
biotech USA a project that aims to
provide ease of access and to work
capacity building in Big Data fine for
teaching and research
so with that introduction now I'd like
to pass on the stage to omic Sergeant
Africa
to take to solved
hello thank you very much
um
um I'd like to please ask for permission
to share my screen
sorry you already have the permission to
share your screen can you please check
okay okay thank you
please let me know if when you can see
my screen
it is loading up
um
yeah we can see a screen but it's not
proportional so
yes now we can see your screen
is it better now
yes
okay great good afternoon everyone from
this part of the world
um I'm happy to be part of
eod's afternoon to participate at the
omics research Museum in 2023
March Edition and
um in these in the next few minutes or
let me see an hour so you will be
um with us here on the UMES logic
African team
um where we'll be sharing some of our
work and equally have no table speakers
from this part of the globe speaking to
participants across um the world so um
once again I want to welcome all the
participants and to these who makes
research Symposium and I want to
appreciate the omics logic Asia team for
what they've been doing since the
beginning of this program
so um quickly we are moving on into the
African session uh within the next hour
or so on um we'll be looking at the
women's logical Africa programs scope of
the informative programs we are running
here as well as researches within uh the
African continent we equally be taking
two important keynote presentations by
two notable Scholars of repute
um the first person will be akintola who
is a fellow and um
he will be talking to us on the need for
more informaticians in Africa
um also moving on will be speak we'll be
having um Dr a local Jews speaking with
us on the role of bioinformatics and
livestock Improvement
um here in in Africa particularly from
her own research
um Endeavors Dr Shalom
academics and also an industry
professional
um being a registered animal scientist
and so she'll be sharing with us from
her works and we hope to have a good
time you know with that session and last
but not the least under the African
women's logic African session we will be
having a panel session we'll be having
some
um you know panelists discussing around
capitalizing the potential of
bioinformatics research for Africa's
Economic Development
um but before then um quickly allow me
to introduce myself my name
you know with the lead City University
here in Nigeria I'm equally an associate
of the medical Library science Council
of Nigeria as earlier introduced
um currently the program director for
Comics logic Africa so moving on this
afternoon I will be talking to Ross
about the women's logic Africa programs
within the next 10 minutes where I'll be
giving an overview introduction on what
we've been doing on the on our training
programs and also talk about partnership
strikes we've had with you know several
institutions you know to advance
bioinformatics on the continent so the
almost logic set of informatics and Big
Data analysis training programs you know
of the Primal Tech USC which has been
globally proven by peer reviews and
curriculum experts in partner
institutions and that the program has
been conducted you know explores to help
close the need gaps that exist with
regards to bioinformatics Education and
Training and you know globally and of
course this is of great importance for
us here in Africa in terms of I mean
building
um this scientific capacities among
students and young professionals as well
as researchers and faculties across the
continent and so
um the postulation we are working with
at Comics logic Africa you know that is
anchored by Eureka is that by
increasingly advancing the knowledge of
bioinformatics and its using obtaining
scientific insights from sequence data
um you know there would be a significant
growth and development of the
bioinformatics community in Africa and
also its considerable implications for
translational research and you know
practices Amino that will help improve
health care and other key and you know
functional areas you know in the in the
in the scientific community and the
society at Large
of course we're looking at you know how
this can impact on biology generally
agricultural medicine and several other
aspects of human enemies and so the goal
of women's logic programs is therefore
to provide this training in
bioinformatics to enable our students
clinicians as well as faculty and
researchers of all backgrounds to
develop his novel independent research
guided um you know skill sets and you
know be able to utilize this to you know
Advance their work and practices
and so um the homeless electric program
boosts everything a participant actually
needs to get started and grow in the
bioinformatics and Big Data analysis
space for scientific research and and
practice our program of course combines
online iterative sessions
um as well as safe guided study
materials practical assignments for an
immersive experience all of which have
been proven to be effective in our
well-known and respected omics logic by
informatics
hello so hello can you hear me
yes yes we can hear you
so why did
hello can you hear me
hello can you hear me yes yes yes
we follow
okay sorry I think there was an internet
glitch day so um so why the intra degree
interest is informatics and Big Data
analysis continues to improve in the
African region
um definitely we at home is logic Africa
and Eureka we have positioned to provide
the plug necessary to help many gained
many many participants and researchers
and students gain these um you know
skill set for utilization in their own
personal research and scientific uh you
know Endeavors and the focus of this of
course is to help capitalize development
of bioinformatics researches and omic
science generally within the continent
and also to subsequently of course
benefit the entire continent with
um the the outcome the outputs of these
scientific Endeavors and so we are glad
that we we are the homies logic African
team with our training programs you know
um anchored by the point biotech
Incorporated
um USA is you know helping to fill these
gaps that is
um you know found to exist particularly
with the uh with the con within the
continent from the perspective of
infrastructure uh you know gaps and um
some of the programs we've been able to
you know coordinate within the space of
our practice over the years include data
science for biologists as far back as
you know
um May 2021
um you know we also organized data
science for biologies program you know
in 2022 as well and equally we've had a
several introductory programs you know
introduction to bioinformatics training
where we bring you know participants
from different backgrounds to come to
appreciate the import of informatics you
know in in in the science environment
today and um lately in December 2022
um the latest program was the
introduction introductory by informatics
Workshop which has about 392
participants that range across you know
several countries here in Africa and we
equally have some party coupons joining
us from you know other parts of the
world including Pakistan India and some
other locations around the globe it was
a huge success
um you know a program that was designed
to introduce many to the field of
bioinformatics and again we organized um
you know other high impact training such
as um genomics Workshop as well as
omics logic metagenomics Workshop all of
which you know have participants moving
on from these basic trainings to our
research fellowship program and so some
of the training program participants
that has gone through the program
includes team Matthew and these are some
of the you know lores that these
participants have gone on to accomplish
why you know undergoing our training we
equally have good job who is a
pharmaceutical microbiologist and I've
seen her practice and application of
keyboard informatics Concept in our
practice and you know significant
efficiently enhanced all right including
we also have Giselle Florida who is from
Cameroon okay um so like I said we cover
um you know we we organize these
trainings and bring a lot of
participants across the continent to
participate in our trainings so um
you know have seen ourselves prepared to
take on her research in her you know
postgraduate Diplo I'm sorry PhD
training program and of course the
homies logic training played some
significant roles in that end level so
we have also been able to forge notable
Partnerships with institutions towards
integrating our handsome Mentor driven
and globally proven training methods and
resources into University education both
at undergraduate and postgraduate levels
so as to help scale the you know the
growth of bioinformatics and the use of
bioinformatics in researches across
these institutions I'm I'm glad to see
that we also have some other
institutions
um you know in the works in the recent
times we are having talks with them
among which uh University of Port
Harcourt as well as University of
Illinois and also Lagos State University
surface to mention that similarly almost
logic African team has participated in a
number of scientific workshops and you
know and trainings conferences one of
which is the Nigerian bioinformatics and
genomics network
um Workshop where we presented on
experimenting with 21st century
e-learning design for bridging
bioinformatics education gaps in Africa
using the umiz logic as a test case
and moving on to I like to at this point
mention our next training program which
is around the corner
um to start to bioinformatics was shot
from training to project design and
Publishing this is a program that seeks
to start from the introductory beginner
level with participants in that workshop
and ultimately you know move the
participants to the focus trainings with
different specialization that applies to
individuals and talk about metagenomics
genomics and facials diseases predictive
medicine okay and ultimately lead these
participants to the stage of Designing
their own project and moving on to
presenting or publishing their works so
that feeling will be starting next month
all right and so uh I'll conclude by
saying that Africa is considered to be
the most
um genetically diverse continent on the
planet
um with the potential to contribute
significantly to the field of genomics
research and I'm happy that we are
beginning to I mean see more and more
interest in this respect on the
continent and that is not withstanding
some of the challenges that we have on
the uh you know with
bioinformatics on the continent due to
limited resources and infrastructure
however there's a greater need for
investment and collaborations in order
for us to fully enhance Africa's
potential in the genomics research space
and I'm happy that the women's logic
team is actively playing such an you
know important role here you know
because bioinformatica has become an
indispensable tool for management of
this hugely generated data sets in our
in our Laboratories so uh moving on I
look forward to more and more
collaborations with um institutions and
individuals as well as participants
willing to conduct their research
um you know weeds who makes logic
African team
I like to at this point accurate your
mislogic Africa and the Euro Cup team
um this is a team of individuals working
hard to advance the women's logic
training across Africa and also benefit
some other countries that come to join
our programs so on this note I'd like to
say thank you for listening into what
we've been doing with the homies logic
African programs
so at this point I think I want to hand
over to our community engagement manager
um I am fellow I love it who will be
coordinating the next set of um speaking
engagements we have with notable
speakers we want to learn from this
afternoon
over to you
um
hello doctor and fellow I can hear me
all right thank you so much I can hear
you clearly
so I will be sharing my screen out in a
bit
thank you so much everyone for joining
us I would love us to at this point uh
get ready I see that the next speaker is
quite on ground uh wow that's great so I
will be sharing my screen on the beat
and we will get started
okay
all right I believe you can see my
screen around right everybody
yes we can yes hello can you see my
screen
so once again I welcome everyone
participant to these zombies Comics
Symposium thematic focus on
bioinformatics and data science research
and training uh the African
session focus more on the African
ecosystem and I trust you would uh
actually enjoy what we have brought to
you I am
molecular biologist and genetic expert
from Princeton State University uh with
a path for population genetics and so on
I will talk more about myself in a bit
yeah
hello
are you there
hello can you hear me
yeah yeah you can
yeah we can hear you okay I think
um he might be having some challenges
there so I like to take it up from here
um so we
in our next session we want to invite
our first speaker to take
um the floor now
um
allow me to quickly share my screen so I
can take over from there before
it comes back
okay
so um our next our first speaker for
this afternoon is um
Ashraf akintola
um he will be speaking to us on the need
for mobile information in Africa and
um
researcher an entrepreneur Auto poet and
public speaker who has LED and fellow
colleagues to conduct free online
training and courses in bioinformatics
for beginners at middle level mastering
bioinformatics case
um he is a PhD fellow with research
interest in biomedical convergence
science and technology which is
specialized focus on mitochondrial
genomes of mosquito species of high
medical importance of high medical
importance and our shop also leads an
impact development company with the
Mandate of leading a generation of
impact prosperity and sustainability
among Africans in the area of
bioinformatics data science health
education media and publicity please
welcome with me Ashraf akintola who will
be taking us on the next stopping the
need for bioinformaticians in Africa
um
hello Usher are you there
can you hear me yeah
oh great great please you have the floor
take over from here
thank you so much I really appreciate
the session that I've been able to join
so far
uh I would like to share my screen
to start with
I think my screen is
visible now
yeah we can see it thank you so much uh
thank you so much sir for the
introduction I I remain my humble self I
should have akin to Allah I am a PhD
fellow at kyunk National University here
in Daegu South Korea
and uh I have been given 30 minutes to
discuss the topic the need for more
bioinformaticians in Africa uh I first
of all want to appreciate the uh the
prime biotechnology company in charge of
the omics research Symposium for this
special uh Gathering to bring about
different researchers in different areas
of bioinformatics especially from Africa
origin from out of African origin so
it's important that once this kind of
forum uh is rampant and consistent in
our society a lot of people forget to
know the benefits of being invoked or
what's the bioinformatics as a whole
what's the prospect it has for Humanity
and especially Africans at large so
without boring us with so so much
complexity I would like to go straight
into the topic so my goal is to further
do a sort of orientation or to like to
in another way reorientation because uh
sometimes I know a lot of people that
are here I might have one time or one
way or the other have an interaction
with sports bioinformatics is and maybe
some came just to fit their curiosity so
but to make everyone be on the same
pedestal so that we would understand
each other
uh greatly and to pass the necessary
information that we have to do that we
have to pass is to Define what
bioinformatics really is in the
definitions there are different
definitions of bioinformatics but there
are three important components that
makes up by informatics and these three
important components are once any
country or any continent or any
organization or any uh name it once
they've been able to
address these three issues they buy a
study of biomatics or even Advanced
research in the area of bioinformatics
would be solved so by definition
bioinformatics has three components the
first is the computer software
all the information technology that
surrounds it the second is the database
and the third part is the molecular
biology aspect and why is that by
definition
bioinformatics it involves the
application of computational methods or
computer software or computer analysis
to analyze and interpret biological data
such as DNA sequences protein or gene
expression profiles now in these aspects
the aspect of analyzing biological data
what it used to be was the area of
molecular biology whereby we analyze the
biological data with sequence the DNA
using molecular biological biology
method but as we all know the first
sequence that we have is the sequence of
insulin is the protein insulin so but
now at least we are now using Advanced
Computer Software
to analyze this course to elucidate and
give more information about biological
data and this data are usually stored in
a database so that is where the three
components come into place once we've
been able to address these three
components the issue of bioinformatics
is already addressed now moving on
to the uh topic now that we've had an
idea about what bioinformatics is now
there's a conundrum about Africa being
short-changed being backward regarding
the area of bioinformatics but how do we
address that what are the problems now
the first problem that we have as Africa
because when we want to discuss the need
for mobile information in Africa we have
to understand the problem that we have
presently one problem we have regarding
the first problem that I would like to
discuss in this area of the need for
bioinformatics in Africa is that Africa
lacks the I.T
expertise there are lots of yeah we have
a lot of people who are into Tech we
have andela in Nigeria we have different
uh Tech gurus but there has been little
or less attention has been diverted to
the health aspect of tech to the I.T
aspect to the to to the to the tech to
the technical aspects of Information
Technology aspects of these particular
technological advances even though yes
there are some advancement we have the
andela and the likes but
they are not as popular as we have the
Silicon Valley we have they are not as
popular as we have different
pharmaceutical industries that are using
I.T or computer expertise to address uh
to address
um uh biological uh problems we are
still going to get to that in in the
course of our presentation whereby we
can see how bioinformatics has been able
to provide solution to the problem of
covet 19. we are still going to get to
that if time permits I have 30 minutes
so there is a lack in the IIT sector
there is a lack of expertise in the I.T
sector that will drive that development
in the area of bioinformatics yeah we
have a lot of tech but they are not as
sufficient because in Africa especially
in sub-Saharan Africa we have in Africa
in general Africa accounts for more than
70 17 percent or of the global
population but right now as we are
speaking there is less than three
percent of genetic information that is
present on the databaseata of African
origin that is present in the database
now when it comes to analyzing or
examining these samples
to correspond with other samples we have
shortage of African samples and one of
the main reasons we have in that is the
shortage of that expertise now another
area
of uh the conundrum that Africa is
facing is the power
there is little
like we all know the situation
especially if that we do if we do not
know of any other place I can say of
Nigeria that weed most facts especially
sub-Saharan Africa we are facing the
issue of electricity
and yes we had a lot of talents
regarding the I.T expertise we have the
lot of talent Africa is producing them
dealing day in day out but if you do not
have electricity
you have problem because a computer
cannot run on its own that is why you
will see a lot of startups coming up
with sustainable energy like the solar
the hydro the wind energy just to
supplement the electricity from the
national or National Grid as the case
may be in each country but the problem
of electricity is a problem because when
you are dealing with computer of course
you have to charge and do a lot of
things I can tell you as a matter of
fact that electricity can be the number
one problem facing a lot of
bioinformaticians in Africa because
there are some times you might want to
simulate a an experiment and it will
require a computer system to be on on
what 24 hours just to complete that
experiment but since you are having an
epileptic power supply you might not be
able to achieve that goal electricity is
a problem now we have this governmental
intervention
that is a major issue on its own a lot
of people do not know that in Africa
most African governments apportion less
than 13 of their National yearly budget
to health
or Agriculture and these are areas these
are areas in which bioinformatics comes
to play health and agriculture health
and agriculture but people are not
government in government across Africa
are not given much more attention even
some people when they tell them okay we
have bad information they will ask you
what is bioinformatics I add a personal
experience that I told them that oh I am
doing a sensitization we are doing
sensitization on bioinformatics they ask
you is it Biometrics that people will be
checking their thumb like is it
Biometrics I said we will start to
explain to people there is a vast Gap in
knowledge about bioinformatics in the
continent I will give a personal example
when I was in Nigeria
that was in
2016 when I was doing my master's
program at one of the universities in
Nigeria we were made to go for an
Excursion or a field trip to another
Research Center in another part of the
country when we got there it was a
molecular leverage in molecular biology
laboratory we have shown the
electrophoresis that I've shown the hplc
machine they are showing the Nano drop
we are showing the PCR but a lot of
people that are working in those
research institutes do not even know how
to operate these machines and the little
and those who know how to operate these
machines they are scared to do analysis
or to work on their own because they are
scared that even if they press something
wrong the machine might stop working and
that might mean that their daily bread
will be stopped because they have caused
the damage so that's issue of uh that
yeah we are in the research institute
but we are not doing the research it is
just for photo ops so a lot of research
institutions like that are banned in
Africa whereby the government if they
manage to get the government to do
something they will buy but no research
will be carried out on those using those
machines the expert is to carry out the
to work on that machine is another
problem we were talking about in that
same field trip we are told that there
was a time whereby there is a machine
the government bought a machine that
they had to send some staff members of
that research institute through India to
go and learn how to operate that machine
so when those people they just go for
two weeks or three weeks those two or
three weeks is not even enough to
understand fully the work abilities the
functionalities of the machines so when
they come back they're just okay and
then the machines will just go and it
just be there
no not used so these kind of uh
situation abounds in a lot of countries
in Africa so that's the problem that we
are having although there are solutions
to that right now regarding training
with the use of this virtual training
and we are still going to get to that as
to what covid-19 one of the benefits of
covid-19 to Africa so government
intervention is still very low uh the
only intervention that we have right now
regarding bioinformatics sensitization
we all know the H3 bionettes and uh we
are that's the only prominence that we
can think of that at the click of our
hand any government and these uh H3
violence is not even a government from
Africa is not an intervention from any
government now it was a foreign aid that
was meant to census Island increase the
bioinformatics uh uh sensitization in
the continent now another area whereby
the conundrum we are having as Africa is
the African biological database
there is no as we've defined what
bioinformatics is in our previous uh
slides there is need for a biological
database of African origin of African
origin uh there is uh there is an
initiative that is currently going on
that is being spearheaded by uh Dr
Ebenezer thank God uh this uh is the
initiative that is working to sequence a
lot of genomic data from Africa and
maintain this database from Africa alone
so this is an initiative that
is privately you know from concerned
individuals so it is not a government's
intervention that okay we are
commissioning this project but
individuals are coming up with that
approach and attempts to enumerate to
emulate the problem that we are
currently facing regarding uh biological
database in Africa just like I said that
those samples genomic data of African
origin is less than three percent
in the global database of course the
ncbi that we know less than three
percent testifies the huge diversity of
our flora and fauna this is a major
problem that we are having that is
against bioinformatics progressing in
Africa
now another area and that I've touched a
little bit more is the molecular biology
laboratory and expertise there is a
shortage of individuals that are experts
in molecular biological technique just
like I said we have little facility
compared to our population and yet even
if you are in enthusiastic to learn it
will cost you a fortune to learn these
molecular biological techniques even
though these techniques do not need
Rockets is not rocket science when I got
to South Korea in 2018 it uh still
stopped talking from my personal
experience in 2016 when we went to a
field trip in Nigeria so uh we were just
shown all the molecular biological
biology apparatus tools
electrophoresis yes hplc machine just
look at it because we are even scared to
touch because once we touch and
something bad happens we held
responsibilities of course the first
thing to do but this when I got to Korea
in 2018 so I discovered that all these
machines all these tools that companies
institutions such institutions are
boastful of in my country is if most of
them are present in my lab and this lab
is part of the department in my is a lab
in the department
so it's kind of buffly so all these
tools I was able to play with around
with them become experts in in operating
the PCR machine and other machines that
regarding molecular biology so I was so
surprised that these are things that are
missing back home back in Nigeria that
is curtailing that is stopping the
progress of bioinformatics in Africa and
however even though to be a
bioinformatician you do not need much
facility you do not need much
infrastructure just have a good system
have good internet and have good uh
electricity you are good to go however
we cannot take away the importance of
the molecular biology parts of
bioinformatics because that is when
you'll be dealing with the wet lab yes a
lot of analysis we are living in the era
of data explosion data ex there are lots
of data that is there to be analyzed but
still we cannot leave the parts of the
wet lab part of bioinformatics
now I would like to discuss a little bit
about the role of covid-19 in advancing
bioinformatics in Africa before uh
before covid-19 I can speak especially
for Nigeria in particular
they are
fewer Laboratories there are few we can
count maybe one or two Laboratories that
can sequence genomes
I know of some companies in Nigeria that
they will collect your sample and even
ship them out of the country to another
country in Africa to sequence and then
you get the results that is how bad the
infrastructural deficit in the continent
is especially in Nigeria but with the
Advent of covid-19 it is sad and good
deal we were able to out of the blue
develop and increase our capacity to
sequence
genomes especially of virus
of covid-19 and with their advancement
in being able to sequence viral genome
you can sequence other genomes too
that's Skyrocket that sped up the
advancement that we see in sequencing
and that is one of the benefits of Kobe
19. of course when you sequence you have
to analyze a lot of people a lot of
researchers I know of different uh
research institutes privately owned that
are coming up with research that is
focused majorly on analyzing covid-19
in itself either as a vaccine or a drug
candidate there is a Alex Biogen that is
doing wonderful well in that aspect that
is a genomic and lots of privately owned
uh companies that are doing that aspect
I know uh Pine biotech and omics logic
are also doing amazing in that area of a
drug Discovery so this has led to
development of a kubernetes research and
we are able to have a lot of researchers
interested in sequencing and analyzing
and then we are having a lot of African
samples samples from African origin
being deposited on the database and also
apart from covid-19 it has also led to
the development of the metagenomics
aspects of bioinformatics now this is
just to show us some of the uh the data
regarding covid-19 in Africa now we can
see
that there is a huge gap between testing
that has been reported by who and all
the uh
International Organization on the death
of testing facility to determine the
actual covid-19 cases in Africa
according to this data by worldometer it
says that in Africa we have more than 12
million cases that have resulted in more
than 200 000 dead and about 12 million
also recovered from covet 19. yes this
is little compared to the population
that Africa has the testing capacity is
a problem that we've not been able to
determine
the exact covid-19 incident in Africa
however
luckily for us we do not have a huge
death rate to have warranted us to be a
graveyard so for Africa to be a
graveyard that's another area of
research that I am interested in that
I'm passionate about that I've been
talking about in different uh speaking
engagements that I've been talking about
that why is it that Africa do not have
uh yes we have covid-19 infection but
our death rate is lower much more lower
compared to other parts of the world and
also you have two more minutes sir wow
so let me speed up so this I spoke spoke
about the covid-19 uh vaccine
development with the help of uh
bioinformatics uh what are the African
names Africa has a high burden of
infectious diseases such as malaria HIV
and tuberculosis and these diseases we
have the potential to use bioinformatics
ethics especially in genomic studies to
address these problems that was what led
to us writing the correspondence to
Nature that got published last year uh
almost a year now only African age
mobile information for population
studies and these as uh instituted a lot
of different research on how do we
increase bioinformaticians in Africa and
one of the problems we'll be having
regarding bioinformatics in Africa is
that okay we are still I'm still going
to talk a little bit before my time runs
up now the essentiality of
bioinformatics in Africa Africa has a
lot of uh diversity in Flora and Fauna
but this has not been worked on we've
not exploited our diversity to the
maximum limit the world is now moving to
Precision medicine to treat a lot of and
to characterize particular diseases and
then prefer profiling solutions to them
require the skills of bioinformatics
bioinformatics and we need that in our
continent to be able to move with the
world and one of the problems one of the
challenges is that there is a lack of
trading programs and I'm sure that is
what omic's logic is trying to do and
also we from Noble can match we are also
improving the training the amount of
training that will be conducting in
Africa so regarding bioinformatics and
also this led us to writing another
paper on African genomic epidemiologists
so there is Need for training there is a
particular research that was done a
popular paper that was published or uh
sorry does carried out by the World Bank
that says there is need to in Africa to
carry out more than 170 million
trainings and covid-19 has enabled us to
move from the class to the virtual world
that we have in uh this uh session I've
talked a little bit about infrastructure
and one of the problems we have in
Africa is the brain drain a lot of
researchers from Africa are moving from
Africa to other parts of the world to
also further their research I've spoke
about African society of bioinformatics
and computational biology this uh also
uh Institute organizations that are
championing the course of by informatics
in Africa but it is not enough yet due
to our population so what are we doing
to complement that effort in by by Noble
came back we also have genomics
introductory course not enough yeah but
it's free we have also conducted from
2020 we've been doing that but it's not
enough to curtail or to sensitize but we
are trying our best and we've
collaborated with International
institutions like embl and also
researchers from across the world to
train African researchers and we've done
this different aspects of bioinformatics
free of charge and yet we are having a
lot of people joining and joining so far
our goal is to train one million by
informaticians in Africa but before the
end of the year and we've been doing
that as seriously from our personal
money this last job January and February
we conducted the bioinformatics store
across four con four universities in
Nigeria and it has been attended by
participants from 10 different
universities as well as different
research institutes and
centers in Nigeria and these was from
our training in Fountain University in
oshogbo we also had a stop at University
of ilorin where we trained a lot of
people we also had to stop in Babcock
University
and it was very very fruitful we also
had a stop at Crescent University in
abeokuta even the vice Chancellor was in
attendance and also improved
uploaded our efforts so thank you so
much for having me it's been a wonderful
time it's been a wonderful session with
you so thank you so much
[Music]
yeah thank you so much for that
presentation I believe that some persons
will be having some questions and I
would love them to actually
share that real quick yeah I believe we
can all hear me can we all hear me
yes we can hear you
all right thank you so much for that I
at this point I would love people
Everyone that actually have a question
to go to the chart and and uh
and write the questions
uh I want you to go to this to the chat
and write the question yeah because it's
quite it's quite interesting I would
also want uh maybe Dr de Conley or
sugar we to make me cool so I can share
my screen
um that's quite quite important
I believe our next speaker is actually
on ground
uh she would be speaking in a bit I will
be sharing a screen
um a slide
um
will be sharing a slide
uh
all right
I believe my screen is visible now right
yes yes it is
yeah so thank you so much for for those
lovely input I want everyone to
understand that Africa is progressing
and uh
and there is a lot of private and public
um individuals and uh organizations that
are doing their best to make sure that
Africa goes forward not only is H3
bounded that that got their funded from
NHS and uh we have very very brilliant
point that
find it for us I mean it was by ashro
vaccola and it's quiet it's quite it was
quite a lovely one at this point I would
love to bring up a reputable
Professor president of doctor for Luke
uh we should associate professor in the
department of animal production at the
University of Illinois as she's a
registered animal scientist a research
centers on qualitative molecular
Evolution genomic diversity uh studying
genetic diversity performance and
conception of Engineers or three other
domestic animal issues in Nigeria using
quantitative and functional genomic
approach
um doctor you there
can you hear
me I'm here
can you hear me yeah we can hear you I
will be sharing your screen in a bit and
um we can get started yeah over to you
man
okay
um good evening everybody I hope you can
hear
him yes we can hear you okay thank you
very much
um
I'm delighted to be here this evening to
present uh the topic given to me and
that is the role of bioinformatics in
livestock Improvement
have been properly introduced by Dr
alabetutu thank you sir
all right
I'm going to start my presentation by
presenting what it is in my hotline
I have what
um
is contained in the introduction
where I discussed by informatics and
research and by informatics the process
of bioinformatics I won't stay long on
this because it has been stated by the
last presenter
then the kid of my topic that is by
informatics application in livestock
production
and I mentioned genomics and
proteinumics although there are other
aspects of homies then gene expression
genomic diversity which is my area
and I moved to my conclusion and
recommendation whereby I State the
function of bioinformatics in livestock
world
all right
let's get to the business
bioinformatics I won't go into details
of the scientific definition
but I want to Define it in a way
that a livestock producer we like
I'm going to call it a tools or tools
that unlock the hidden treasure for
Optimum production in livestock
and at the end of the day
it gives good life for man because when
you have quality products on your table
you will be happy and you will feel good
right
defining bioinformatics
like the past uh speaker just said it's
like
solving biological problems
in terms of the DNA the hairs amino acid
sequence and other related information
through mathematics statistics and
computer science
you need to ha you need to be found in
these three aspects mathematics
statistics computer science before you
can be a good bar informatician
and if you're a goodbye informatician
and you are maybe a molecular scientist
or an animal production is it will
definitely help in providing information
for the masses and for researchers that
they can use in improving livestock
correct
scientific research and bioinformatics
without
um research the economy by informatics
and by informatics actually
is something that provide information at
the end of every scientific research as
we all know research starts from having
an idea you have to you know put down
your proposal him objective
justification budget then you move to
materials and Method and at one corner
you are providing information which you
get either through the internet whereby
you write your introduction spiritual
review you gather your results for
presentation but for how this to be
meaningful and for you to communicate
with the world what you are doing
if it is a molecular science research or
other scientific research you need to do
data analysis and under data analysis
you you can either use statistics or bad
informatics in our own case if it is
phenotypic parameter or quantitative
aspect of study we use statistics but
when it's getting to wet lab molecular
studies we have to use by informatics to
be to be able to present to the world
what we are actually doing in the
laboratory all right
I don't want to go into the contribution
to livestock Improvement without talking
about omics
um is omics data that makes
bioinformaticians to be prominent
without a mixed data what we buy
information be doing
by informatics is the key to unlock all
omi's data
genome means proteinomics
metabolomics transportal means glycomies
lipidomics
data things think about informatics okay
all right
bioinformatics entails
revelation of the Unseen
because if you are teaching a class it
might look abstract
to students but by the time you use the
tools any of the tool of bioinformatics
you will be able to present to the
student or to the world what you are
actually imagine or what you are saying
you cannot see
and it does this by creating advancement
of database algorithms computational and
statistical techniques
Theory to solve problem arising from
management and Analysis or biological
data
through your careful planning careful
procedural planning and execution
all right
foreign
Ty analysis
it's
a challenge in Africa and in Nigeria
especially for example I was just
getting ready for this seminar and I was
you know I was almost ready I got enough
data on my laptop to come back to mobile
data Mobile store Sports and use my
laptop my laptop just went off it wasn't
connecting with any network so there is
a kind of a problem and many of us have
been in and out of this seminar because
of network religion I have to be moving
from one spot of my house to be ordered
to see where I can actually have each
free discussion on that information
so this is a big challenge in developing
what
most of the things that balvamatics
needs Bible romantic need good network
with strong bad bandwidth good computer
with good speed
it needs data time maximum concentration
on behalf of bioinformatician you need
to be patient then resilient you need
not to give up easily then you need to
be determined that you're going to get
results
but we have big problem here a lot of
students they don't have the capacity to
buy data there was one that I registered
maybe 10 of my students organized by H3
I've been buying it none of all of them
drop off I asked them why they told me
they don't have money for data so this
is a big challenge in Africa and uh it's
something that is affecting us in
livestock and production as well
especially the molecular scientists and
the bio information
all right
what are the tools that we use in buying
format like I said computer and internet
simple
and other software that we use in
bioinformatics require computer
from blast to
analysis of sequence to
um
sequence alignments editing Gene editing
and other you need computer you need
strong internet so these two things are
the basic things there was one
particular uh training organized for
Nigeria free of charge they asked us to
write the capacity of our computer they
asked us to write whether we have
Internet facility whether I will be able
to complete the course these are very
key things that a bioinformaticians need
to be able to contribute meaningfully to
animal production
next all right
all right
we use bioinformatics tools in
lifestyle production
by we use it to generate information we
use it to mine we use it to retrieve we
use it to analyze so when you handle the
tools you can generate a lot of data or
information from it you can mine as in
search for a lot of things then you can
retrieve then you can analyze from it
all right
what are the bioinformatic websites that
we use
well I would like to kind of saying if
you want to be a bioinformatician you
must be able to solve the web very well
and I like a comic actor that that like
you know webs LinkedIn web solving and
that's Spider-Man you could see me
putting Spiderman on my screen and you
should be able to sit down and search
the web very well for what you are
looking for so that you'll be able to
make meaningful contribution at the end
of the day
which
what the website that you can use are
you can use the NCB hi the gym bag the
uni Gene embl ebi Swiss
protection all these are websites that
we have used in one way or the other in
livestock equipment all right
all right
bioinformatics application in livestock
production
yeah in livestock production
we use bioinformatics for biological
data organization it give us access to
information modification of information
medical and health information diversity
information evolutionary information
phylogenetic analysis in major research
efforts such as sequence alignment Gene
finding genome assembly drug design drug
Discovery protein structure prediction
and Alignment prediction of gene
expression gene expression itself
protein protein interaction metabolic
pathway genome-wide Association studies
and the modeling of evolution all these
we have a lot of research reports that
people have done and they possibly
contributed to livestock improvement
from the lab to the computer of a buying
from artificial then to the field
whereby the farmer can make use of it
and it's a contribute possessively to
livestock improvements
all right
in livestock production
I said I want to talk about genomics
genomics has a contributed positively
I'm talking about genomics now go back
to genomics like that I have problems
with my computer okay yeah now genomics
has helped in sequencing of cartoon
buffalo Pig sheep goats coming and
poetry all genome sequence of this
animal ancestry prediction has helped in
accessory prediction there are AIDS
selective breeding conservation of
extinct animal species improvements of
animals health and products
understanding genetic diversity and
selection of desirable traits for
livestock Optimum production
to Capital it has done something to the
environment it has helped in sequencing
of microbial genome that has ceased in
reduction of greenhouse gas thus
contributing to stability of global
climate change
as livestock are the major impact tools
of climate change in
the world all right
all right
for the protonomics
autonomics have helped results have
helped in increasing of increasing
livestock production to give animal
protein and ensuring that this animal
protein our high quantity
well characterize the authentic they are
safe for consumption
that it has helped in detection of
microbial problems in animal protein and
it ensure quality that gets to the
consumer
proteinomics also has helped the
industry by transformation of the
industry and detection of fraud it
serves as an high to see whether protein
manufacturing and processing indoor
industry are into fraud and such
companies involved even they will get it
whereby we'll be using all these tools
to do all these things and produce
quality products for our people all
right
all right
for gene expression in livestock
it has helped
tools such as our process such as
microarrays ESD s-a-g-e tax sequency
mpsa's RNA sake uh various application
of Multiplex Institute hybridization and
through high high throughput gene
expression measurements of hair Marine
level with multiple new techniques as
reviews in the htge have all helped in
livestock improvements
all right
what have we done in my molecular
Evolution and genomic diversity units
well what tools do we use
we have used tools such as segment Pro
of less charging
version
7.1.0 we have DNA star we have used DNA
XP mega version
6.06 we have used Harley Queen all these
two have helped us to contribute
positively to a lot of information about
genomic diversity in poultry species in
Nigeria
all right
we have also used
um
to view our sequence most of the time we
use Java View and um
I can remember a particular time I was
teaching in the class I taught my
students in the classification
polymorphism and all sorts of things
like that so it's now got a stage that
they didn't really get what I was saying
and I was like okay don't worry when
next time Dream by informatics analysis
and I want to view a sequence I will
call you to come and you know have a
look at it I invited my student when I
was after you know putting the the
sequence into jazz View and you know for
them to see the polymorphism and the
differences between the processor and
the the main sequence and I was telling
them look at this if you check this you
will see that it's different from it's
supposed to be C you now have it not
have instead of c and this is part of
what I'm talking about that this animal
is different from this animal and this
is what makes it uh look like as if
something is as happened to the animal
and this is what give them the
differences they were like wow so is
this what mutation is all about is this
what it teeth oh I can see the
differences I can see the inside of the
sequence we have a 70 ma would this be
deletion would it be in fraction will it
be you know Omission or something like
that and they have better understanding
of mutation so this all these tools like
I said one of my students now make a
comment Mark is searching for the
unknown I mean for the sin I mean
looking for the Unseen and now I can see
it and I'll say yes but informatics can
make you to see the Unseen so it has
actually helped us in lifestyle
production to see the understanding um
most of the time
all right
we have also used tools like
um cluster hole and cluster W2 to
construct our phylogenic tree tree and
you know understand the relationship
whether it's a monophyletic leader of uh
or or if not in the animal between our
both the species of birds that we are
studying the kind of relationship that
exists uh between them we have used this
tool to study it and we either put all
our sequences on cluster or cluster W
and generate relationship for more
explanation and to provide information
for the researchers
all right
now some of our findings uh we have
reported genetic diversity and
population structure of musculinity dog
in Nigeria and my name is and we have
also reported Association of ncya
variation
um plumage color diversity of Nigerian
domestic Beijing Columbia Libya
domestica
we discovered that genetic markers such
as nuclear DNA cyp2u1 and ncdna setup
will be reviewed two groups in Nigeria
Muscovy dog population and also MC
Warehouse sniffs our c2060
g253a and a520g they were informative in
Nigerian pidgin and the Snips were
assigned to seven hypnotypes and two
after type reports in all diplomiage
types
all right
now the our findings have been reported
in reputable journals and we have been
able to contribute to knowledge from uh
this study and other studies like that
but I just
pick these two because of time our
Studies have shown that there's no
genetic differentiation between and
within Nigerian Muscovy dog human
activity share population structure of
Nigerian Muscovy dog and it shape it is
shape it because people that they give
them out as gift people travel from one
place to the other and they carry their
animals alone
um our study also revealed the
suitability of DNA cyp to u1g and it's
provide insight into the relation in
anything
color diversity Association of Nigerian
domestic pigeon all right
now my conclusions and recommendations
there are other aspects of livestock
that researchers in Nigeria or Africa
needs to continuously especially
molecular scientists in Nigeria need to
continuously be using bioinformatics
tools from their web wet lab they should
use the tool to generate information
that will be useful
and improves our animal further
biographics to in livestock research has
provided more information on DNA
sequences
genomes Gene variation Gene regulation
gene expression and mutation
you have to embrace obix and by
informatics research to understand
livestock
then you have to do omits and
bioinformatic research to mix livestock
production better all right
all right
use of bioinformatics for lifestyle
improvements can be true analysis of
biological data Gene structure protein
structure gene expression Gene
regulation and Gene variation
by informatics makes life talk
production production easier and better
all right
the use of bioinformatics in livestock
research has been useful in prediction
of
Gene structure and function protein
structure and function Gene regulation
Network simulation of the environment
and you have to make your livestock
happier and you will get quality and
quantitative protein for construction
from them which will make life easier
for people
all right
use of bioinismatic about informatics
as being of great importance in
detection of Gene regulation Network
simulation of the environments mapping
and aligning of DNA sequences and
protein sequence
and when you use all these things you're
going to produce livestock that have fit
and viable all right
as a scientist
as a molecular scientist or west lab
scientist
I want to stay today that you have to be
a buy informatician and when you are
buying from a teacher you're going to be
happy you will stay informed you will
keep informed you'll be a Model A
solution provider you'll be
knowledgeable you can make money and you
get busy all the time then you provide
scientific information you'll be a star
and you'll be an oracle you know why I
have to put another quiz in Africa is if
you don't if you want to see the own
thing you consult an oracle then Europe
will tell you that this is what's going
to happen but this is how it's going to
be so there is even a you know there was
a time a hero and you learn more about
computer and how to use Oracle and I was
very happy at the end of the day so as a
informatician you just be like an oracle
because people to provide solutions to
most of the informations or things that
are happening in the world
no
my recommendation
uh creating Awareness on what makes
research and bioinformatics Analysis in
whole African University and Research
Institute is very very important it's
Germaine it's something that we need to
do we have to think by informatics all
the time we have to keep creating an
awareness that people should engage in
bioinformatics for not only livestock
production impact in food production and
in everything that we make life easier
for everyone for the Youth I want to
encourage them that they need to be a
star in what makes and bioinformatics
study you still have plenty of time you
see I have a lot of things to do that
will make you to contribution legally to
Lifestyle production and other aspects
you are whether you are in medical
student whether you are anywhere you
have that uses a whole mix and
bioinformatics be engaged and try to
know more about it for the adults I want
to encourage you that age is not a
barrier you can start today once once
you are determined I started buying from
ethics at the age of 45 or for this 44
45 and I was the youngest in my class
all the time and when when I started
with uh this my second year training was
with the 83 uh baronet I used to write
notes and they'll be looking I mean you
are writing notes that I was thought to
write it and they and I thank God today
that you know I I can say that I've used
a lot of the tools and I understand them
so age is not a barrier in a
bioinformatics study also livestock
biological data in Africa needs to be
upgraded to omits and by informatic
level for Optimum production and
profession of adequate protein for the
teaming population which is because all
form of omics contributed to lives of
production and you can't have any of the
old mix data without using
bioinformatics to
when I started I thought I'm just going
to be a molecular biologist I just have
biological data then I discovered that I
have to be paying heavily to do my
informatics analysis I say ah then I
need to go back to class so I had to go
back I have to sit with them most of
them the first time in Spain when I was
in Spain and they gathered us together
and that we should come and have a
lecture on by informatics we should open
our computer my computer doesn't have
you know the speed and the capacity I
start with a very young fellow she was
very kind to me and she put me through
so we need to keep on doing this so that
a lot of people can have you know um the
knowledge of informatics and they can
impact you to the younger generation
so to this I've come to the end of my
discussion I thank everyone for
listening why I wait for questions and
contribution thank you very much
these are my references thank you very
much
thank you for listening
wow thank you so much for for those they
are quite on point
um
as a population geneticist myself was
quite it was quite interesting to see
how that uh the same tools I used I use
for my own research are also the same
tools that you use for your own research
and and it's quite interesting and
enlightening to actually see that I
uh thank you so much
um Dr Professor for Lucas yeah for that
it was quite interesting and I want to
to uh and join
us to to get ready and get set
um because another section will be
coming on now and please if you have any
questions feel free to write the
questions down in the group and we
will be throwing the questions out
um all right so that's uh doctor
uh should I owe you again for you I
believe we can all see my screen right
I believe you can host in my screen okay
yes we can see it
okay
all right so um
um we have met our our speakers and uh
uh permit me to mention that uh we'll be
having a panel session right now and as
part of this panel session I'm convinced
that our panelists uh will be doing
Justice to the discourse around
bioinformatics education training and
research in Africa
um
uh
uh many African countries just like
Nigeria are also facing the same issues
that
that uh
that Nigerian also face and I must
actually say that because we engage
um universities from Ghana from Cameroon
from yaunde and Co and we we know that
we are all in this together so Africa is
quite a place to be in engaging some of
these subject matters we have made our
our several
um
the mental several uh participants I met
Ashraf
um we've made a
uh Dr for Luke uh we have not made one
of our last finalists uh in the
simulator I believe this is is around
now uh Dr Abel Aziza and Jeremiah your
answer
section is about to start
hello doctor are you there
yes I responded thank you very much I'm
happy to be with you all right thank you
so much sir uh let me just introduce him
shortly he's a senior lecturer and
medical biologist at the legal State
University Department of microbiology we
need to research on influence and other
respirative track viruses
from Lagos State universities PhD from
University of Lagos he has been trained
by the Reference Laboratory at The
usenberg Institute of Health and and the
international Society of influenza
another respiratory viruses he has
conducted groundbreaking research in on
influenza and other viral infections and
presented papers in diverse countries uh
one numerous award and is a member of
several professional societies so Dr um
and Jerry uh you're welcome again I so
lovely to have you here
um we also have another panelists uh
which is the president of our program
director we've actually met him I have
spoken to us at the beginning I I would
love to say that is such a wonderful
person to work with he's had a modern 17
years combined experience and cut across
our public and private dynastic practice
practices and so on is is a data
um that are enthusiasts such as myself
and uh I would be asking some some very
very typical questions so I would love
all of our panelists to make ready
themselves uh uh Dr ashram
Dr adekunle doctor and during I believe
we are ready and set so real quick uh to
start the question to start a question
I would love to begin by saying that
Africa is a home for some of the most
diverse and biologically Rich regions in
the world however many African countries
are facing significantly challenging
Health Care in agriculture and an
Environmental Management bioinformatics
like we are there today and play a very
crucial role in addressing these
challenges by enabling researchers to
make sense of complex biological data
developing
um Innovative solution
yeah we've also had uh and since so far
the biological bioinformatics is rapidly
growing you uh it combines a lot of
these different different
um Fields uh for us to analyze and to
interpret biological data and becoming a
very very important
an essential for researchers in the Life
Science and it it allows also process
and analyze large amount of data
efficiently but
in Africa
uh the need for bioinformatics education
is particularly acute it's particularly
accurate so I would love to throw the
first question to uh Dr Andrew in your
opinion
uh the need for
for bioinformatics education in Africa
is urgent so uh can you actually share
from your own opinion uh seeing that
you've actually
um
you are you you are you are
professionally uh experienced with
different continents uh what will you
say in the current state of mathematic
education training and research in
Africa
yeah thank you very much can you hear me
and can you see my face
yeah we can hear you sir
okay so I think I must uh commend you
and to also appreciate your company
uh as per what you guys are doing in
Africa permit me to also appreciate the
previous speakers
especially the last one
our associate professor Dr foluke from
the University of Illinois
so to start with you did mention in
about the importance of bioinformatics
to
that we've gone beyond that now
and that the entire world is now looking
at uh the application of bioinformatics
at one else
you know we had a global uh Congress at
the world one else
conference in Singapore literally you
know last year where a lot of things you
know were said and now what's the whole
world the world Organization for Animal
Health the world Organization for Animal
Health The Who The World Health
Organization you know the United Nations
Environmental Protection Agency unit and
several other International bodies what
they are all looking at now is they
study that has to do with
I think I think Dr Andrew is breaking
now
I think Dr and Jeremy is very kicking
all right I think I will have to call on
doctor for locate
the environment
and I can also tell you hello can you
hear me
yeah we are fully now okay I said with a
lot of effort so far in the 1970s in
1980s about nucleic acid about protein
you know their analysis and with the
coinage of the world or by informatics
in 1989 by Daniel you know masses that
we can also talk about the first
sequencing of the hemophilus influenza
microbial entity you know in 1995 that
is the first genomic sequencing of any
microbial entity you know to also talk
about the 2001 woman genomic you know
first publication you know and to now
it's down to Africa a lot of things are
currently been done and I can tell you
for free that Africa is also you know
putting oh our best as far as by
informatics you know it's all about it's
just that we need to to do more you know
as it got bioinformatics in the entire
continent but I can tell you that we are
not going bad you know we've picked up
you know before now we've been slow we
do not know what bioinformatics is all
about but I can tell you gladly that now
in Africa in our speech and we are
gradually coming into you know by
informatics and what uh bioinformatics
is all about so that is the introduction
over to you
all right thank you so much sir uh let
me call on Dr uh for Lucas straight away
um so uh from your whole face and
experience with with lecturing uh now
talking about bioinformatics education
in the University system in Africa uh
what will you will you say the
experience is
um
is it actually
is at the University system are they
adopting it or it's actually an
independent race yeah so that's the
question to you Doctor okay thank you
very much
that's the question the question is
um
is in two ways in some University
they've taken it up and they've added it
to their cost system whereby you know a
student of uh biotechnology molecular
science will be taught basic um topics
in bioinformatics but in most
universities
even my universities needs an individual
race like uh the first doctor that spoke
said he came to train some people in the
University of Illinois I'm sure maybe
this is their supervisor their organized
I don't think it's used the university
that organized this for for the students
so it's an individual is in my whole
case it was an individualist and when I
was spending money to actually live
quantitative you know aspects all these
um diet manipulation and other things
and face molecular and biographic
Analysis I have to sponsor myself you
know train myself and pay for it so in a
more
all right I think we are we're losing Dr
fuluke there
yeah but the message is quite reached
um she's saying that it's more like a
every University
put it in the court system from the
basic of bioinformatics to the Regiment
of biomatics and everything thank you
very much all right thank you so much I
will be going to the next question and I
will be calling on on Dr Ashraf um
uh Dr Ashraf you are not presently in in
uh in in Nigeria or in Africa I suppose
or are you I would love to to ask
okay sorry did you say yes or no I'm not
in Africa all right so the the question
I would love to to ask ask from you now
is kind of in comparison uh and that is
actually about from your own perspective
uh research-wise uh how do you think
educational uh institutions in Africa
how do you think I think they're using
utilizing by informatics
um
and improving
how do you think
um educational institution in Africa are
utilizing by informatics in in improving
the quality of of their teaching and
learning now I'm not talking about
research I'm talking about teaching and
learning uh in in in in the continent
because there is one thing to teach
mathematics there's also another thing
to actually learn about informatics you
actually think that the education system
in Nigeria are utilizing uh our
informatics system itself to actually
teach yeah
um thank you for the beautiful question
uh in my interactions so far it's a lot
of researchers from Africa before I
double down to Nigeria I feel that uh
there are there is especially in
countries like uh Kenya
uh Tanzania
Uganda
and of course South Africa uh these are
countries that are competing with
Nigeria in terms of
bioinformatics teaching and even in its
research so I can say categorically that
Morocco Egypt these are also countries
that can also be included on that map so
of course Nigeria South Africa
Uganda Kenya Tanzania Egypt those are
the countries that are at the Forefront
of biplomatics teaching so in terms of
teaching in Nigeria I think
a lot of people a lot of lecturers in
this case
they can teach they have the ability to
teach because one thing that we are very
good at in Nigeria is that theoretical
aspect of things and that is what makes
uh bioinformatics easy however a lot of
people do not understand the rudiments I
think that is what makes it difficult to
to understand regarding bioinformatics
so about teaching
from from the researcher that I've been
meeting so far the they are still a
large a huge gap in terms of that
ability to teach because there is an
Arabic saying that says that
you thought you cannot give what you do
not have so because right now my major
Focus as you can see during my
presentation was my targets our Target
at nobody might was to Target the uh the
teacher the teachers themselves the the
lecturers because once we've been able
to port to the lecturers they'll be able
to spread it to the teach to the to the
students and right now to allude to what
uh professor uhluka said regarding the
uh bioinformatics in the universities I
heard when I was in Nigeria especially
uh at Babcock and Christian University
and I later confirmed from lecturers
from phone to University and that of
unilory that they've the nuc has already
added bioinformatics as a core course as
part of the I think CC Max or something
I forgot I didn't get the is it
curriculum so the national Nigeria
University commission has already added
bioinformatics so the teaching like it's
it's a caucus now bioinformatics now
part of being is must be taught as part
of the causes to be taught in Nigeria so
it's a progress but regarding the
present teaching ability I think it's
still very very low from what I have
seen so far compared to other countries
in Africa and also in other parts of the
world all right thank you so much for
for that Summit I would love to call on
uh Dr dekula now uh I would love you to
speak to your own experience firsthand
as a lecturer your experience was hand
as someone that has worked with uh with
omics with it with the omics logic team
your first ad experience as someone that
has worked work with the cold playground
the five facility office and experience
as someone that has actually inter I
mean interacted with with the omics
logic learning platform uh what do you
think what do you think the the I mean
by informatics education and teaching
strategy what do you think they can do
better I mean
and learning strategy what do you think
they can actually do better in the in
the Nigerian teaching um or or in the
African teaching
um environment
you are muted please
okay great yeah
thank you for that question I want to
appreciate all other speakers and their
thoughts on this question
um in my own opinion
um from experience I've seen
um
um that um before now before the Advent
of the system us which I'm going to
speak a little more into
um you notice that it has been an
individual risk personally by
individuals from institutions and for
some very few institutional institutions
here in Nigeria we have seen
um some level of adoption at either
departmental level or faculty level
maybe one or two institutions that that
is actually embracing by informatics at
the University level most importantly
they are the private institutions and
for some of the universities we've
attempted to work with uh we've seen
different
um you know reactions from the from the
stake include us I can share that and
there are some instances where the
students will feel seasoned since it is
not part of our Core Curriculum then
they see it as an extra load of work for
them
um whereas there are some students who I
mean having the opportunity and getting
to use or learn when informatics get
excited and they want to actually go on
deeper and deeper you know to learn by
informatics so but however I'm happy
with the new
um Core Curriculum
um you know and minimum academic
standards known as CC mass by the
National University commission okay and
um with what they are doing they are
actually providing 70 percent of what
should be taught giving about 30 percent
um of that um curriculum to universities
to develop and I think this is where I
will actually be calling them you know
researchers faculties and you know
University City management to actually
use the opportunity to build and
inculcate your informatics into their
educational
um you know curriculum because
um these the uni the nuc is actually
expecting institutions to build 30
percent of that
um curriculum
um Dr ashram mentioned that um so
bioinformatics have been co-cated yes
but then when you look at these key sets
of individuals expected to teach these
bioinformatics then you know that we are
up against a a I mean we are climbing
the an uphill okay but nonetheless it's
a good beginning and it's a good one
um the nuc is now giving a framework to
Allowed by informatics to be inculcated
and included in the curriculum knowing
or hoping that most of our institutions
are University management will now begin
to invest in this training capacities
and um I mean particularly working with
International
um platforms and pull up operations that
will help scale up the the train of
capacities both for lecturers and you
know researchers within the university
and also students to be able to take up
by informatics
um you know education in within our
system so for me it's um we are at a
Tipping Point here in Nigeria and I'm
happy to hear that most institutions
across or organizations across African
continents are actually loading and
appreciating the systems December
Nigeria and so we hope that they also
follow that um you know pace and that
could perhaps you know provide a good a
a a good Tipping Point it means a means
of scaling at the more broad
perspective informatics into our
Education and Research in in Africa
yeah thank you so much I would love to
to weigh something in vehicle on Dr
Nigerian in the beat uh to talk about uh
scientific community in Africa so I
would I would just love to just had one
or two things as a bioinformatician
myself I would love to say that
the know-how
of a bioinformatics uh for of a
bioinformatician user they buy
informatician consultant of a uh of a
bioinformatics engineer and the other
aspect actually differs from one another
I believe that
um that the universities are kind of
breeding about informatics uh users
people actually knows how to use it they
are not actually I mean they're living
out of other aspects of it so we should
be careful as as Educators to deliver
the other aspects it's not so good when
you when you take people out to use an
application and they don't in the future
knows how know how to make the
application to reduce the application to
to become by informatics programmers I
mean to be able to to produce what you
really really want many of these aspects
are being dominated by by Specialists
from other fields who actually do not
know the basics of what you are trying
to get so you actually have to explain
this what your your aims are and in the
long run
um
in the long run uh time will actually go
so uh there's actually a need and a call
for for even these these these Educators
to to start digging out I mean to to to
start becoming multi-disciplinary that's
one the secondly speaking to our
code.omexlogic.com there you don't need
to actually know how to code but you can
just go there and look at those codes
and start building your own
you need to start building your own old
blocks yeah that's a that's an advice I
would love to give to give everyone
actually go out and start building your
own food database so that so that in any
case you would be able to to not be
thrown uh off board or off Target
because
um because someone is mentioning
something python someone is mentioning
something on on our code and so on and
and it will not actually ship you off
your feet because you understand what
what the basics are we are power
biologists we have very very good grabs
for science so at that point I'm going
to stop and the next question will go to
Dr and Jerry
I have actually noticed that uh Dr
abdulaziz enjoying uh is quite a
community
uh it's a scientific Community person uh
several several times before I reached
out to him I've seen a lot of programs
we actually anchored as as always I
actually joined I actually did not tell
him I did not mention to him that uh I
was already I was part of some of the
the the the the communities that that
they actually hosted yeah and yeah it
was a moderator for for some of these
this this uh this this community yeah
that's actually because I'm also a part
of the scientific community and I'm a
part of a lot of scientific community so
Dr Andrew that's actually a shocker for
you
yeah but so did
good fault
what step do you think can be taken to
full size vibrant by informatics in
Africa and you can just you can take it
to Africa you can take it it's available
to Nigeria you can still take it to a
lower level Southwest
okay uh thank you very much so that
means I'm going to charge you you know
for joining the
the programs you know without orange so
thank you that's a beautiful one
to start with let me just correct an
impression you know I appreciate the
earlier speakers that it is true that we
now have the system as in fact we just
wrap up that of my departments and we
are now about submitting to the faculty
and I happen to be one of the you know
experts that were selected to you know
be part of the committee that wrote the
systems for my department but I want to
add to it that even if before the Advent
of the system as
the bioinformatics has always been there
in our curriculum you know has given to
us by nuc that is the National
University commission but unfortunately
the challenge has been raised by some of
the earlier you know speakers that we do
not have enough resource persons
to you know gloss over or to take the
the the course you know itself you know
it is part of courses but you find out
that uh lecturers in the department will
just keep that uh synopsis that part of
the you know of the course content
without you know going over the buy
informatics and recently when we started
having some of the colleagues you know
we traveled abroad to acquire paging by
informatics and all of that now to come
back to what we are doing at the uh
scientific Community level or what can
be done to you know resolve some of the
challenges I can just tell you straight
away that the solution is one of the
things you guys are currently doing you
know I must salute the uh or omics you
know that is the omics logic in Africa I
know mixed logic you know generally I've
been part of the company before now
learning a lot of things from them you
know I think the team based in the US
and several other countries and to also
talk about the iomics and a logic that
is based here in Africa so you guys have
started the work already and I can tell
you a lot of other bodies the African
bioinformatic net in a network Abu net
the South African National bioinformatic
you know platform the history about it a
lot of them the Nigeria you know
bioinformatic group as well they are
already doing what's meant to be done
but the fact means that we need to do
more can we go down to the community
level can you guys now group up you know
come to each of the Departments come to
faculty you know or or call on the
scientific Community within each of the
Nigerian universities like Dr ashram
said that now is willing to partner with
some of the institutions you know to
train the you know it should be a
program of trained trainers
the experts the lecturers are the one
that will in turn take the postgraduate
students the undergraduate students can
we have more of the PhD students you
know running by informatics as a program
in all of our universities
you know that are interested can we have
been you know by informatics you know
being taught at postgraduate level can
we have Workshop you know training for
the lecturers in the biological sciences
and or computer science and mathematical
you know in physical sciences generally
can we have a platform where all of the
team can meet you know like I previously
mentioned that we have a lot of studies
to be done at one Health so like the
Advent of the coveted one night you know
the sasko V2 needed to be sequenced we
got a lot of unless parts coming on
board result
and the rest of them but can we have
more can we have a lot of Laboratories
across the entire Africa doing more
apart from the pandemic that the
government the you know the government
of Africa is willing you know the cities
and the rest of them can we do common
surveillance for viral you know
influencer embeds the Indian influenza
and Community level you know at the farm
level in the hospital settings but for
us to have all of that it means we must
do more of the training like you guys
have started already we must do more are
we willing to write more books like I
was reading I read a book you know a
publication by Oxford you know publisher
so by Bishop better on bioinformatics in
Africa can we have more books published
about bioinformatics you know can we do
my training can we do more workshops you
know and a lot of other things to be
done within the continent to ensure that
surveillance and several other
assignments can be done within the
scientific community so over to you
thank you
yeah thank you so much for for that
challenge uh you know I have actually
been enjoying this session because I I
see everyone bringing their their
expertise
to the uh discussion panel and it has
actually been a very very rich one I
would love to bring the session to a
close by asking this last question
and the last question is about is about
um
what measures do you think uh when do
you think are needed by the African
countries to to capitalize on the
potential of informatics for economic
development now can can by informatics
serve the purpose of Economic
Development EBS
um I mean knowledge of all the applied
by informations can it serve the purpose
of economic development in years because
it's actually the the the essence of the
economic importance of bioinformatics as
a subject is is the only reason why why
the nuc they they the union I mean the
the National University commission
that's why that that is the only reason
why they can add it to Columbia
University it actually means that they
have to see okay uh bioinformatics
actually
uh what measures please just have only
two sentences to make or two points to
make what measure do you think are
needed by the African countries to
capitalize the potential of
bioinformatics for economic development
I'll call on you Dr Ashraf are you there
are you there
okay yes I am can you hear me now yeah
yeah yeah please yeah now we can hear
you uh that's a very big question but uh
difficult to summarize within a few
sentences but I will try I number one
challenge I see that of course the
bioinformatics has tremendous potential
to improve the economic situation of
Africa we have that tremendous potential
but before we have make use of start
talking of the potential there is this
problem and it's a perennial problem uh
professor professor feluke has already
mentioned that and that is part of data
the data is very very very important
very slow in in major part of uh Africa
the bandwidth is very slow secondly the
good good computer system so and that is
the reality for a lot of people that we
are kind of
um sensitizing that common group of
informatics they will say they don't
have enough data if they have the
bandwidth is very slow and if they do
have the fast bandwidth yes they have
the their computer system we do not have
the capacity to carry out that
sophistication so I don't know how we
are going to do that but the tremendous
potential of band so much I was I
enjoying I love the presentation of uh
Dr Abel Aziz on uh on Dr Andre on the
efforts that have been put in place to
improve bioinformatics in Africa in and
the efforts that uh omics logic and
other private or public funded
institutions are doing but we have a
perennial problem and once we've been
able to solve that problem I can assure
you that the issue of bioinformatics in
Africa would not be at any issue any
longer so thank you so much
uh like doctor for look they said uh or
Professor for looking like a lot a lot
to call her she said every molecular
scientist
should be by informatician I I took note
of that it has it was actually
sticked with me so so I would love to
call on uh on her to say to ask the same
question what measures are just
measuring a country can take to
capitalize on inshallah
uh thank you very much dranyafe
actually
um Dr ashram have said everything but
I'm going to add that
you know by informatics we actually lead
to economic development in Africa if
the government now on their own path
have decides to start funding research
data bioinformatic base at times when
you write a proposal and it doesn't lead
to food on the table directly you hardly
get anything
you know they if they look at it as if
it's you know full of mathematics or
something like that like that that what
food does he want to contribute to the
table you might want to search for
something that will be useful in future
and you need by informatics too
researches that are tailored towards
this are towards these aspects should be
funded so that a lot of researchers will
have ability to do um molecular research
that will end up in mathematics quite a
lot of researchers cannot do molecular
research
in Nigeria we it's not only the
scientists that have been funded and a
lot of people cannot use their money to
fund research or to do research so the
government need to do this on their own
path also
the scope of research that will involve
the use of bioinformatics to should be
our objectives and him as a researcher
so we should be focused and we should
develop more of this research then the
the more bioinformaticians need to be
trained
that is true trendy trainers that Dr
adekunle said
they need to train the trainers so that
a lot of us will have more knowledge on
bioinformatics then we can train the
postgraduates today and train the
undergraduate students on bioinformatics
and to Capital which computer good data
money finances and all sort of things we
actually make bioinformatics education
to be prominent and to be embraced by
all in Africa thank you very much
uh what solution is it actually bringing
to the people for example
and and you can just link it to the
measure that is needed by by African
countries capitalize on the potential of
informatics
okay yes thank you very much um I want
to appreciate the earlier speakers
um I would also conclude with them that
it is going to really contribute to
economic development in Africa and so
what we need is to talk about measures
and these things that we need to to put
in place we talked about infrastructure
investing in infrastructure is very key
and um we need to I mean find a way to
speak more engage with our government
our representatives and you know to to
invest in infrastructure and our hope is
that most of this investment will also
not be misplaced all right we had lately
um of the of the government here in
Nigeria wanting to put internet at um
you know what's it called now airports
all right I would it would have been
more logical if we had at all our
government wants to put internet in All
Nigerian universities you can imagine I
mean the impact the effects what that
will contribute but of course the after
their
hello the universities are included too
okay great thank you for that
information all right so uh we really
need to invest so much into
infrastructure good internet not just
putting something there that cannot
download anything take for example email
University
um we have internet but I've come to
realize just like Dr Christopher
mentioned earlier on at some locations
the internet is not as good compared to
some other um you know locations also
you might have to eventually fall back
on your own personal internet
um you know
um data and all of that effort so we
really need to do much in that aspect
and um what uh to talk to speak to your
question so in omic's logic we actually
have
um the Tiba info server okay which helps
to take most of these pipelines on um
you know informatics activities
explorations of
um the researcher or the users doing
them on their local machines but rather
do them on the cloud you know server and
so that's one of the ways we think
um we need we can't be able to
contribute to
um you know that aspect of
infrastructure
um deficit and I also want to encourage
that our government or institutions look
into that we can have institution-based
um data centers and or Cloud
um services provider or Empire Computing
machine uh machines that can help
improve these bioinformatics in our
environment during fluid that the output
we you know remarkably improve the
economic potentials of our country and
lastly please there's also need to begin
to look at entrepreneurial aspects of
bioinformatics I think there is one
other aspect with which we can of course
this will involve Partnerships between
the industries and the
um you know
um the the academics okay the academic
environment but we need to also begin to
look at that as we might see more and
more um input or output or empowerment
economic empowerment from that
perspective so I think I want to eat my
mic at this point thank you very much
yeah thank you so much uh there are some
questions that are coming in I should
also ask this question I mean throw this
question to Dr and Jerry for one minute
I would love to just pass a question I'm
sorry I mean pass a a comment and a
comment says that uh okay I can see I
can see Dr Zan's hand I will call you in
a bit
um
I would love to pass a comments and the
comment is that even in developing
countries for example
um not every institution has the
opportunity to have a server for example
so what we do in a institution where I
am is that we go
and we go with with a memo with our own
institution institutional memo to
another institution that has a stronger
server they can actually do our steam
work for example I'll go there to go and
write that com we will be using your
server for these next two or three days
if they can't give us because we are
going to have an interrupted uh data
um process that will tell us that come
you can only afford to give you for one
day actually we sometimes we also pay
for the server access so about if it
goes from an institution to another
institution it's going to be subsidized
so that this actually brings and gives
us a challenge and the challenge is
cloud not just cloud computing Cloud
container making and some of this server
I mean and and serious serious about all
the same because that's actually one of
those resources that I think that Africa
needs to actually capitalize on so on
this notebook
during
um then I'll call on the unrest app then
I will also call on the program director
after so Dr Andrew yeah can you just can
you still speak to the measure that you
think that the African countries or
maybe local authorities of universities
maybe uh local government of the state
can actually take take to capitalize the
potential of bioinformatics for economic
development
okay thank you very much on that uh yes
everyone is saying the government I
quite agree that the government should
do more but the government is actually
the people
one there must be more commitment on the
part of the individual myself yourself
and everyone like you know we've been
doing we need to to do more can we do
more that's a question then number two
like it is done in other countries of
the world and that is the position of
our Union you know they ask you that
every company the private institutions
must come you know to the fall of these
on challenges somebody mentioned the
issue of slow internet you know capacity
you know of the system and all of that
the companies that are making millions
of dollars must be taxed the dangotees
the Unilever the liver borders and the
rest of them they must have a certain
percent of their uh profits you know
remitted for by informatics or fire
institution training you know or
research funding and what have you
generally to the point that you know
when we have all of that
two together we can say this is the
percentage that is going to Medical
Science that is going to accounting
going into all of that including
bioinformatics and when the people are
well trained you know we are not talking
about lecture you know it is not the
issue of the nuc bringing bioinformatics
as part of the content to be lectured in
the University but rather I should be
taken as a skill you know as part of the
skill sets to be acquired there must be
workshops there must be Hands-On you
know Technical Training so that people
acquire the basic skills and at the end
of the day they can do something
meaningful design better project that
will eventually translate into money
including vaccine production we didn't
have to produce vaccine you know doing
the you know still going you know
covered one night the monkey pox is
around us the last fever is still very
much there the Ebola in Africa and all
of you know and all of that so we need
to design vaccines for all of these
diseases so to do that people must be
are trained then they now design project
that were eventually translated into you
know money making for each of the
countries in Africa and Africa you know
as a whole and to narrow that down to
the last point you raised that oh what
can we do of course a lot of things can
be done and once we start from the issue
of training ourselves the individual you
know getting committed you know being
interested by themselves the government
cannot do all of that uh people the
scientific Community must be interested
like a lot of them have said they
trained they started training themselves
my servers were I have to start joining
different groups you know learning it
you know going abroad you know
sponsoring myself getting a little bit
you know for funders you know applying
for Grant and so at the end of the day
it is when people are willing to do it
they will not talk about the government
the private sector and all of that
coming into this you know the system to
help and at the end of the day we end up
having or people that are well trained
that would do something meaningful they
I will eventually translate into you
know money making so over to you thank
you
yeah thank you so much for that
um we are saying and we are clamoring
for bioinformatics to get into the
industry uh like the inside uh first of
all I
um
I mean these are still money money
making I mean Avenues really when you
have quality products we have
quantitative products they are still up
to Quality yeah I believe that that is
quite good I have there are two
questions before I read the two
questions I would love to call on on W
Atkin uh Azan I believe you have a
question
your hand is raised up
uh are you there yeah I'm here I'm here
all right
yeah thank you very much for the
opportunity
can you hear me yeah yeah we can hear
you yeah thank you very much for the
opportunity I want to congratulate the
organizers of this uh
program
they have done very well
and also my gratitude will also go to
the speakers as well as the members of
the panel
uh someone asked a question
what do we do to really make
bioinformatics relevance to livestock
production in Africa
I think if we want to achieve that we
need to pay attention to
animal performance recording
bioinformatics requires data and the
organism the the the mechanism for data
collection on animal performance in
Africa is still very very rudimentary
so I want us to take that along without
data we cannot make good advantage of
bioinformatics
I also need to appreciate uh Professor
solao Joe for our brilliant presentation
and I I like and advice for the adults
it's not easy to really uh fall in line
with new technologies I remember my
professors in Germany had to learn
computer at very old ages and they made
very good use of the technology so I
don't see why old lecturers in Africa
cannot also be brought online in terms
of bioinformatics
I appreciate omis logic
and I promise you as
a representative of bad technology on
Maya's Council that's Nigeria Institute
of animal science that if the chance is
giving we would like to collaborate with
uh or Miss logic as far as about
technology and especially about
informatics and other omics
are concerned so thank you very much for
giving me this opportunity
thank you
thank you so much sir we really
appreciate the feedback you've brought
and so on I believe that you can reach
us to Dr solojo and that is that yeah in
fact we we are we work together a lot
and uh the next question goes to thank
you so much
um the next question goes to
um Dr adekunle uh I believe this
question also I mean
may also be asking the same question
okay I know why I actually passed that
comment doctor
here is the question says that you've
been you you had you had training across
universities in Africa because we heard
you mentioned some of them of course
yeah but in Ghana
criteria for choosing those universities
that's one secondly
um what are your plans for other
universities in Africa especially
in Nigeria with respect to
bioinformatics training
yeah
all right thank you very much for that
question
um I believe you can hear me
yes we can hear you hello okay great so
um thank you for the question
um yes we've run some programs
particularly with um Ghana a lot of them
here in Nigeria of course yeah only that
is University of Cameroon Hyundai and
um several other institutions um like
that so um our criteria we do not have
the criteria to actually
um select an institution over the other
um it's just availability at times
um some of those collaborations come
from our programs where we have
participants who participated in our
training and then they are willing to
open that um you know Feast of
opportunity with their own institution
so with just an introduction we're able
to move on with such a partnership and
you know exchange Communications and we
end up you know carry out such a
training and equally I think I would
want to sit here on this program we are
open to collaborations we're open to
Partnerships uh you know our goal is to
just I mean create the Avenue for many
researcher students postgraduates
um undergraduate as well as researchers
faculties to have opportunity
opportunities to use these tools or have
access to these two
um these tools for for their own
researches and I'm learning or training
so um we are open for to these
collaborations but like I said most of
those
um trainings recently we have um some
collaborations opportunity coming up
with University of Port Harcourt as I
mentioned and thankfully we have one of
our alumni sorry I'm sorry alumnus from
that um you know that is a lecturer in
their University and so when the
opportunity for their resetting up their
research
um you know about Psychology Center
chemo and she reached out and so we've
been on that and on that together so
that is essentially what I've been doing
however I'd like to see
um we we look forward to seeing more and
more institutions from Africa in joining
the umiz logic platform if you come to
our platform you see a whole lot of
institutions in India in the United
States institutions universities
leveraging on the resources of uh buying
biotech of omixology for their own
training okay University of Georgia for
example as part of their training their
own postgraduates program every there is
I mean a part of the semesters where
they are students have to take some
courses on omis logic platform so why
not same thing our universities can live
average on this starting from above I'm
sorry biochemistry students back
topology students the the university can
simply allow them take these courses
others you know grade um graded
um courses that will be transferred to
their uh you know their their great
points or even us just
um programs they can see just to improve
their capacity personally so these are
the things women's logic Africa and the
prime biotech which are learning
learn.omex platform is available for and
we look forward to forging such and
Partnerships so I will end by
appreciating
um I think Professor Dr akinazan who
spoke earlier on so yes we're open to
such a collaboration with your Institute
or our association please do not mind
having your email if you can drop that
for us on the chat or perhaps you can
write us at Africa at Africa at pine.bow
so that we can take further these um
collaboration store thank you very much
all right sir uh thank you so much to
send a big thank you to everyone that
has been on our team yeah starting from
from
um
draf you've been so wonderful
uh Professor um
you've been so lovely so lovely having
you around and seeing you again
um same as you my one one of one of my
my mentors uh
uh Dr Angeles so lovely seeing you after
a very long time and I so lovely I also
I've been having uh the program director
here for mix logic Africa it's so lovely
to have been working with you for so
long you've been so lovely and wonderful
thanks so much everyone for joining us
for this session uh before I call on
on the next
uh on the next section to to take over
I'll also on I would love everyone to
earn their their camera I would love I
would love to take a screenshot
I love I would love to take a screenshot
so so if you're there you can hear me I
want you to turn on your camera I would
love to take a screenshot
yeah I don't know can you hear me yeah
thank you so much for those that are
turning on their camera I want to just
take a a general screenshot
yes
yeah yeah I can see you please just turn
on your camera I would love to just take
a screenshot real quick
yeah thank you so much thank you so much
for those wow so lovely seeing a lot of
faces yeah
can you see me please
one minute no it's not it's not turn on
wow yeah yeah yeah it's quite it's quite
okay
if you can also take a screenshot it
will be so lovely I can't I can't see
you sir
all right
a camera is it fine can you see me I
can't use
wait I I can't see Dr abilities too
all right but I will I will take a
screenshot nonetheless and I'll take a
screenshot nonetheless
I will take a screenshot nonetheless
YouTube please take a screenshot from
from where you are
thank you so much everybody I've taken a
screenshot thank you so much everybody
I'm taking a screenshot
uh I really appreciate your presence
okay and now now we can see you
okay okay
I'm sorry let's take the last screenshot
again some some some
business camera just just connected
Dr uh please some business camera I just
came on now yeah let's let's take that
screenshot again
um three
goal
all right thank you so much everybody I
so lovely to to have everyone here I
love to call on on the next section to
take over our Asian team are you there
or Asian team are you there
so thank you so much everyone that made
me quickly share my screen
questions
all right so thank you so much Dr paluke
Dr Andrew and Mr Ashraf minister at
Louis and for handling the omix logic
Africa very well and it was pretty
insightful and informative session to
learn about the various challenges and
opportunities that the session had to
explain about so uh before uh we quickly
wrap up uh today is day one of um
let me quickly give you a overview about
tomorrow's uh fashion schedule
so in day two of omics research
Symposium 2023 you will hear from other
experts from Asia Africa and USA so
first of all we will be joined by Dr
Jagdish gunla who will be discussing
about Trends in healthcare and
biotechnology Dr prasanna is OT will
help you gain valuable insights and
knowledge about how bioinformatics is
being used to shape the future of
academic and Industrial Research Miss
Anuja Mishra will also introduce the
audience to the latest guidelines and
research that are shaping the future of
medical genetics and genomics you will
also hear from Mr Emmanuel
who will share insights on latest
training and capacity building
opportunities
Miss Elizabeth will also take the
participants to the world of single cell
data sets and discover how they are
transforming our understanding of
prostate health and relief Dr Laura
Harris will introduce participants to
integrating multiomics data and
conducting meta-analysis you will also
hear about the price distribution
ceremony from today's sports reputation
competition
you will learn about bioinformatics
education and groundbreaking work that
is done at home exporship America you
will also learn about the present status
of data science and bioinformatics in
Louisiana and ideated States from Dr Gus
casulis Dr Jamie Souza will also help
you delve into the world of Next
Generation sequencing and its
application in the study of animals
thank you
so we look forward you all to the rest
of this Symposium and exciting
discussions and insight that are yet to
come so thank you everyone for
participation and contribution and we
hope that the Symposium will lead to
further collaborations and advancements
in the field of management and data
science so see you all today too of
Symposium for 5 PM IST 6 30 am CST or at
12 30 pm
thank you everyone have a great day
thank you so much
all right thank you thank you everyone
thank you everyone
[Music]
thank you enjoy it again thank you
see you tomorrow thank you thank you
take care of yourself yes yeah thank you
so much Dr
thank you very much thank you
so much
thank you sir yeah okay
thank you